[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
there were turnarounds and upsets galore
at the sinkfield cup in saint louis sure
wins turn to inexplicable losses that
upset the standings ian nepomniacci won
a crazy back and forth game against
lavon orronian to join a three-way tie
for first wesley sew's costly blunder in
a one game gave alaresa ferrugia more
than just a win and a co-lead but also a
coveted place in pole position of the
gct standings there's only one round
remaining can anyone stop the young
frenchman from winning at all round nine
of can't miss chess coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day nine of
the sink field cup this is it the
championship round the round where a
victor will be crowned we start a day in
front of the statue of stan the man
museum who is going to be the man at the
sinkhole cup let's go to the studio and
find out with yasser peter and alejandro
from the home of chess in america
welcome to the sing phil cup the
centerpiece of the saint louis chess
season and the very last day of the last
stop of the 2022 grand chess tour
hello and uh welcome to the show i'm
peter smith learn with me as ever is
yasirovan peter it's it's been great but
all good things must come to an end
absolutely hello everyone thank you for
joining our show for this the final
championship round it's been a memorable
event to say the least my goodness but
there are some serious scenarios of a
possible playoff
peter please do the honors and tell us
our current standings absolutely and the
play of scenarios are yet to come this
this will be a separate segment because
they're absolutely there they're many
and varied but for the time being we
have two leaders there up top janine
pomnessian alireza ferrugio are on four
and a half
out of seven importantly out of seven
and as you can see there fabiano carrana
also has four and a half points but his
tournament is done and uh uh
he is going to be an interested observer
today uh and potentially maybe even more
than that but we'll we'll see about uh
additional details on that on that score
wesley so is the person who could very
much get into the mix uh with a win in
particular but even in some scenarios
with a draw today and then we have
linear dominguez interestingly the only
person 50
at one point i think we had like six
people right 50 percent in this
tournament he's the only one standing
now
and and then we have people in the
miners they want iranian not having a
great event hans neiman now after his
stellar start uh back on minus one and
chakra air majority and mvl really
really suffer
we're wishing by this point for this
tournament to end i think well just tell
us uh about our grand chess tour
standings
yeah and this is where it becomes
interesting uh prior to the tournament
starting mbl was leading the gct with
26.5 points and he needed a good result
in this event to to
i think more or less guarantee himself a
top three finish and some prize money in
the overall standings but as you've seen
on the previous graphic is tied for dead
last
and
it's difficult to imagine him even with
the wind getting into the mix although
you know all kinds of permutations are
possible but i think that's a
mathematical miracle there that he needs
to be hoping for there a ferrous on the
other hand is currently tied for first
and is in clear second place in the gct
so most scenarios today involve him at
least getting into the play-off right of
the jct standard and just remind our
viewers our format yeah the format is a
nine player round robin with uh an hour
and a half for the first 40 and then 30
minutes for the rest of the game with an
increment starting from move one a 30
second increment drawfors are being
frowned upon here
and the classical scoring system is
being used
and we are very fortunate to have
alejandro in studio to break down some
of those various uh playoff scenarios
potentially alejandro good to see you
good to see you yasser good to see you
peter great afternoon here in saint
louis and a little saddened that this is
coming to the end it's not just the end
of the sing field cup but the entire
tour the grand chess tour finishes today
potentially tomorrow in case of a
playoff in the gct we haven't found the
numbers for that to happen just yet but
let's take a look at some scenarios that
might happen today as of course we have
our leaders alireza perusa and jan and
pomnyacci they can be caught this is one
of the many scenarios if both of them
draw today and wesley so wins we have a
three-way tie for first and that means
that we have a playoff for the singing
field cup today but alaresa perugia
takes the grand chess tour if alerza
perugia and nepo both win that's pretty
easy it's a two-way tie for first
playoff today for the sink field cup
alaresa ferrugia wins the gct as well
now we have another scenario for you
guys if ferugia and nepo both lose
and so wins
wesley so wins not only the sink field
cup but he passes aliresa in the gct
standings and actually clinches the gct
for himself now there's even one more
scenario if alireza ferrugia loses and
so wins but nepo draws
nepo and wesley type for the first place
we have a playoff today and because of
the way the distribution of points works
wesley so would win the gct if you do
the math that's because uh alareza would
be sharing some of his gct points with
fabiano carona who remembers also on
four and a half points so a lot of math
being done we expect all of this to be
correct there still could be surprises
we'll see what today's round has in
store but certainly an exciting finish
not only to this tournament but the
entire tour where there are still
scenarios where different people can
take home the crown and it's a lot of
money at stake of course it's been a
fascinating tournament off the board as
well as on the board but for some of
those off the board reports let's go to
our social media specialist wgm
anastasia karlovic
thank you alejandra thank you for
clarification i mean it was really
complicated what will happen in which
case uh i just would like to remind our
viewers that we still i mean of course
following this drama which happened
after round three of sinful cub long
time ago it seems to be so magnus
carlsen withdrew from the tournament and
then we had all this storm in the social
media and we still follow of course this
case yesterday the chief arbiter of the
tournament chris bird came out with with
a statement i think we can take a look
on the screen and um
he mentioned that and confirmed that
currently has no any
indication that any player has been
playing unfairly in think world cup uh
of course i mean there were many many
comments in social media and twitter
accounts uh i mean people were
discussing this statement but now i
think it's very very clear for everyone
what's happening and yesterday of course
we also followed the
fans of hans niemann who showed up in
saint louis chess club we made a short
interview with them and you can check it
in youtube channel if you haven't done
it yet
um i would like to mention that all
chess media still of course follow sync
health cup um but lately everyone was
focused mainly on on the event itself on
the games because we came to the last
round of the tournament so i mean mainly
this is what's happening right now this
this is the main topic
probably it's also happening because
magnus carlsen still
didn't say anything after his withdrawal
and then of course i would like to say
to everybody please follow our
grandchester official website as well as
grandchild store instagram twitter and
facebook accounts you can also follow st
louis chess club accounts as well
so the players are coming i think it's
time to give a floor to peter and yasser
thank you anastasia and for everything
you do there we see
our
co-tournament leader ali reza getting uh
wandered as uh the players come into the
playing hall getting ready for this
ninth and final round peter
absolutely yeah this is this has become
a very familiar picture for us
they've been doing it from round one
onwards and
uh every show basically starts with this
with this view
uh but
the games will start soon enough but for
now tell us about those uh games in fact
uh what are the pairings and what can
our viewers expect peter absolutely as
you can see there at the bottom fabiano
quran as we already mentioned a couple
of times he's done he's done in the
tournament i would have played magnus
today but that is uh alas not to be uh
but in terms of pairings uh
the three people we are watching
are mainly wesley uh alireza and jan
pomnishi in some order probably maybe
not that order but some order
and
in that respect wesley is playing white
against lanier dominguez vanier is a
very very solid player absolutely
but wesley as we've seen on on
alejandro's screen a few moments ago
generally speaking should be playing
very very uh aggressively for a win
today if he wants to if he wants to be
in the mix to win both the single cup
and the gct
uh we'll see we'll see what approach
cube brings because he he also i think
has a tendency of playing somewhat safer
after losses so um it remains to be seen
which approach he chooses uh mvl versus
ferocious is a very very interesting
matchup and vl is having a proper
nightmare of a classical tournament i
don't believe well i've seen that from
him for for a very very long time i
think he's been extremely solid and very
very consistent this is not a good event
but they obviously
have a lot of personal history mvl i
think was instrumental in others has
moved to france they are in very very
good terms it will be an interesting
match-up
for sure and uh of course the anime
she's playing against hans neiman which
is a
a game unto itself exactly i'm expecting
a very very
big fighting round and uh what are they
fighting for peter uh and they're at the
top as well as a game between moderate
and longer which did not get mentioned
too much because it's uh
of the four games perhaps the one less
relevant for for the standards yeah uh
as for the price fund the price fund uh
as per usual but we'll get in a second
here we just again it started round nine
some last minute announcements
if you want to be involved with that
please be in the playing hall by 6 20
6 20.
yeah there was an announcement that the
playoffs will start at 6 30 sharper
assuming there is no you know rook and
bishop against roken exactly things
could get moved or queen ending god
forbid
and yeah the the arbiters are asking the
players who are involved in the playoffs
to be there 10 minutes early for 6 20.
um security measures exactly
in that case tournament play will start
tomorrow at 1pm
and we'll do a drawing of blocks etc as
needed approximately 10 feet
and i think in general 63 is reasonably
safe we've had some long rounds in this
tournament but i think none have run
further than maybe six sharp no i think
six was the longest yeah i think i think
pretty much every single round including
the green ending ones
which which queen and
the white screen no the the the exactly
yeah no the five the fabulous
that one was quite long
by the way that was chris byrd of course
our international arbiter making those
announcements
as a play
as play is underway and once again peter
uh fighting chess oh oh okay i'll take
you on function let me what happened
there yeah i want to i want to make sure
the clock is properly
set to chris that's uh
now okay yeah and then
make a different one would be yeah yeah
making a difference
messing up the score sheet that would
have been bad yeah but so now what are
they fighting for peter i know it's lots
of money but break it down yeah the
prize money here is uh three hundred
thousand three hundred fifty thousand
dollars total for uh for the singfield
cup uh with a hundred thousand going to
the winner and actually i
once more a bit of a clarification about
the gct points number at the top there
if you win the tournament outright you
get 12. get 13 13. but if you if you get
into the tie break it's not that the
winner of the tiebreak gets 12. the 12
goes into the pool a community community
and and the pool as i understand it at
least just gets shared among the people
playing and playing in the playoffs uh
so two people type for first both get
11.
both get to level three people 22 points
yeah if if three people die for uh for
first uh that's uh difficult yeah that's
nine and nine in the third right
wait
three people is just
ten oh yeah okay
good morning st louis
and on top of this we've got work to do
guys check it out uh we've got to get
anastasia in on this as well we got to
start talking about this guy right yeah
the brilliancy uh peter uh yeah there's
there's an additional five thousand
dollar prize there donated by uh brian
priester of key west florida second year
running that brian is uh generously
providing this additional prize
for the best game of the tournament and
uh
we are we are going to be judging that
and we had this conversation yesterday i
think uh on the topic of you know how
how long the short list is
and i tried kind of uh not necessarily
arguing with you but i sort of disagreed
with the idea that it's only really one
game in the running and then i went
through the games of the tournament
and it's you know it's
slight spoilers there but currently we
do have a very very clear favorite i
think unless something spectacular
happens specifically today right i think
there is a pretty clear winner for that
prize and the play is underway i have
mvl versus farouza
berlin opening and going straight into
this berlin ending first essay by the
way i think
uh
here at the sinkhole cup in 2013 between
um
nakamura was on the white side what
knight f5 97 check took the bishop
versus
yeah but bish b7 played instead of
bishop c7 which i think has become
norman also i think they played this
uh in either the rapid or the blitz
there's definitely been at least one
game in in the summer of chess that
we've been following that went exactly
like this d45 cd5 bishop before right i
can't remember exactly who played this
but this is very very heavily uh
theoretical and i think by this point
pretty much analyzed to be a draw right
uh if you don't make any mistakes which
is not really the move bishop before
that's a very important inclusion yes
and and the reason for that let's
explain this to our viewers you can of
course recapture and d5 straight away by
95 95 but then you cannot take with the
queen because the bishop on a7 is
hanging so you have to take with the
pawn and then after let's say queen b3
yeah it's not much but it's a little bit
awkward for black because black is
currently it is faster in a symmetrical
position the bishop on ca doesn't get to
uh be developed very easily because b7
is hanging conversely
if you get in bishop b4 right here right
now and all of this is already on the
board
they're
going through it at great pace right you
tickle the rook you get your bishop out
of hawk
on the e7 square and as you say they're
they're on it and and then then you can
take with the queen this is obviously
the huge big difference here that queen
takes d5 becomes a move no bishop
hanging on e7 and if you give black one
more tempo to play bishop b6 here black
is actually better but because he can
play rook e5 and follow it up with
bishop c4 and x move the bishop doesn't
get to e6 and people have lost this
position with black once or twice and
the the average rating of people playing
this position in the database will be
extremely high i feel like it's probably
above 2700 because it's very very
popular in extreme top level chess and
when you said once or twice that was no
exaggeration it's exactly twice
out of 45 games blacks won once
whites won twice
and the rest are drawn the rest are
drawn
the speed at which they're playing peter
is indicative to me what you said at the
opening of the show
for mvl
yeah it's time to say bon voyage i would
like to return home to paris as soon as
possible true
true but right
if nvl wins and somehow some miraculous
math happens okay they still can get
third in the gct that's worth 25 000.
yeah and a lot of money that's that's
never on our graphic but yeah the gisty
prize money uh the specific gist of
prize money is a hundred thousand for
first right 50 for second and 25 for
third so there's definitely things at
stake in in that respect but i think uh
really for mbl um
you know considering how fast this is
going considering
uh yeah and there there we can we can
actually see it on our screen
175 000.
bonus
uh prize money awarded to the top three
finishers of the grandchild store
absolutely and and uh
it's definitely something very much to
uh you know to fight for but right but
mvl has had such a lackluster tournament
and uh i didn't mention that they're in
very good terms and uh nbl has been
involved with uh you know alireza's new
life in france very much right
it doesn't always mean that uh you know
people who have this particular type of
relationship aren't really playing
against each other very much but it
sometimes does happen that it kind of
dampens the excitement of trying to beat
somebody you consider a friend exactly
and coupled with a very very uh you know
sad tournament for mbl it it has been
indeed and again queen c3 alejandro
they're blitzing through all of these
moves like uh this is
all prep for bo from both sides and
again uh
everything's theory right pretty much
seems like it right there's a bunch of
correspond well not a bunch a few
correspondence games i think this game
of uh valentino should not be a
correspondence game i think that's under
actual game
all games so far that have gone into
this position of course ended in draws
uh you can see that white keeps a little
bit of pressure this rook on e5 is
annoying that rook might come to e1
someday
actually the move bishop d7 a3 is rather
rare almost everybody plays rookie one
which is the more normal move mvl
himself has played this against uh favi
all the way back in 2016. this can't be
a surprise wesley has tried it with
white hickory started with white uh
certain
piece viddler tried it against apollo in
2016. so certainly a known position but
the move a3 is a little bit of a wrinkle
doesn't seem to catch alaresa by
surprise and now after queen c3
the engines want to play g6
which i guess makes sense right to put
the king on g7 and then when they hint
at the movement and then perhaps yeah
perhaps even yeah the idea has to be
like g67 specifically f6 just to uh
because if you take on e5 and allow gta
xe5 there is not a lot of material left
on the board it's not going to be
horrible horrible but this is sort of
the absolute dream for why this is maybe
the most you can get in these types of
structures the queen goes to e7 we go
rg1
we've occupied the one open file on the
board we have a bit of a pull like this
position you still expect this to be
holdable reasonably comfortably for
black because of once again only two
only two heavy pieces left on the board
right but you can't get more than this
in these types of positions and for
black you don't even want to let them do
that yeah yeah yeah for black i think it
makes perfect sense to see if maybe it
can be stopped altogether and this plan
of g6 g7 and then f7 f6 i think does a
very good job of just stopping
all of that if that happens because
any other square on the e file we are
trading very very happily rookie three
percent rookie three we're not worried
about f2 takes e3 at all uh so
isolated upon uh turning into a
potential passer by the way i understand
this is all they played this
variation this position
even before in a blitz game
ah okay so they are uh maybe even this
year
i i i i have a feeling this is the game
i was talking about
yeah i think this is what uh the the the
the game i was trying to remember that
we covered during the rabbit and blitz
but i'm i'm not 100 sure and our
database on the screen is but i've been
holding myself in complete anticipation
how did you do with vessel
i was i actually wasn't aware this was a
thing at all
i it was what our viewers were expecting
i crushed him
it was a very very boring draw but the
the kind of the the the sad part for me
in that game was that that tournament
vaseline he had a nightmare but uh
like for the first half of the
tournament he played fighting openings
in every single game which is what you
expect from wrestling he is you know
arguably one of the most combative and
most principal players of the last 10 or
30 years right and uh
in particular at some point he lost a
game to karakian in in a sicilian
that me and my my team have also looked
at specifically for that tournament
and i was watching that like with tears
in my eyes because for a tournament this
was the kind of thing
yeah
this is this is a kind of tournament so
you really really want to to get you
know an important bit of prepping right
and then i played before against him and
that turned i think i was playing the
english mostly actually i was like 1c4
was my main weapon for that candidate
and i played d4 against vaseline to try
to try and get a sicilian
he plays the berlin against me and i was
just it was just so heartbreaking and of
course i knew nothing whatsoever so like
it's just i can only imagine it wasn't
great oh my goodness uh alejandro uh
where is the action in this uh final
round oh if anything is action that's
actually probably the game that not the
most relevant for the standings but you
can expect it from these two players
chapman with yard against levon aronian
still in theory is this position but you
can see it still it will be chaotic
because these kings they still haven't
castled and getting them to safety well
it's still going to take some time if
you castle kingside of course this rook
on h1 is already opened you shouldn't
have done that uh you can't really
castle queenside so you're gonna have to
play with the king in the center for
some time what is your compensation this
king's also in the center and you do
have the pair of bishops as black white
slightly better developed and here is
where the fun starts now this position
was reached from a nimbzo indian
uh that has come become quite common
with bishop g5 h6 bishop h4 and this
idea of playing c5 takes g5 bishop g3
and knight e4 now you throw in the move
c5 because in many scenarios queen f6 is
possible because take breaking the
center in general is a good idea yes you
leave yourself an isolated pawn but it's
not so easy to exploit considering
there's a lot of tactics in the position
for the time being now e3 is the main
line bishop to xba there's also a line
uh queen a5 rook c1 now roxy was not the
main line in this position most people
do play the move knight e2 right away
securing the knight on c3 with the other
knight bishop f5 has been seen in many
many games and the game just kind of
goes on there's a lot of theory here
rook c1 is another twist uh i've noticed
that most people actually capture on a2
taking advantage of the pin of the
bishop on before on this knight on c3
and this king on e1 so that is actually
perfectly possible queen a2 is one of
the main lines of the position
but levon had no interest in that
instead he developed this knight to c6
uh white needs to continue their
development as well now finally
spreading the knight on e4 this knight
has to move might as well take the spawn
knight takes c5 is also a possibility uh
h takes g3 d4 opening up the position if
you just stay still here and play
something like queen takes e5 i don't
know trying to regain your pawn a little
naively then after knight f3 you start
not liking your position g5 is actually
hanging in many situations because d4
can be met with knight ge4 remember
there is a pin on the h file here so
this point is actually weak if you
decide to push it your structure is kind
of bad why can you even sacrifice a pawn
here just to get rid of a couple of
knights and accelerate the development
just castle in this position saying that
yes europe a pawn but you haven't
developed anything anything coming to d1
will probably regain the pawn on d5
anyway and the king is pretty weak so
none of that d4 played instead pawn
takes d4 knight takes d4 now the queen
has many options queen d1 has been
played most often queen b1 is one move
as well and queen d2 was the one chosen
in the game bishop takes c5 and this is
how we got to this position i expect uh
mahmed to develop the knight i think
that ge2 is the most natural move in
this position and it does come with a
little bit of a thread i think knight
takes d4 and bishop b5 check is the main
one so levon still has some problems to
solve we'll see how this one goes i like
those open positions of course in many
cases a couple of simplifications away
from being a symmetrical structure but
with the king still in the on the center
of the board anything can happen
thank you for that alejandro quite the
uh opening
lesson there and i do remember and then
gary kasparov nigel's short world
championship
match they were really discussing this
variation
at great lengths you were explaining to
me peter that wesley
he should be taking an outsized risk
risk reward ratio certainly favors him
to go all out
and
no
no
i i did i did preface it by saying that
we've seen wesley take
wesley in general is is a very very
strange kind of a combination of two
players combined into one yeah yeah an
incredibly risk-averse
and also an unbelievably strong chess
player right i think those two are not
that often combined into one because i
think
uh when you're as good as he is right i
think at some point you realize
you know you have an edge so why not
play for a win right
but but wesley really is a like a
stunningly good chess player mm-hmm but
in his incredibly yes in his league in
his league i don't think anybody else
plays as safely as he does i think
uh
i don't think i'm being unfair to him uh
in that description and today this is
and the thing about this is that
yes this is a very dry position but this
is still mostly playing wide exactly you
make a mistake somewhere you will suffer
exactly but yeah it is
a slight pull i mean uh
it is
uh from
visually yeah four versus four two
versus two uh in a rather dry position
but you can be outplayed yeah absolutely
this is this is still a position uh that
uh that can definitely go wrong for
black if you allow i don't know
something like knight a4 bishop a7 and
then the bishop goes away from c4 and
the knight lands on c5 and this somehow
let's say costs you one of your two
bishops exactly those positions start
looking uh
less less than ideal yeah is actually
very clever i like your bishop d3
because otherwise yeah exactly in this
position after bishop c5
right yeah yasser is just doing doing
the entirety of the joke
well the idea is that you i'm getting to
get to the position that you were about
to
uh elucidate uh yeah sometimes
this is not nice this is not nice at all
you just built the position for a long
long long time to come absolutely so
that is how things could go wrong
for a linear having said all that i'm
pretty sure that uh
in that line there there has to be ways
to uh to avoid landing into that precise
situation for instance if bishop d3 is
played knight before looks like it
probably just equalizes on the spot
maybe i don't know
if
i really do need to wake up today for
some reason good morning
yes
no night before
um not here no not yet
is it
i suppose it is actually somehow
uh yeah we can go rook aj and bishop c
but then okay the bishop on d3 is
actually exactly that way now i regret
that i put my bishop on d3 i wanted to
play knight takes c5 so i guess we go
bishop b1 because if it goes back to f1
then takes takes knight e4 will be back
on the menu
but now that black has a tempo here you
feel like there has to be a way to uh to
you know avoid maybe
97 i thought maybe rook d6 would have g8
it could be made an argument for
rook uh part b bishop d one
six just stopping like takes a6 and also
preparing to double on the g file
doubling on the g file can rarely be a
mistake i think in these types of
positions exactly
uh so it's not much but
you know my sole threat knight takes
asics you stopped it
i liked uh
nepo yesterday coming in well he has a
threat to play knight g5 i played h6 it
can't be bad rook d6 stops the threat oh
i mean we should probably take a look at
some other positions sure i will just
finish with the here i think maybe six
is not that precise because particularly
here in knight c5 before i feel like
maybe we haven't actually equalized e4
in this one no not g5 before knight c5
even yeah because i think it pretty much
forces the capture right and then after
bishop to xc4 it becomes awkward once
more yeah because
i mean maybe rook fd8 is still fine you
generally don't like allowing bishop to
take c6 but maybe because of the pin
along the g file it's not that horrible
right only five of six maybe this is
fine
okay uh but i think yeah we've had
enough about and actually let's take a
look at the mvl alireza game because i
think that game was over in that game
i think i think we can watch the
handshake right there
and they have
after bishop e6 they got
as you said kind of to a maximum for
white
but it's not it's not very much it's not
the great backspace and now and now
there's going to be a repetition and uh
we're down to three
with this draw
alert that's secure because nepo could
win
and then alireza would only take 10
points but i think alireza has won the
gc2 that was my question yeah i think so
too right i think alireza with this draw
has won the gct so he might not win the
the singfield cup if
results go against him or if the tie
break goes against him but i think he
did secure the hundred thousand dollar
first first prize in the gct count
fantastic
well our hearty congratulations
on his grand chess tour victory his
first
his first time on the grand chess tour
guys 19 years old
and he wins it i mean that's
very well played
well done well done oh
not the most exciting game today but no
was yesterday yeah but
i mean we can we can definitely uh
uh appreciate you know a bit of
pragmatism there by bailey reza when you
know securing uh after all this is also
a sport where exactly and
the first prize matters yeah and he has
one he has won the tour at the first
time of asking this is his first ever
participation as a full a full tour
player right and he's won the tour uh
at the age of 19 against this field very
very impressive result by
by the young frenchman and he did it by
the way he came to saint louis
people kind of i didn't say write him
off but what he did in the rapid and
blitz was simply remarkable that was
mind-blowing yeah yeah winning the uh
rapid and blitz with four rounds to go
yeah that was pretty impressive and uh
his result
uh alejandro it speaks for itself what
can you say breathtaking when you think
about where he was after the first half
of zagreb where he had an ok rapid
but he comes back with a ton of
victories in the blitz
comes into saint louis rapid and blitz
destroys the field
and then comes to the same field cup
takes risks
and
gets enough points
to clinch with this draw
yeah and the spectacular yeah
especially if you consider that
bucharest really did not go well
did not go well for him at all and
zagreb also wasn't really going well
uh at all either so yeah an an
incredibly impressive comeback there
from uh from marie reza who seems to
have put
you know his troubles which you know
like the if you if you take the
bucharest through madrid through maybe
the first half of zagreb right that was
very firmly put behind you know he is
clearly no longer dwelling on those
results
and yeah i mean he's just an incredibly
incredibly exciting player and we we
we're going to be watching him for for
quite some time yet
now for uh nepo
he's come on the show and he said i've
had five buys
he's called it he says that his opening
preparation in four maybe five games i
may have
exaggerated
was such that he didn't even feel like
he really played the game and the
opening really kind of transitioned
right through the ending
and in a very quiet way he's put himself
in a position to win yes maybe his first
thing for your cup just a second i mean
i recall him losing the mbo
i think it will be i think he played
here once previously i can't remember
the exact year i think he played he
played here once again with a victory
today he just couldn't win this thing he
wins the tournament outright if he draws
he ties for first exactly uh and i think
also
as a kind of a i mean it's it's maybe a
bit early but
considering what wesley has just done
with his position uh
it will be if there's a tie for first it
will be a two-way tie not a three-way
tie because wesley just
very very quietly and very very calmly
just allowed the entirety of the
position to get traded off right uh so
yeah this is a kind of a quirky uh
quirky english i don't think i've seen
this particular appreciation very much
nepo versus
uh hans neiman game again a game that if
nep wins as you say
uh he'll win the singapore cup if he
draws
he will he will die first with alireza
but not wesley i'm pretty sure because
on wesley's board
i think in like five moves time there
will be no pieces
maybe a pair of bishops will remain
vacuum if you will um
what's the theory
alejandro should tell me because i have
no idea
um not theory on anymore we have already
a novelty
very early in this game with the move
bishop e6 g3 this move just was just
played has not been seen before but the
games that have been have reached this
position they're not top level gm games
either in general this variation of
knight d5 which we have seen before with
the idea of a5
um with bishop e7 it's not as common d4
takes and takes is also very really rare
after bishop b7 d4 the main line is to
actually keep the position closed sure
with the move d6 so that you take you
take back now whether it's the best move
or not that's up to debate but this
particular position where white just
gets the pair of bishops without any
real uh drawback for the time being
is supposed to be a little bit better
for white now after the move h6 you are
evicting this bishop from its powerful
square you don't want to lose a tempo so
you'll probably take you don't want to
double your pawns with the queen still
on the board so you'll probably take
take take and after i assume i move like
b3 we'll get an end game in which white
is pressing a little bit this structure
is never going to get any better but how
easy is it to access i'm not really sure
this really reminds me of those queen's
gambit variations in which white goes
queen f3 and bishop takes f6 and tries
to play against these couple of pawns
but it's not so clear how to get to them
or how really weak they are you could
play the king on e7 and then try to hold
on to that structure somehow so i'm not
entirely sure how much better nepo is
but it's one of those positions that's
play on one goal white's a little bit
better black never has an initiative but
may might not have that many
difficulties defending
the move g through alejandro the move g3
for for me may be a novelty but when you
play the move g3 you're gonna give up
the two bishops isn't it like e3
but i wonder
yeah with the idea of bishop h4 and i
don't necessarily have to yeah the edges
don't like this so much it says that you
are done a lot of development can we not
take on g5 95 exists yes let me show
that real quick if you take one
if you take on g5 here it looks like
this is winning
because you have this uh pin on the on
the knight but you have 95 which covers
from the queen and if you ever go f4 at
the very least i have knight e d7
defending the knight so you just end up
down a piece after h6 you're right that
you have to give up the pair of bishops
but the engine says that here you also
have to give up the pair of bishops
because this particular position after
long castle is just bad for white d5
coming you haven't developed and if you
castle short well you're kind of
castling into the attack of h5 and h4 so
again maybe a little pulled maybe not
that much take a look at wesley's game
yeah this is not very much at all it
actually has all been played before
between
two members of the chinese olympic team
of 2018 the that won gold uh huang chan
and shenyang
i do not believe that this can't be very
much the game ended in a draw i expect
this game to also end the draw honestly
i think he just goes rook c2 here takes
on youtube with the c rook and then
bishop eight yeah and then we're
professional right yeah yeah and then
this is why i said we will only have
like a pair of bishops here like 94
knight c6 take stakes and whatever yeah
like it feels like
uh this is sort of on his mind today not
very much peter often times i mean
you're such an experienced grandmaster
in these round robins oftentimes after
an exhausting tournament round nine the
final round sometimes it's a fizzle
because people just run out of energy
yes
we could have uh i mean
the way things stand we are likely i
think to get together
uh and yeah there's there's the
interview there with uh uh being queued
up not just yet yeah uh because i i
agree with alejandro's assessment about
the uh the nepo uh niemann end game i
think it will be very very difficult to
break down okay uh so i think it's
reasonably likely we get a play off and
the playoff always will get very very
exciting but but the round itself
does feel like it maybe will be i mean
clearly it won't be as exciting as
round or whatever it was seven that we
had three uh three and a half decisive
games right right
or it was actually yesterday i don't
know
yeah everything kind of blends together
and it was almost four for four yeah it
could have it could have been four for
four for sure oh but we do uh have
alejandro in studio uh is getting set up
with our
grand
chess tour
champion absolutely i'm just holding on
sorry very very impressively done and uh
our
preliminary congratulations
yeah
yeah where i was going with this was
that uh nepo who has played a
theoretical
uh duel a theoretical tournament uh is
quietly positioned himself for
potentially winning
the event i mean we'll take a victory of
course for him to do that we'll see how
that goes but for now let's uh let's uh
hear alejandro talk to ali reza
already welcome to the studio
congratulations on the performance on
this tournament did you see yourself
coming to saint louis playing in this
dream club for you especially how the
gct had started and coming out with the
victory in the grand chess tour
yeah it's a really
amazing feeling
when i came to saint louis i was in last
almost last place in gct so
um i played very bad in romania but okay
i played decent in croatia so
um but in general
i am happy with how things went i could
have improved my result maybe a bit more
for instance game against john but okay
he played brilliantly so
um i cannot be very bad very sad about
that so
i'm in general happy with the play and
yeah it's really amazing that i could
play at uh
i'm really happy that i could play at my
best here
in saint louis you mean right yeah it's
an amazing city um must be one of your
favorite places in the world now
it was before i come so
um it's really amazing whenever i walk
around the club
it's really everything is very high
class in this area
and the club is just amazing so
it's really
privileged to be here well the privilege
is ours to see your tournament
performances here tell us some of the
highlights that you remember from this
grand chess tour
um yes um yeah of course the highlight
is here in saint louis
the other places like are not very
special but
especially here in saint louis i won a
very important tournament the rapid and
blitz one
and that was a very
great boost for me
to start with things well here and
yeah in general
the granchester is the toughest tour in
the history of chess i think so
to win it is an amazing
feeling and
[Music]
i cannot be more happy
it seems that things started clicking
you coming here did you do any kind of
special preparation or something that
changed the way that you started to play
yeah yeah i i
for sure i got some experience from the
candidates tournament
i played their
14 games very imp very tough games
against very good players
and everybody was motivated so i'm
so i took a lot of
lessons there and experiences there and
it definitely helped me to be
at the top of my game here so
and in general
i think the rapid and blitz portion i
played very well
and that really gives me confidence for
the classical because it's really a
boost so
um in general i think the candidates
tournament helped me a lot of course
let's go back to that point you said
that the candidates tournament was a
lesson for you what did you learn what
went wrong over for you in madrid
yeah there were many things that they
were
wrong um
okay it's part of
chess chess
related some part is not just related
but
there are many things that
still still i am learning still i'm
going back and thinking about it
maybe in my team we should have made
some different
um adjustments but in general
i think
for the first time in being in the
candidates it really helped me to get
experience if nobody was
expecting me to okay maybe rating was
that was one of the favorite but
in general it's a very tough tournament
you need to have a lot of experience so
for instance like like fabiano he had a
lot of experience he won it
i don't know two times and he still
collapsed at the end so it's just shows
how difficult it is the tournament
absolutely very difficult tournament
you are one of the youngest people here
at the top you've now won the gct at
only 19 you crossed 2800 what's next
yes for now um
i i want to improve my rating of course
and
it's really important for me for the
rating i think
to go hop is very important to go at
least back to 2800
um i lost it very
you know because i was not in a good
shape and lost the rating a lot and
now i should go back and train more and
see what's coming up next so
yeah peter joined the conversation yeah
jessie winner yeah just one question for
you all amazing first of all our
congratulations
simply an outstanding performance salute
i mean no question about it thanks but
but
your tournament may not be over
is a very strong possibility that you
would have a playoff against nappo first
of all have you been involved in
playoffs in the past and if so how did
you do and then finally
how about
how about nepo uh would you like to play
a play i have never been in the playoffs
um one time i had the chance to go was
the world rapid and blitz this last year
but the rules were not the same as
grantees tours so
i was third place and first and second
they played the playoffs so
yeah
there i lost my chance but yeah i never
played any playoff in my life so
maybe in some
strange tournaments five six years ago
but not in the top level tournament so
and uh but i think jan has a good chance
to win today so you like his position we
can take a look it's a very good
position i think this end game is known
to be better for white there are some
good games that white won
and i think yeah here takes e4 bishop b5
it really
you look at the board real quick yeah
right over here we take bishop takes e4
we shall be six bishop
bishop d7 i guess yeah i think if you go
bishop d7 you're worse i think he
probably should maybe try to castle
immediately oh yes just play wow
shatter structure yeah if of course
white consolidates here is much better
but okay there the king will be attacked
with f5 right yeah f5 from before hd8
yeah something like this right yeah i
have a feeling maybe hans knows this
position he's thinking but i think he
analyzed this position maybe
because it looks very direct the
way he's playing so
uh and of course john has to go for this
position because otherwise there's
nothing to play for
so it's a very direct position maybe
yeah it's tricky of course i cannot say
john will win this game for sure but he
has a good chance here of course i
wanted to ask you about your opponents
in the grand chess tour is there any
anybody in particular that's given you a
lot of trouble
um yes of course wesley is a very good
player every year he plays
okay i never played in granchester it's
my first time but every year i watch
uh
he plays always very well and he's
always in the top fighting for the
first place so he's very good i think he
was my biggest competitor of course but
john is also a great player but somehow
he didn't perform and perform very well
in granchester so
but he's amazing player of course
and this is a good time for you to pay
attention to the monitors i'm being told
let's take a look at what they have
prepared for you
i guess that's official
grandmaster alaresaruja the 2022 gct
champion comes with a extra hundred
thousand dollars not bad congratulations
thank you yeah well well played and uh
i mean not much to add i i just for me
personally there was this this little
mention of i want to at least get back
to 2800 i'm just sitting here thinking
yeah you know small steps you know
it was like little little targets
you shouldn't really set yourself too
ambitious a target in life just at least
get back to 2800 of course it's very
difficult to get to 2800 because there
are not many 2800s nowadays so i have to
play always with
lower player low rated players and it's
very difficult but okay i have to try
well there is a period when you have to
play these lower rated players like
bobby and nepo and wesley and the
wingfield is higher than me
i like how he knows that very
specifically
congratulations we'll let you watch the
rest of the games in case that you need
a playoff and we might see you later
today thank you
again our congratulations indeed
absolutely just uh fantastic fantastic
outstanding result and his first time on
tour
uh normally my my modus operandi was
whenever i went to a new tournament
usually i bombed and i came back
now that i knew what i was facing i i
improved
a lot but
uh coming and immediately winning
in president so it's very very good and
here interestingly i wanted to ask you
but uh
he's now gone because jan chose bishop
g2 in this position instead of she takes
d5 which was also specifically i wanted
to ask
whether he would if he had this position
with black is he taking on c4 is he
playing long castles those are i think
your two choices right as i say this i
now realize knight before might be a
move but it's kind of ugly i
don't want to do it okay let's take the
ball by the horns ourselves and here uh
the issue for white is obviously you're
playing this to take on c6 otherwise it
makes no sense okay and now after b
takes e6 i think if white had enough
time to play like both long castles and
knight e4 c3
this is the position
i would maybe like to get but the issue
is long castles now i think runs into c4
c3 at least you have to calculate b3
sorry b takes bishop takes a2 this would
be i think good for black if not for the
fact that maybe c4 wins a piece right it
could uh yeah bobby fischer bishop
king c2 i think we've actually uh we
very very simply run out of squares yeah
our bishop with okay one coming in uh
yes so so that's one question okay and
then if if c3 is impossible i will just
play 94 or i don't know
if you play if you play a five yeah just
to be yeah and then and then we have to
we have to discuss this yeah 94-bit
should be five actually here so let's go
number one knight b was actually
seriously going to be one exactly uh and
then i wanted to ask you for uh yeah sir
like
this is a kind of a
this makes my eyes bleed structure from
black right so yeah i know
we win this with white borderline
winning uh
oh yeah if we if four rooks off the
board i think it's one i just i just
think it's my my question was
as we as we sort of know about you know
we've been talking about this in a very
different context in the context of
let's say the four against three on the
king side that f7 f6 h6 actually takes
away so many squares right that it's not
such a best structure defensively right
so let's say we imagine let's just
actually put this on the board we take
on divan gurukji it's horrible nobody
does this of course of course just the
fall for demonstrations exactly g8 we
take those off the board we go knight c3
the king comes to g6
you play i don't know uh
i was gonna go king d oh you just you
just maybe you're in time to pick this
one up yeah king d2 yeah this this this
is okay
let's assume that the black king gets to
c5 no no in this position yeah obviously
uh
maybe he doesn't but king d1 and king d7
king d2 king d6 c3 c5 knight d2 let's
say f6 f5 right i mean i understand it's
it's it's ugly as sin but
are we winning this
maybe we are but maybe we are i think
it's a question i think i think it's
it's
possible to ask this question because in
order to start collecting those pawns
you will have to start opening up the
board four
potential king incursions right and the
bishop will become slightly slightly
better and so on i put my knight on some
very terrific square i think i actually
kind of took songs here that's what i'm
thinking too oh yeah some terrific
square and
if i ever get my knight i don't know to
the g8 square you're going to have to
play and i show you the xc4 i think has
been played because i was wondering i
think i as black would have chosen long
castles
ah that was
yeah that was the question i really
wanted to ask you if you
if you are uh pardon me uh bishop g2 if
you are terrified by this ending yeah uh
what did you think of the characters
yeah and and this is this was the
question for me because now that the the
whole line that alireza was showing with
e4 and bishop b5 is completely
unplayable there is no bishop on f1
right and there's no king on e8 right so
i'm guessing jan was planning just to
maybe castle long here and try to
transpose and try to yes say that you
still have nothing smarter than d take
c4 so we will play the same position
anyway and we can play rkt8 we can play
95 we can play a number of moves here
which might not be all that stupid right
um
other than other than the big c4 in the
game and honestly i think i probably
would have preferred that because this
like if we miss
if it's black we must miss evaluate this
right we're just we've dead we've lost
again you really you you're really dead
the crazy part is the computers tend to
give the bishop such a great value they
may not see this as that big an
advantage
we have this ability to just say okay
this pattern 20
20 moves down the road we've got an h6
issue and since this is likely to
actually be happening at some point
actually all of this has been i mean up
to long castles has been played exactly
i want to just for our viewers to
indicate that
uh let's say after uh knight b1 here yes
so the setup for black as i understand
it would be to play rook d6 or yes
knight c3 let's say and play f6 f5
and to keep that rook on d6 saying that
let's say anytime you want to trade then
be my guest please please yeah on on
triple my pawns right
and
it might actually be a bit difficult for
white to make significant progress
because you like you would like your
king to be on a four or somewhere right
precisely but crossing the g file
might turn out to be a challenging
proposition and if you have to if you
have to vacate the c3 square
by the night black might develop some
counterplay if we go back peter if you
don't mind me for just a moment going
back here to this moment
when you see the g3 the novel
moved by nepo
and
this
i want to say very very natural
progression of the game
how much of this oops that that was
bishop g2 how much of this do you think
nepo has prepared
he's playing really quickly today
but this is nepal uh so with him this
isn't necessarily a sign of anything
yeah there's no telling that yeah we've
seen him play
exceptionally quickly in positions he
then confesses uh during the present the
the interview here that he knew nothing
about right
uh so i don't know how much you can read
into this but
would he have prepared this specific
ending that we're we're yet we're
getting on the board so i think that's
you know him he i mean in particular the
speed we wish he played knight g2
yeah because if we go back to move 12
there for a second this one nice too
wasn't obvious yeah this was the first
moment in the game where i thought okay
he may have looked at this because i
think you you kind of think i should be
playing b3 here
but yeah he just
quickly played very very quickly he
chose knight to uh i think specifically
with the idea of bishop g2
and yeah
it's hard to say okay let's bring in uh
the engine and
alejandro
what do the computers think of uh
nepo's novelty and the position he's got
doesn't think it's very much but that
it's not zero couple of ways to try to
equalize i find it still a very a bit
uncomfortable to play this with black
now castles is one of the main moves in
this position you guys were mentioning
rook b1 and ib1 and you were discussing
this ending with rook takes the one rook
takes d1 rook date of course a
theoretical practice to see if white was
actually winning that one i even with
the engine i wasn't entirely sure at no
point did the engine cross one so
it seemed like it was better but it
didn't find a clear way to win it it
does say that of course that's way too
helpful you might as well just play rook
hd8 you can never take on d8 because
pawn takes d6 just fixes my structure
and then how do you make progress from
this position because i go to rook d2 i
just put this rook on d8 and the moment
that you play rook for example here to
d1 then i just start bringing things in
a go king b7 and
how do you make progress here as long as
the rooks are on the board your king can
go up that's clear and if you ever take
on d6 i snap take with the pawn and at
that point you're actually just worse
because you're down a pawn right so it's
not clear that this is going to help you
so much actually after castle castle the
engine doesn't want to go to b1 it wants
to go to e4 probably to take away the
square d6 from the rook of course this
runs into bishop d5 which is a pin on
the knight in the rook then i can't move
you have to play f3 and you might stop
looking at this just right away because
it looks so ugly but then you realize
that if you take take it's not just
these two ugly puns it's these three
ugly pawns here there's two ugly pawns
there that one's isolated so even though
white's still down a part in this
position and i've doubled the e pawns
perhaps this can be playable for the
white side we have none of that actually
c3 was played by hans
which the engines do not particularly
like they don't think it's a terrible
move but they do think that white's
slightly better here i'm trying to
figure out the point of this move take
on c3 king e7 was already played he just
wants to shatter the structure on c3 i
don't think it was quite necessary to do
so of course he cannot take on a2 that's
not bobby fischer this because after c4
you just get your bishop trapped in the
corner king c2 will be played against
for example rook b8
i don't think i need to rush with this
just king c2 and rook a1 is gonna uh
trap and if you play rook b4 i always
have king c3 to reinforce that pawn on
uh c4 i think i had a better move but
whatever rookie one was even stronger
yeah but kings three is also good yeah
good enough king e7 i expect the move
king c2 to come up and it feels like a
nagging advantage for a very long time
because this structure is just so bad i
don't think that you have a path to
equality
anymore
i like white from this position it's
it's a free role yeah you run the pawn
back after this move through c3 not
quite sure about that uh bobby fischer
really i mean one of the greatest
players of the world being known for
blundering a bishop
yeah bishop would be it would be a bit
unfair to suggest this yeah this is his
claim to favor right exactly once more
everybody uh we have our first result of
the final round and a very telling one
it was as
mvl
and ali raza played a very
theoretical duel that finished in the
draw which was the perfect thing from
ali raza's point of view peter yeah
absolutely uh
mvl really
not having a great tournament just
decides to
you know get it get it over with uh yeah
that that game was a very very quiet
affair but it does
does give alireza an unassailed
unassailable lead in the egyptian gcd
standings he could still play a play-off
today if jan doesn't win and he will
actually finish and clear a second
lithium actually maybe not even clear
second because wesley could win
potentially potentially yeah uh but the
gct uh title is safe with them it's
sealed and delivered our congratulations
to 19 year old phenomena
that's not uh
yeah i think that's that's fair phenom
yes i think that's 19. that's a good
word
19 years old just incredible our
congratulations as he wins his first
grand chester at his first
outing and again we were mentioning
wesley so could still you know get
himself somewhere is he i i feel like as
is often the case i uh kind of slandered
him there a little bit because
wesley is playing safe but he is also
not the kind of a person to go roxy to
rooks he takes d2 no he is still playing
this game yeah this knight goes to
either c4 b6 so before
yeah
more activity right now at least
this rook is active this rook is not so
this bishop on e2 has the potential of
being far more active than this fellow
which is likely to drop back to e8 and
this knight is ready on a good day to
jump into two very
delectable squares or e4 c5 b3 c5 are
also uh potentially good squares i think
c5 is generally maybe the best square on
the board for that knight because it
puts so much pressure on the b7 pawn
due to specifically the fact that the
pawn is on a6 basically i think in this
position if you imagine this very same
position with the pawn on ace back on a7
instead of six it's just immediately
completely equal because i think because
a7 b6 will be such a solid pawn
structure on the queen side there will
never be a single nibble for white
spoken like a grunfeld lover i mean a
real groove fella you know your
grunfeld's peter everybody get uh
peter's uh chess-based uh
course on the grunfeld it'll do you well
you'll know just basic chess bases
conducting their
legal representation yeah did i get it
wrong
hate that hate that
as we prepare to go to break peter tell
our uh audience what they can get at a
cue boutique absolutely let's let's take
a look at this what am i missing do i
get any specimens
let's see what we have i'm sure you do
if you ask and there it is on your
screen the sinkhole cup polo a cotton
polyester spandex blend polo
features a
sinkhole cup logo on the front and
available of course in both men's and
women's styles
and it also has a saintly chess club
logo on on the sleeve
so
as with everything else available at
cubaticstl.com above
veritable bonanza of
things uh things
chess related that you can
uh deck yourself out in right
three words fabulous
we'll see on the other side of the break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the final round of the
ground uh of the sinkhole cup the final
event of the grand chess store uh with
the granchester there's still some
intrigue in terms of the second and
third place in the tour but the first
place has been allocated uh shall we say
with the uh
young frenchman at reza ferrugia uh
clinching it as far as we understand
with a very very comfortable early draw
in this round which is the only result
so far today
a slow start to this the final round of
the sinkfield cup peter
just kind of across the board i see a
lot of balanced positions but when we
left this particular game between shaq
and lavon it was quite the theoretical
dispute and after knight f3 the players
have reached this position and rather
quickly castles came uh talk about the
position because
i myself would find them a bishop e5
check rather attractive and i kind of
want to keep my rook on the h file even
if i had to play king f
would be
a point yeah uh
but on the other hand like it's
interesting that you mentioned king of
wang
sort of coupled with the idea of bishop
v5 check because i think i'm not playing
bishop b5 check almost ever in this
position because we're
making it easier to play king of fade
king jason
black echoes uh the the sentiment of
just kind of fianchetto is king yes okay
i think fair i think if there's no
follow-up of the bishop e5 king of fate
and i don't see any
forced follow-up then we're just making
black's life easier by
kind of driving the king to one towards
one of the better squares on the board
can be on and also opening up the g-file
so that let's say okay d8 comes with a
tempo so i think bishop b5 check wasn't
really all that topical the choice for
me would have been between i thinking if
one and castles and
i think it's difficult to make an
argument against connecting the rook
straight away i think
we are most likely con considering how
open the position is we're not going to
get mated on the king's side with
something like h5 h4 i don't think black
ever has time enough to
start this kind of a direct attack on uh
on the king's side so we might as well
castle connect uh connect the king side
and the queenside rogue and and go from
there okay
and then break down uh from black's
point of view black might
like to put his king on b8 but it's not
open castling open castling we would
allow you to go king to a8
and rook to e8 and you could take your
choice of the b8 square the c8 i wasn't
aware of that rule yeah open castling
but the problem here maybe is it runs in
the knight e4 not really i think it's
playable right now specifically because
of the tactical issue that the bishop on
d3 is hanging we just take on g2 here we
do lose the c5 bishop with the check but
we just go king b8 and recapture on d3
okay this is completely i mean in fact i
think
you start to look at a2 is hanging uh
shades of the neiman game and uh okay so
wait a minute castles is perfect
and then we're going b at next move and
we've
moved away from the potential x-ray
yeah so what could be the 22 yeah king
b8
uh knight b5 might be something that
might worry black a little bit
because uh else
knight p5 you say
maybe like this as well yeah but maybe
we're not winning here with white
because i think maybe i can maybe even
just go bishop b6 and say
you only really have one threat and as
long as i can get that knight off the
board the moment it lands on c7 maybe
this is just not doing as much as okay
as it looks so yeah for me the choice
for black is between the very very
concrete long castles and potentially
still
even in the current position even
without being prompted by bishop b5
check i still don't hate king f8 king
king g7
or short castles or short causes short
castles i think maybe is the
the least favorite option for me here
because let's say we play shortcuts okay
should be one here it should be one i
don't know if it's the best move but
just like you start as an illustration
yeah
i'm glad your king's not on b8 exactly
yeah or alternatively like if we compare
this to king of fade
you play bishop b1 there i go king g7
you you know please play your queen c2
move which creates zero threats yes
you're absolutely no threat yeah
placed in this case i think f8 remains
playable probably short castles is also
playable but um
by the way one of the nice things about
both king f8 and long castles is you do
keep this do you preserve this option
yes absolutely and that is a little
worrisome this uh three pawns um let's
get alejandro in on this one alejandro
we've been looking at this position
between shaq and lavonne
and
we're
kind of trying to make heads or tails
out of where black should put his king
queenside fag-7 kingside what say the
engines i think in general if you had a
choice you always go queen side it's
just whether did the tactics work can i
actually get it there without losing too
many tempi or too much material because
the king on g7 whenever you get it there
you've mentioned this bishop b1 queen c2
doesn't have a direct threat on the h7
square as long as the rook is there but
it is there laden and knight e4 is also
an idea you can also consider this
diagonal to be weak in certain cases it
really depends on where your piece
placement is but the king of g7 will
never be fully safe if you get if you
see the king on v8 it might be fully
safe and then you can start with h5h4 so
this is the reason the engines want to
long castle they don't want to play king
of fade as much it is the second best
move but they start considering that
after a simple chess like rook fd1 and
maybe a move like queen e4 just to
prepare 94 without the trade of the
queens it might start becoming annoying
for what for black to defend all of his
pieces and at the same time safeguarded
king that will always need peace
protection uh so long castle is
definitely playable and it is the top
engine move now the top engine move here
it is you could just play queen e2
there's knight b5 as well i think you
guys were mentioning it but b4 right
away that's not b4 b4 right away might
be an idea what's the point just shut
the pawn just give up the pawn so that
you have the b file in so many different
scenarios you don't have anything direct
rook b1 or something like this doesn't
do very much because queen d4 but if you
start with a move like queen e2 now i'm
threatening knight e for winning the
game you kind of have to go this way and
now i play knight b5 you have ideas of
rook b1 you have ideas of queen e5 check
like we were looking at earlier the
queen is no longer defending c7 in many
scenarios so perhaps a couple of new
ideas here for the white side black is
supposed to be completely okay as usual
the engines give zero zero though it
doesn't really matter what the position
is but they do prefer long castle over
king f8
absolutely nice point there are castles
when you're on g7 you're always a little
vulnerable yes when you're on v8 you
have a chance for full safety it took
them 31 very very long minutes
maybe more
but lanier finally did uh make a move we
were talking about lanier's ability to
find ghosts when they're not there but
when they're there
yeah benny could really scare you peter
why did he take so long and did he make
the right choice with 97. i think
it maybe isn't even that he was so
worried about things i think it's just
very very difficult for lanier to
uh
not be in the mode of looking for the
absolutely cleanest solution in every
single position even if it's a position
like this one where i think he probably
recognizes on some level that
most likely the difference between like
the top three moves in this position is
not going to be huge right but
it's just not how he approaches chess he
uh you know the moment an actual
question is being asked of him he he
wants to get to the bottom of it he
wants to uh to figure out exactly how to
equalize and he ended up with the move
97 i think both king of faith and bush
p8 were also very logical here
and from lanier's perspective
he's seeing the knight coming to c5 he's
seeing the bishop coming to f3 so he's
with the move knight e7 he's taking
concrete measures like
to stop that potentially even i don't
know knight b3 bishop
okay seven warriors man rook c7 worries
me uh
so
let's start by saying why rook c7
doesn't worry me in the current position
okay instead of 93 if you go rook c7 it
will have to immediately go back after
95
because if you take on b7 you just lose
an exchange in two moves to bishop c6
which pay for
that's a shish kebab yeah it's not a
difficult variation but it's a variation
that is important to indicate because
otherwise rookie seven would be very
much part of our conversation because
hanging knight going somewhere next move
will attack like skewer the entire
seventh rank and so on so roxy seven is
completely unplayable i think it is
knight b3
or ninety four i don't know which one
you prefer the the immediate bishop f3
will run in the bishop c6 yes we don't
want to trade is it sort of like uh what
are we doing anymore so maybe three
let's see let's say it's b3 okay and
then you have to
you you have to figure out how to
approach this you can place the bishop
on c6 and kind of accept that knight a5
probably trades it for the night i think
in most cases we will have to allow this
trade allow this trade it's still not
very much you should or bishop d5 yeah i
don't know either you immediately called
perhaps now you're rook c7
exists for sure yeah maybe seven is
actually kind of awkward here okay so
knight eight five and and then
yeah play a quiet move here like king of
eight and the loud knight c6 knight s6
bishop f3
and
i mean my assumption is this is still
not very much
like it takes takes from divan
yeah yeah i mean it it can't really be
horrible but
well
it's possible black has something even
cleaner okay but i don't know
what that is i i was kind of
unsure what the reply to knight b3 was
here i i think it might actually be
bishop c6
um
and then i mean knight c5 is kind of
empty here now that we we've solved the
issue of
uh the b7 pawn in advance is there any
potential that i'm not going to take on
c6 is there any potential i can put up a
picket fans of the pawns on f3 you know
how it goes pawns on e4
and suddenly you've got two minor pieces
that are kind of they're not facing
oblivion or anything like that but
they're under control yeah i guess my
initial reaction here having looked at
this position for three seconds would be
to play the play king e8 and then just
snap on the one play place it in second
rook on on
and say that i understand why i might be
a little little tiny bit worse but i
mean so much is coming off the board
with every move there's so little
firewood
that
it's it's it's very difficult for me to
get very excited about wise chances here
if i'm honest with you
very good uh alejandro are you getting
excited about nepo's chances i'm not
just asking is this inquiring minds want
to know that kind of thing well we have
a new position here in the game between
nepo and hans but actually it's saying
that the engines are saying at least
they don't like this move h4 too much
but the way that they wanted to continue
was pretty inhuman putting the rook on
a1 you kind of understand it after a
while it actually wants to squash this
rook on a6 by playing a4 and not letting
it get out of there potentially even
playing a5 now the edges were looking at
this they started to think this might
start to be dangerous for the white uh
black side after the move a4 even though
you're putting a lot of com pawns on
light squares which is usually not what
we want to do the move h4 came very
quickly by nepo i think it's a very
understandable move the idea is that you
don't have rook g5 which would allow you
to transfer over to the queen side so
it's in some ways locking the rook the
only problem with it is this move f5
which at the at the beginning i thought
was completely
weird because obviously f4 is an idea
with the idea of rook g2
okay but don't you just play e3 and
prevent this party like you'll never get
f4 in and the engines were saying play
something like c5 lock the spawn on the
light square and if you ever start
playing this plan of rook a1 and a4 boom
f4
just give up the pawn it's worse than
having it for free because after takes
check is a little uncomfortable you
can't really play the you don't want to
play the king to the first rank unlock
this rook you play king c3 rook d8
starts becoming uncomfortable with a
suddenly rogue d3 suddenly this bishop
is good suddenly this rook is good not
so clear right
that being said f5 looks so
counterintuitive
like so counterintuitive because if i
play e3 and you don't move when i get
the knight to f4 just from a visual
point of view for many everything you
know about chess
that is not good
so
understandable that hans didn't play
that he played another move that's good
rook a4 looks like a good move to me
it's very direct it attacks that pawn on
uh c4 i will take it if you give me a
chance if you play king c3 probably just
check
ask the question how are you going to
defend against the simple the simple
move right um if you go king b3 i assume
rook b8 is just a check is good you know
yeah rook bait is not very nice for
white you take take and now you have to
promise on the second rank since the
white's okay but nothing more than that
and
uh yeah perhaps black just have enough
counter play in this position uh to make
up for this
kind of disgusting structure but every
piece that he has is very active
absolutely including uh the bishop on e6
that is supposed to be your bad minor
piece it's actually uh fully employed
sorry peter no and and this is i think
the reason why hans played c4 c3 so
early because if you if we compare this
just uh how to say uh in in terms of the
sort of the spirit of the position if
you castle here and you allow knight b1
knight c3 you might be fine with the
rook on d6 as well as we've been
discussing it would have been difficult
for white to make progress sure but
black is not going to have any moves for
the for for the rest of the game pretty
much it's just we're claiming that this
is impossible to to break down whereas
by playing uh c3 and then bringing the
rook over to a6 which i think is the
correct approach here
you are
playing for active counter play and
interestingly uh i i looked briefly
while alejandra was speaking i looked
briefly through the moves that they
played and weirdly or maybe not that
weirdly but somewhat weirdly for me the
engines were adamant that rugby one b2
and move 21.
rook b1
b6 c4 okay six yeah here uh and
yeah the engine at least on my screen
was absolutely screaming at me that rook
a1 is way stronger
than rook b2 yes because of the same of
the very same plan of playing a4 as
early as possible
right i really don't know how easy it is
for a human person to make that map
you're like you're abandoning the open
file placing the rook back on the
starting square seemingly kind of giving
up on your on your queen side because
the second row can come to b8 here for
instance like you have to you have to
have a reply to a kb8 if you play rook
hb1 after rook takes b1
you have to activate the game with the
king and then rook for maybe wins
material
none of this is intuitive
none of this is intuitive but i'm not
sure
if it's the same at greater depth right
but at the depth that i briefly looked
at while we were
we were watching like the game unfold
yeah yeah the engines were absolutely
insistent that rookie one followed by a4
is maybe the only plan white has to
significantly improve on the queen side
and
you have to start now what alejandro was
talking about the plan of going ruby and
then rook h1 a1 right is slower so you
if you can
you have to start along those those
paths
as soon as possible right very
understandable that you didn't i i
really don't think it's a move that
maybe even occurs to your friend
the one move actually that did occur to
me uh in this position which was not
chosen by the way uh uh it was the move
84. the image are they for because i can
imagine that the rook comes to b6 i
would like to have a5 and i would like
to challenge the b file
and tickle the rook
along the b file
but in the game with the move uh rook b1
and c4
conversely a moment ago there was a
black pawn on c4 which the
which sacrificed itself with after c3
now there's a white pawn and it's a
target it is very much a target yeah it
is it occupies a lot of wise resources
yeah hans has played rook g8 g4 here it
doesn't actually threaten the pawn on c4
it's a bit of an empty gesture for the
time being because yeah you let's say
you would play rook c1 here okay as a
kind of a logical follow-up if you take
on c4 you lose material straight away to
f2 f3 as
yasser is indicating because you are
running out of squares on the fourth
rank for the rook for the bishop g4 so
you're not really threatening very much
but it's just a natural kind of an
active move which you make quite happily
just do
just to play something
yeah
well at a certain moment
shouldn't i be playing active moves
myself uh
just doesn't do very much right because
i if if all else fails i can go kingdom
7c8 or something right okay because i
would okay well to to to be to be clear
uh peter sort of like
i wasn't gonna be three yeah i was
trying to keep but maybe
yeah okay
there is also this i don't know if it's
an issue but i could meet king b3 with
bishop takes no i couldn't i'm keeping
wandering full rooks
it's the rook b6 stuff that
gets me down so all right we have rook
g4 on the board we'll keep an eye on
that one uh let's just jump to
the whoops that's what they have the
west they sew game for just jump to what
there are no moves in any other board no
moves in many of the boards yeah oh dear
yeah lavon stock yeah and wesley and
lanier are both stuck as well
okay well that will
continue our discussion yeah it it's
clearly i think the the moment our rnn
game is potentially the more interesting
one but
uh this is a very very non-standard end
game it's just that i think it's very
difficult to talk about this end game
kind of sensibly because
it it is surprisingly concrete
uh i think we've described the general
themes here the general theme mainly uh
is
you know despite the absolutely
horrendous pawn structure all three of
black black black's pieces are so active
that
white finders find themselves
in the situation where
it's very very difficult to figure out
what
a plan to improve would ever be because
you have to pay attention to the pawn on
c4 you have to pay attention to the pawn
on a2
and that ties down basically your entire
setup right to the protection of your
weaknesses which is a very very
uncomfortable place to be
uh eventually c65 because i was about to
say maybe i can play for like rook a1
yep and i like that movie yeah and then
i want to play for a plan of a3 and rook
b4 makes sense but eventually c65 will i
think get played and then once again how
are we challenging any of this stuff
exactly it's just rock solid this the
setup and and uh as alejandra was saying
um
h4 is a very understandable decision
because not allowing rook g5 rk5 seemed
like a very logical thing to do right
but now the rook on g4
even if it doesn't create an immediate
threat like how are we getting rid of it
we can't play f3 no no no that's for
sure so
yeah
they're very stuck okay but i like rook
a1 c5 could i just play games
i don't know king d6 c6 here i mean king
d7 let's not blunder f3 with f3 f3 1994
check probably we shouldn't be
blundering yeah okay
that's uh
yeah that's
how am i gonna yeah if it gets to c6
like what are we attacking in this
position with what it's you you what are
we ever attacking you're you're raising
a very very uh important question there
i don't know how to use it it's just so
so strange yeah we're gonna take a break
but we're gonna we're gonna come back
with a very special very very special
guest to get the perspectives of
rexingfield himself
don't go anywhere
[Music]
welcome to our show
[Music]
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
[Music]
that's our show now go start
at this moment.
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
[Music]
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums art history science
even
magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
[Music]
whose kids it is
st lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back to the final round of the
sinkhole cup uh there are still three
games in progress and they are actually
becoming quietly becoming interesting uh
and
we'll get back to that in a moment but
for now uh alejandra is
with the man himself
rexing pill he needs no introduction
we've been talking about his tournament
for about a week and a half rex we've
seen it all at previous thing field cops
with offi seven zero we saw magnus take
this tournament in the first uh edition
but this one was a completely different
beast tell us your thoughts about this
one well it's it's pretty hard to
comment on this i mean you know how do
you get that kind of excitement however
nefarious it might be
but we did get it you know and it is
what it is
uh but you got to say the players have
rebounded and added a lot of excitement
to this event as if nothing happened you
got to give them a lot of credit uh like
the game last night between fabi and
neiman that was
exciting and i loved the commentary
people saying they're going back and
forth bobby can't make up his mind to go
for a win or not and he said that in the
interview he doesn't know which way it's
going that makes it all pretty exciting
for us low-level players you know it's
actually been a great event in terms of
chess and it's been headlined in
different ways by two 19-year-olds
that's right how do you feel that
alireza ferrugia has been doing here he
said his dream was to play at the club
but it seemed like the dream was for us
to see him play i i think that's
absolutely true it was a dream fulfilled
for us we need more players like him
although i don't think there are many
more like him but he's fabulous he's a
fine young gentleman
and hans niemann had a lot of excitement
he's not having the success that farouza
did but not many people can
but overall it's been exciting for all
the players
you know and uh
watching a quick draw this morning with
the mvl
and farouza that was kind of interesting
in itself
joey and i were lucky enough to have
coffee with them later i thought they
were just drawing their game just to be
with us you know
well that is why we come to the sinkhole
cup to hang out with you
[Laughter]
what's impressed you uh from this
tournament from the last one from the
players that are new perhaps to the tour
i think the fighting spirit of this one
you talk to the players and you you see
how genuinely excited they are how happy
they are
uh
despite the way things have gone they
they've all bounced back it's been a
really good event i think for the entire
chess world and the players and of
course the three greatest commentators
in the world we owe it all to them
there's no question about that we always
appreciate that tell us a little bit
about that from the pr perspective we
saw this just explode over the internet
of course unprecedented news when magnus
carlsen withdrew but when were you
informed about this how did you learn
about it well i was watching
when it happened and but i was talking
to uh anastasia last night about it and
i didn't realize
how extensive the coverage had been
worldwide she was telling me the hits
were between two and three million
every day i mean this is stunning
you know
you got to give it magnus is a great
personality and
and his actions brought some attention
to this
how do you feel personally as somebody
that puts together the best tournament
in america arguably one of the best
tournaments in the world every single
year and this one we always look forward
to having the world champion participate
and boom he just leaves
well you don't want to see something
like that happen you never want to see
a top player you never want to see any
player leave under questionable
circumstances so it's unfortunate but it
is what it is and i have total respect
for all the players involved uh and i
have no ill will toward any of them i
think they're they're all great and
they've all tried to do a good job and
they've worked in accordance with their
own best conscience well we'll see
magnus back in events
oh i'm absolutely sure he likes being
here he's he was very public about that
and i've heard him say that himself a
couple years ago i was walking out of
the club with he and his father and he
looked around he said dad this place is
really nice why don't we move here well
you know that just filled me with joy
absolutely no already himself said it
how it was spectacular the high class
that surrounded the club and of course
everything inside that club even though
they were in the middle of renovations
yeah i know that is really amazing you
got to hand it to joy and tony and all
of her staff i mean joy bray is the
brave the greatest and you know the
problem with my saying that is she's
probably listening right now
she's going to take it all very
seriously you know so how do i get out
of that one uh no but they've done a
fabulous job
and uh you're absolutely right i mean
this neighborhood is one of the best
neighborhoods in the world like you i've
been all over the world and i've seen
them i don't think it's really hard to
compare to this one we're surrounded by
culture and beauty and great
architecture
and tremendous history and now the chess
club just gets better and better no it's
one of the best places to have the
center of the chest world every year
especially during the sing field cup
guys join the conversation here with the
man himself uh i you you brought it up
rex uh culture and i know not only
humana culture bobby fischer
has always been an important part
of your awareness of the chess uh
world and
across the street the world chess hall
of fame
arguably one of the greatest exhibitions
of bobby fischer memorabilia of the 1972
world championship match talk a little
bit about that because i know
you have a lot of bobby fishermen well
this is sort of a dream come true and
around here you know we've been talking
about it for several years we knew it
was coming
and uh
just seeing it realized is amazing
seeing all the artifacts and the
memorabilia is incredible seeing that
table and those pieces that they
actually handled and played is
amazing and i like yasser have had the
good fortune at one time to meet bobby
fischer i like to tell people i i taught
him a lot of chess but they all know
better
no but it's a fabulous and i think it's
going to be extremely well attended it
has already i see people walking out of
there waving the posters and the signs
that they bought and and it's really a
good thing it's great for the city it's
great for chess no i have to say that
the world chess hall of fame exhibit
right now of the 50-year anniversary
between of the match between bobby
fisher and boris basket it's just
spectacular they have so many different
things i didn't even know existed
there's so many booklets that fisher
used seeing the boards themselves the
pieces themselves the fact that they
played game three on the pieces that we
have on display that wonderful knight h5
that fisher played in the benoni i mean
having that set you taught him you know
of course doubling your pawns come
on rex i'm gonna ask you something
outside of bobby fisher you can invite a
player that was at his peak to
participate in one of the singfield cups
who'd you choose boris baskey boom
boom now you know
we thought going back five six seven
weeks we thought this was all under
wraps you know we were working hard to
prepare it nobody knew about it and out
of the blue i mean truly out of the blue
joy bray gets a phone call from france
it's from boris baskey jr now you talk
about a secret not well kept that is it
you know
and uh he he was gracious and wonderful
we sent three people over he had loads
of memorabilia he said my father has
lots of memorabilia he would like to
loan to your tournament what a wonderful
gesture from a wonderful man boris
baskey you know that's just so typical
of him no i have to say if you have a
chance to check out this exhibit like
for sure stinkfield cup is great to
watch and it makes it even more
worthwhile to go in front and check out
what we have at the world chess hall of
fame
yeah
you're right thank you very much no rex
thank you for letting everything that
happens here in the central west end is
definitely thanks to you we have the
tournament it's been fantastic we've had
such drama but the games i mean the
games have been amazing they are amazing
and they're even made better by
yasser and peter i mean can you ima and
you can you imagine that
it's like having three hairy carries in
one room
oh dear rex thank you very much for all
you do for chess uh we are
very very grateful indeed uh peter
anything i've been agreeing kind of
sitting here and nodding nodding in
agreement but one thing i
that's always struck me when i when i
speak uh with rex is uh
how much he how deeply he cares about
this being sort of a continuation of
saint louis specifically saint louis
chess history and his knowledge about
his knowledge of the saint louis history
and uh
it's just wonderful to see uh you know a
person care about sort of legacy and
continuity and
continuing to preserve those traditions
uh so yeah thank you very much for
everything you're doing here it's thank
you peter that's very kind it's
wonderful to be part of it
thank you once again uh rex uh
gracious thanks gracious thanks
jumping back into the games uh jan
has just been presented twice an
opportunity peter to get in the move a2
a4
and he didn't do it on both occasions
right back yeah it's so i mean right
here this was a
this was a golden opportunity i thought
right to get in this move and you try to
just take away the squares of the rooks
yeah you you you're trying to to make
that look much less active and i think
the fact that jan keeps on passing on
these opportunities because uh he is
basically there was this moment and then
was i think after rook c5 as well the
engine was very very much
adamant that a2a4 is a very good thing
to uh to try and work in at some point
uh
and yeah bishop take c2 bishop take c4 i
think just gets completely uh
destroyed by the move king b2 and then
rook hc1 and black will be
forced to shed a lot of material here
exactly bishop d5 here is sort of
semi-playable right i've been
calculating this
saves saves material for the time being
at least rook c5 which page one but i
mean it looks a little strange to have
the bishop on it but maybe maybe
five here maybe actually just preserves
the advantage because a7 is falling
right but what i wanted to say in more
general terms is that
uh jan is actually a very good endgame
technician you know it's probably not
something you associate with him uh
first and foremost but he is a very good
end game player and he's been passing on
a2a4 for a while now which i think is
just a very fair indication of just
how
non-obvious it is right that this is
what you need to do because
it feels like maybe like in general when
you're
pushing pawns forward on this on the
flank where it's not clear that you are
the side you know attacking right you're
generally presenting targets
so i think in your mind
uh
that you need to provide black like you
move the pawn from a2 where it's very
well protected
to a4 where you can imagine some
scenarios let's say you know the root
goes to a5 black goes c5 bishop d7
the other rook maybe gets to be four
right you might lose this pawn you know
you never you pretty much never lose it
on a2 right you can imagine a scenario
where it gets lost lost on a4 and all of
those a good one yeah and all of those
patterns in your brain they they tell
you you know don't touch it like it's
it's don't do it yeah
keep it very keep it where it's
protected don't don't really commit to
anything but the reasons for having it
there are very clear that you could
eventually start taking squares yourself
and if on a good day you could play
moves like king a3 rook
b2
rook b7 absolutely now instead of being
defensively oriented in the white
species that is to say they're active
and this rook
could
also get freed up to to do things
exactly exactly yeah but it's just such
a confusing ending but would it will it
produce an advantage and if so is it a
big advantage
great we get it in a4
how pleased are we
well i have to defer to the engine
because really to me i i absolutely sort
of i'm in agreement with jan it is very
very non-obvious to me that this is
strong he hasn't played a4 here
he could but he has putting some moves
on the board and is
at no point during this game like
at all of those inflection points where
the engine says play for now or else
kind of things you know at no point
did it really feel to me that i would
for instance maybe maybe even consider
that move during the game let alone
definitely play it
uh so i have to i have to kind of go
back and uh and rely on engine
evaluations and
move
25 let's say after uh
king b3 or k5
rook a5
dropped the evaluation from almost equal
to i think almost plus one after a to a4
still yeah still absolutely no guarantee
that you you win from here
but it was a very significant drop in
evaluation for black because
you do start taking away very important
squares but as i keep on saying none of
this is obvious this is an extremely uh
non-standard uh end game with a
structure you probably will never see in
your life again
and we'll we'll never have seen in your
life prior to today uh jumping over to
you alejandro we've been kind of
thumping the the drums of this ending
between yon and hans just because it's
so important for the standings and a
potential playoff later today absolutely
and the last move that hans played huge
mistake rook g8 the engines hate this
move the reason this move knight b3 a4
is also good as it's always been but
knight b3 i think is really strong it's
a very findable move because you do want
to improve the night and it looks like
it wanders upon because rook takes g3
look at this uh beautiful pin but if i
play knight d4 your rook runs out of
squares on the f file so you just lose
material now if rook h3 takes takes
bishop rook d2 or whatever rook h4 you
do get two pawns for the exchange but
remember which pawns we're talking about
right these are terrible pawns and i
think that the rook should be good
enough to win in this position i don't
guarantee it
but i think that it should be
and if you don't do that you kind of
you're kind of forced to play c5
allowing knight d4 i don't think it's
really playable if you stick that rook
on c5 this knight on d4 is beautiful and
always hits c6 and you're kind of
depending on the rook on c5 to protect
c6 for pretty much for a long time
i don't think allowing knight d4 is good
but if you play c5 this rook in some
ways is on the wrong side because in
many cases we needed this counter play
against the a pawn so many different
scenarios in which we saw the rooks
attacking the spawns actually on a4 if
you could teleport this rook or this
rook to a4 then you're you're attacking
both pawns right you're doing what we
were supposed to do but now they're on
the wrong side and the agents are saying
just improve the position rookie one i
don't really understand but rook d1
looks kind of human to me you start
playing for a move like king c3 rook d2
even knight a5 and suddenly we start
creating threats and these rooks don't
they just don't create anything as long
as this rook is are on this side of the
board a2 is safe c4 is much more
difficult to attack you only have so
many squares on the fourth rank and
you've already retreated your rook out
of it right so king c3 will follow very
soon i'm going to start having a real
attack i'm going to start having real
threats knight a5 knight c6 will be a
huge one not so easy to deal with
because you'll need to put the bishop
passively i can hit that bishop things
start to become complicated for hans if
nepo finds the move knight v3 if he
doesn't you can still play a4 like the
same as you guys have been talking about
but i think knight b3 specifically at
this moment because of tactics might be
very strong
thank you
alejandro
the irony is that yesterday hans is lost
in the exchange down ending
against fabi when you get to this
position as alejandro was saying one of
the one of the worst endings i would
ever want to find myself in
if i was
an exchange down then big right just
just
specifically because
it's the next day yeah exactly after
knight b3 it does feel like in
particular because you know hans uh
his game yesterday did
you know
i don't really i can't really say i've
he just burst onto the scene very
recently i i don't have a good handle of
exactly what kind of a chess player he
is but i don't think passive defense is
his forte from what we've seen in this
tournament so i think he might be
tempted to actually take on g3 pick up
both the g3 and the h4 pawn
and and say that
at least i have counter play you know it
might not be great but at least i have
counter play here after knight five bish
p5 let's say we go out on a rook
somewhere let's say d2 or c3 we take on
h4
and the bishop returns to e6 and then we
start pushing the h pawn right we we
just go h5
rook somewhere h4 h3 scraggly and it's
ugly it's structures you've ever had
it's still an outside passer right right
so i'm just putting some moves on the
board there is one issue it's very risky
for black eyes that the a
pawn could be
vulnerable as well just throwing that
out there well we'll keep an eye on that
one uh we were saying that lanier might
be seeing ghosts is he uh not really i
mean uh he played knight knight b3
bishop before we thought six but bishop
iv was chosen
this is an interesting point for me
because after takes takes uh wesley
chose not to play rook c7 here which i
thought must be the i think that was why
we stopped yeah it must be the only way
to continue here if you want something
out of out of this game the point being
that if you play rook g7 which appears
to just liquidate everything right i
take on d7 okay i play knight c5 okay uh
you go i think bishop c6 i play bishop
three okay and my issue is maybe knight
g5 just protects everything because
otherwise i would maybe start becoming a
little bit interested here with white
because you're just one tempo away from
playing a5 and b6 but i'm not really
giving you this tempo right at this
moment right right and uh
if not for the move 95 i think i would
be quite interested yeah any trades of
the light square bishops favorable for
white but knight d5 puts you off yeah
and then i thought
it looks like there might be something
here for white but if we don't achieve
anything right this moment the king will
come to g6 and it's just very very level
uh and okay what wesley ended up doing
in particular his final move just now
after
he played knight c5 instead of uh rook
c7 allowing uh that move rook c8
and i thought you know a way here to
pretend we're playing for a win still i
think we need to play b2b4 because b7 b6
is a threat
but now after b6 i will play bishop
takes a6
it's very important for us to not
immediately lose a piece to rook takes
c5 right right and then b takes e5 i
assume loses and if you play rook c7
i'll play knight b3 or knight d3 or
whatever i'm i'm upon up here
yes
i'm very unhappy about this yeah and if
you if the bishop goes away from a4 if
you play something before bishop b8 okay
i can play rook d1 at least
and i'm not just like a kind of god yeah
grippers on it exactly by the way that
was rook d1 that not my master brookie
you get the knight on c5 the ponzi
a5 a5 does exist yeah so maybe it's not
very much but that would at least be an
attempt because what wesley has done
instead is play king f1
right back here
he's played king of fun just now we
played b6
knight g3 we take on c1
and this is the structure i was talking
about absolutely nothing yeah like once
those pawns reach the dark squares i
mean there's really there's really not
very much left to play for yeah because
you're just not attacking them exactly
you're they're not weak at all yeah all
right so that game really looks like
it's heading for uh the draw and finally
that leaves us with shaq and lavon devon
having
pardon me castled queenside earlier and
against i think we reached this position
peter and we've tried bishop b6 but
with
foresight of the of the game bishop d6
looks much stronger it looks fine yeah
an interesting point a somewhat
interesting point at least came after
queen e3 okay g8
uh because you can play before here
and b four here yeah i guess you're just
not better after queen b6 though right
yeah i was trying to figure out you
can't play queen takes before that that
that's made in one i was actually trying
to calculate something very fun you can
play bishop takes before knight c7 check
king b8 knight takes e8 and weirdly i
was unable to refuel bishop d2 here
bishop d2 yeah but maybe oops maybe
after queen c5 we actually preserve some
material but i was trying to calculate
this trying to figure out if this was
ever going to be levon's intention
because i assume i assume no yeah i
don't know thanks take some
yes exactly something of that nature
right or maybe even just takes on d3
right away maybe even straight away
right and this knight is a little high
and dry and the two bishops open board
if we don't get
kebab exactly yeah i think i think if
you teleport this bishop from g2 to b6 i
i like i'm happy with this with black
totally but rook d1 bothers me a little
bit but i think the probably the answer
is just much more prosaic you just you
just play queen b6 here and you say
uh
i thought maybe we've broken the the
coordination a little bit i will take on
d6 and the pieces maybe last slightly
discoordinated it looks like it but but
maybe it's nothing very much nothing
yeah so in the end the ashariar goes
takes bishop c4 and now yeah it just
looks very very dry yeah i think i don't
think coming off the board in this one
as well i don't think anybody's better
no no it feels like
that
that will be a draw as well so once
again back to a crucial it is a very
important game and it might be the only
one left in the moment actually right
the way the other two are going it might
be the only one left
it looks very likely actually
surprisingly enough once again
okay i can understand why
maybe you don't play a4 but knight b
number three did look attractive yes you
know that did look attractive but king
c3 it was i think not the only reasoning
i would have is that perhaps you don't
believe in your winning chances on the
exchange
sacrifice sacrifice i think i think jan
might also be somewhat interested in the
idea of just making moves and and sort
of continuing to ask small questions
because maybe he feels that he's not
making much progress but he's also not
really worsening his position by
shuffling around
and uh you know perhaps eventually some
inaccuracies will come because right
because we can look at the current
position right rook b1 played the
engine's top move is c5 and you know
allowing c5 rook b5
among others among others yeah exactly
knight b3 also interesting very very
many things there will have to be it's a
little sus this move c5 oh yeah but it
is a very firm top move in the engine
wow yeah c5 c5 yeah because knight b3 is
a threat currently i think if we if we
put it back and we when we and we start
thinking about
okay so he and he's already passed on
that yeah so rook g4 okay we can't play
knight b3 now but we can freeze the
knight
yeah
we can start invading we can go rogue b7
i think rupee 7 in particular is clever
because it does ask the king where it
wants to go
and it's not necessarily true it's
better on d7 it's closer to the knight
in in one if you want to look at it that
way right
the king of king d7 it's like close to
knight v3 knight c5 jack
let's say we play knight king b2 here
and we try to play knight b3 next move
right this becomes tricky this this
definitely becomes tricky for black and
i think this is what jan wants he wants
to continue asking those small questions
without really committing to any kind of
a structure change until he feels that
it actually is maybe winning
uh which is i think a a reasonably good
approach against
uh
hans who
uh
[Music]
let's say the way he the way hans
approached his game yesterday hans
played i think until mistakes started
creeping in very late in the game he was
playing very quickly but also pretty
like he was making decent solid moves
uh but
against somebody you suspect of
being in in this mood of just sort of
trusting your instincts and playing
quickly
this is this is an intricate end game oh
yeah good question about it yeah subtle
moments yes sorry peter and the point is
that
if if you think your opponent might be
in this kind of a semi-blitz mode right
not giving him concrete questions to
answer could be quite useful because you
know if if you ask him a concrete
calculable question
he will sit down and calculate but if
you just ask him more after move to make
general general decisions right
uh it could at some point become tricky
to to make them well by the way rook
is not a bad move either yeah well i was
about to say a moment ago rook b7 was
the point of discussion i
could well understand that you might
find that the king is a little bit
misplaced on d7 as a compared to e7 but
i was actually
on a different track altogether i was
thinking about rook to b8 with i hope is
a concrete threat
of king and actually just marching back
into getting to c5 and then playing for
knight b3 with my rook in leading so
thinking before okay six is the only
good response there because you need to
have a threat of rugby six check and
response exactly if you don't have that
you are i think you're just dead like if
you're looking rook b8 has a concrete
problem it's rook f5 rook f5
oh yeah
that does make sense yeah
that does make sense because we suddenly
we find ourselves very very uh you know
i was i was living this this charmed
life of just you know like having
nothing to worry about and then
alejandro showed up
uh all right that answers that one so
rook b4 uh and i think rook v4 is
partially done to encourage to move c5
yeah so
white is ready to meet rook f5
now not with knight b3 yeah because that
looks horrible he's protected upon him
maybe he's ready for
tricks of his own yeah you got it if the
rook lands on a4 for white i think the
game pretty much ends because then then
things will start collapsing so quick
but knight b3 is suddenly a very serious
a huge thing yeah i think you kind of
have to play i think you have to play
you have to play c5 and then he goes
rogue b8 or b7 or something and goes
from there well
having induced c5 a move you said
alejandra the engine is prepared to play
voluntarily there's no more rook fives
in the position
not at all there's no types of uh
threats anymore c5 is useful for white
in the sense that you cut the rook from
the king side
but it's also useful for black because
you actually need to prevent anything
from hitting this rook on a5 which
includes the king coming to b4 right or
the knight coming to b3 and the knight
coming to b3 is stopped by the rook and
g4 and the bishop on e6 attacking the
pawn on c4 right mm-hmm so it's on king
g7 for instance i don't know which
square is best yeah it's just going to
suggest let's look at something concrete
for a moment
because
you know
there was hang on a second this might be
f3 and then that'd be three yeah
i was about to say there there was a
study i once saw where there was a pawn
on a6
and a black pawn on a4
so black pawn on the a6 black bought an
a4 and a white pawn on a3 and this i
just laughed and laughed and left the
poor predicament of the rook on a5 and
somehow i got hardwired and i think it
was the laughter of this rook that just
got frozen but you were about to make a
very important point peter i think it
works though yeah i was very excited for
a second there by f3 rook g3 knight b3
quote unquote winning the rook but i
think simply rook a4 yeah knight c5 king
c6 solves those issues issues and we've
activated the rook
uh in all of this uh we we never do this
to our king side unless it wins the full
rook basically and it doesn't and it
doesn't at this exact moment
um
okay uh now that i've induced your king
however to the square can i
just kind of hover around are you going
to go for this rook a6 or b6
tree no i think if we go to b8 maybe
we'll go to b8 straight away and i
actually b8 as i now realize
uh has a very concrete idea right
because let's not forget once after c5
yeah let's say c5 for gp8 i beg your
apartment first of all let's yeah let me
get the
c5 yes
because suddenly i realized you know the
bottom h6
is a legitimate target we can go after
it yes we can go after it
and if rook h8
prompts rook g6
that's a major achievement because it's
very very much needed for black to keep
an eye on the c4 pawn yeah to tie me
down um
how about the apples alejandro c5 rook
b8 just asking some questions to the
black not necessarily
invoking king d7 just rook b8 uh
advantage or is our engine
being its treacherous self with the
triple o's no no no triple o's anymore
but it is tricky for black and i think
you have to do something and the way to
start to do something is to move rook a4
you need to start harassing the spawn on
c4 now if you play something like king
b3 then i play rook a6 and you can kind
of gain a tempo with this track so let's
just move the rook somewhere i don't
know random to h8 you have this move
bishop f5 see it's very concrete that
you need to start harassing the pieces
that white has uh this bishop is now
attacking the rook e4 loses a pawn and
check this out check this move out oh my
god
good luck finding that
it's a prepared it's a perpetrator you
take because check you need to defend
the rook right if you go a3 check if you
go here check if you defend this way
check you have to take and i take and
now i have counter play on the second
which is enough for equality even though
even getting here is not so obvious you
still lose h6 there's still up now
there's a
uh battle between this pass pawn and
this pass pawn as soon as a2 is taken
very hard stuff to imagine especially
all the way here so
there is concrete play there are tricks
for the black side as well
but they're very very very concrete so
it's not a position where we can talk
about generalities because in
generalities the white is just winning
if you can unravel unravel this it's
over right but there seems to be just
about enough
for what for black to keep creating
things created threats create a trick
create a trap
that white isn't fully able to unravel
according to the engine
uh my trainer and nikolai minev kind of
drilled into me that if you're if your
position is relying upon tactics to save
it it's likely you're strategically lost
but i find that engines very oftentimes
rely upon tactics especially in these
endings and they save themselves
just by having moves like rook d4 yeah i
think if you replace lost with very
dangerous that will be uh
universally understood obviously you
subscribe to that right away
but
definitely one of the things that
engines taught us in in the past i don't
know 20 years is that
margins are a lot wider than we thought
that positions which look indefensible
really aren't in in in a lot of cases
like you we've learned we've all learned
by analyzing with engines that
if you can summon enough precision a lot
of things which would just be written
off as unplayable
are still defensible and perhaps
are now even being defended because
i think even psychologically people have
started approaching defending difficult
positions much much differently because
you
you get a new burst of confidence
through knowing
through experience of of watching uh
and analyzing with engines and realizing
that
you know you're not getting mated
if you play well no this end game can be
held if you uh if you pay attention move
after move after move of course it's
very difficult because you know that
level of precision is not very easy to
summon uh even like for short bursts
right but yeah i mean uh there's
definitely been a shift in how people
approach uh defending difficult
positions
on the board and everything else did
look kind of losing if you allow knight
b3 unimpeded
it really started to look started to
look extremely extremely sad this is uh
like an example uh where am i putting my
rook beater well you're in trouble
wherever you put it like if you put it
on a6 i might be tempted to go e4 a5 and
tell you could you please wait well i'm
about to play rook b6
oh that's right even that though like if
i play a4 or b6 a5 i force you to take
on before
in exactly the way i would like right
right and then like king c5 94 like this
starts looking hopeless totally right uh
so yeah c5 did feel like it was
absolutely necessary and hans uh did
give it the appropriate amount of
thought and did play c5 and now we're
choosing between rugby 8 or b7 i don't
know which one is stronger
yeah i mean rook b7 i do induce king c6
king d7 but then again maybe i give your
king a good outlet on the c6 square
therefore i find myself
more i don't know if intuitively is
right but i find myself drawn to the
immediate rook b8 all of these are
difficult to judge but yeah
it feels it feels strange to force black
to play kingdom 7 king c6 because
it does feel like c6 arguably is maybe
the best square for that king you're
doing something there right why am i
putting your king on a good square yeah
so it yeah it remains a very kind of a
difficult difficult to judge end game uh
and young has played something i think
it's from b8 his
not explained player would be
seven sorry b7 okay so young disagrees
my guess would be is that like he feels
that if if there is to be a race if
let's say our plans in the future at any
point do include rupees okay
maybe
jade
want your king on c6 exactly getting a
king further away from from the h pawn
will make sense for those races
specifically that's looking very very
deeply into the position once again
imagining just for a moment that white
ends up in a situation where he ends up
capturing this pawn
black for whatever reasons ends up
capturing some something of his own and
there's some kind of a race
with the h pawn versus the c very simply
f6 will be hanging like if if if we
imagine taking on h6
ah just very simply like if we if we
imagine some kind of scenario where the
rook takes
takes the whole uh the whole uh uh
circumstance circumnavigates the globe
there goes rook h8 h6
once we get there we're thinking away
from these seven square if so f6 is
hanging which might win us a temper
and that might be an important tempo in
the in the general uh scheme of things
that every tempo
is important rook before c5 rook b7
and king d7 already played this is by
the way move 33
they've been and yeah they've been yeah
they've not really been
lagging
yan as usual however it still does
maintain
a good uh clip on the clock he's got 51
minutes and bh played very very quickly
to the 33 of hans
now again a structure being as terrible
that's why we're thinking that if
white ever gets in a situation where
black
goes on the defensive with rook h8 rook
g6
uh
it's terrible it's just
terrible i don't think this position is
defensible passively i i really do feel
that the moment we force black to switch
to the passive defense with more or less
one here with white but
okay which kind of begs the question
okay four okay six once again i guess
should i be doing something with my rook
on the a file peter yeah either okay
four or k3 check as you're saying you're
trying to provoke king bitsu and then
going back to a6 creating this idea of
is this all together terrible maybe
maybe i'm leaving as well yeah well i'm
leaving
all kinds of ponds vulnerable aren't i
yeah i'm not sure about this because
yeah i can even go to k8 which takes a
seven first and then and then that's
pawn that i really don't want to lose
right yeah i don't know so rook be eight
on the board and maybe
this attempt at activity is too slow but
this whole idea of bishop f5 and rook d4
that was
that was amazing that was really really
really funny can i do it this way peter
rook a6
rook h8
bishop f5
idea of
it's coming
rugby six yeah yes
yeah this is what i expected alejandro
to show us a moment ago when he showed
us rook d4 yeah and then you showed us
something else all together right yeah
this looked scary honestly because rook
d3 is such a tremendously strong threat
right it looks scary in in the previous
position we could be discussing it looks
scary here i mean afford to play e4 i'm
not
i'm not convinced i i'll be any better
in that four rook ending
but
maybe
tactically it works out because i have
this weird feeling that maybe a e4
before f3 is working
what
what
f4 e4 you should take c4 f3 yes you can
give a check from d3 oh no yeah okay i'm
i'm being willfully blind through takes
a 3 discovery check it might be the only
move that is good here but it's pretty
good
okay got it if you didn't have this move
yeah if it wasn't for those pesky pesky
captures capture as well hit those
captures with check yes
that's weird guys jump in jump in i've
been looking at this for a while trying
to understand the difference i'll tell
you that king d7 was a mistake and king
d6 was much better
and i was like
why
why why would king d6 ever be much
better than king d7 and i think it
specifically because it's in the range
of the knight
and this is what i'm going to talk about
king d7 was played rp8 played and what
happens if rook a6 hear bishop f5 and i
thought rook b2 rook d6 actually looks
like a lot of counter play
but precisely at this moment
because your king's on d7 i can play
knight b3
uh-huh
if you take on c2 knight c5 is game over
right and if you don't
allow me to take on c5 via i don't know
first of all it's not so easy to stop
i can just move my rook thereafter
they're after in in a in a very
comfortable way
so actually this king's very vulnerable
bishop f5 just loses to knight b3 in
this position i mean you still have king
e7 and there's still some stuff to
calculate but it it doesn't look good
for black
so after rook b8 it's
the engine thought for a while and said
you know what best move is king e7
yeah i don't think yeah but he does that
yeah good luck with that
i don't think anybody does that but what
else do you do because rookie chair is a
huge threat and precisely with the king
on d7
we don't have the same variations as
what we did with the king on e7 so in
essence this rook b7 rp8 is actually
very clever the king is worst place on
d7 and it is on e7 because of the
tactics i think nepal understood that
very well and hans is the one that needs
to figure out what to do in the next
couple of moves because he is he is
basically lost if you give me one or two
moves here with white absolutely this
much we know yeah this this has become
critical enough that if you if you make
maybe one more imprecise move white will
just assume total control so meanwhile
in the other games
dead draw
dead the draw between shaq and levon
expect a handshake here pretty soon
and uh
maybe even better draw
between these two guys
the funny thing is i think we've had
this like there was a game in this
tournament which ended in this exact
bishop ending i just can't remember
which game that was
like this exact bond setup happened in
this tournament really i think maybe
magnus on the black side in round two
against who was magnus playing in round
two can i just play this tournament
well i mean we know he hasn't but still
who who did he play around too all right
he'd be young
and then he drew very very quietly in
round two uh yeah against uh lev and yes
that's right no they they still have the
a pawns i'm lying okay but the like the
final position of that game was
basically this exact position with with
a3 inside with a3 and a7 remember
yeah
i had the feeling i saw this on my
screen and uh i'm not entirely reading
so let's just go for the handshake in
this game and there we go and that i
believe guarantees wesley second place
in the grand chester and mvl third
mvl third yes
okay don't see any scenario where that's
not true
um
yeah fiber is not in contention but
isn't jan in contention not anymore i
guess yeah i don't think so now with
this drug can we bring can we bring up
the gcg standings uh for a second just
to i'm sure alejandra is correct
hundreds pretty much never
or this one in particular
i don't guarantee anything this is what
i think i did some quick numbers
yeah so
because if jan wins the tournament
outright which doesn't look impossible
at all right this moment
he does get a bunch of points but i
don't think it's enough to take
questions
was behind by quite a bit but remember
he started so long coming in so he will
be 16. he'll be on 29 right uh and
wesley with this draw that's nine points
uh gets uh he'll be tied for third
fourth why what i mean alireza is above
him and jan will be above him he dies
for third fourth ah sorry he gets seven
and a half
so he gets seven and a half it's still
enough he'll be up by a point he'll be a
buy point he'll be up by a point so you
are right yeah so he gets he gets third
and yan probably gets fourth but it's
not enough it's not enough right now
don't argue with winning coaches from
saint louis university they will shame
you
and this is another result shaq has
drawn against levon ironian i think a
lot of the interest of that game was
left in the sidelines but it was a
fascinating opening and that means we
have one game left in the grand chess
tour 2022 waiting to see if yonder pony
she actually takes the the tournament
clear first yeah because the engines
love his position more and more and more
and more
now this has gone off the rails for hans
because now rook hay just basically wins
the h6 pawn for not very much
uh yeah this just has to be winning
right yeah i mean you just collect on h6
and the rook will escape like if if your
plan is perhaps to like
uh rook h8 king e7 rook takes h6 rook g8
it does lock the rook down for like one
move but then it will escape i'm pretty
sure yeah unfortunately the rook on h5
is actually not a bad piece yeah yeah
just go rook h5 provoke five and once
we're up a pawn we might even you know
invest in e3 e4 somewhere just to free
that brook up mm-hmm you know knight d3
might be winning many many things at
that point become
the floodgates are open um exactly in
this position after rook a a6 rook sorry
okay
important not to blend the ruby six
check in the rook trade right after
which we would not be better at all yeah
yeah um
do i have some ideas of rook t6 and
bishop f5 peter because i think i think
we're like at this point we're pretty
much always running into some knight b3
shenanigans because like i can actually
start trading pawns because h6 is just
by far the most important
rookie six maybe even the immediate
knight b3 frankly i said all right rook
d6 just a side step just a side step by
five all together yes you can take on c4
but like all of those enemies will be
horrible because h6 is i think is just
so much more important something like
this just i'm putting some moves on the
board just take one h6 yeah
gosh i doesn't look right it doesn't
look right for me can i take advantage
of the fact that you're king
it's not that weak and the rook on g4
really isn't
creating too much trouble for it
um
rook h8 on the board and alejandro i
mean
hans has been kind of in a spin cycle
and let's face it this young man
the whole world's been jumping on the
bandwagon it's been very tough for him
to concentrate on the second half of the
tournament
um he's in deep trouble here yeah you
might be redeemable at this point that's
a big pawn that he's losing on h6 none
of the counter play really works
actually against rook d6 if we look at
this position uh rook t6 uh taking on h6
not so good because bishop f5 knight b3
not bad but king c1 just consolidates
everything it's again the fact that this
rook can't target the pawn on c4 right
so i just go rogue c3 against most
things like for example bishop f5
particularly in this position let's go
of the attack on c4 so i can play either
rook c3 winning or rook b2 winning just
defend the rook h6 is going to hang next
move that's pretty much it so kingston
won a nice consolidation move it might
be the only one to win super clearly but
it's it's that's great
rook d6 king c1 very impressive yeah
that would be that would be a nice that
would
yes but rook h8 on the board
and sorry just remind me i mean hans has
gone into the spin cycle
he's lost a couple in a row not in a row
i think he made a kind of a he lost in
round six and i think he made the draw
in round seven and lost yesterday so he
is uh
uh he is on a half a point out of three
stretch
half a point out of three yeah yeah it's
it's tough it it is very tough coming
into the event i basically said as the
lowest rated player he's got this giant
bullseye target on his back
and then the first three rounds he
played very very well of course as we
all know and
and culminating with a fantastic victory
over magnus that precipitated this uh
the bursting of the dam and uh
well we all know where that goes uh but
rook h8 on the board and hans as you can
see on your screen is studying the
position but in the we meanwhile we have
our second place finisher
in the grand chess tour suited up ready
to go with alejandro and that is
grandmaster wesley so wesley saw
literally jumping out of his seat to
analyze some more chess here with us
wesley first of all congratulations on
your overall performance in the grand
chess tour you got second place how do
you feel
well first of all uh thanks for having
me and the reason why i want to look at
other players games because i played so
bad that
i want to look at other games and not
mine
but
i mean of course second place that's not
bad but
after what i did yesterday i mean it was
probably one of my biggest choke
choker in my history of choking which
happens quite a lot
tell us about yesterday what happened
you saw yourself
surely with a huge attack
yeah i mean the problem i guess is first
of all i was probably preparing too much
between my games like i had two rest
days in this tournament and i was
preparing like a few hours
during those rest days probably never a
good idea because you consume a lot of
energy then you can get good position on
the board but preparation cannot really
win you games and uh
i think fearlej was playing badly in the
beginning
and uh
i surprised him in the opening because i
never played this a6 a5 line before
so
i had no problems after i played knight
h5 i was very happy
obviously i just didn't want to lose the
game
because it practically
guarantees winning the grand chester if
i drew yesterday
um
so when playing knight h5 with f6
i
was just trying to play risk-free but i
couldn't exactly understand what's
happening like i think
alireza played very well practically
like he played knights he takes e5 very
quickly in this position here yeah
like i thought
his position is super suspicious
but at the same time he took on e5 very
confidently so that kind of
confused me a little bit so
psychologically a little impact there
yeah i think uh i must say i have big
respect for alireza i hope he
becomes the world champion one day i'm
very impressed with his play so far
winning st louis rapid and blitz and
he's only 19 years old so i think
possibly he would be the best player of
his generation
on his age i mean some people like him
some people don't i i for one i like
watching his games what do you mean what
some people don't what do they don't
like about his chaz
uh well also the
personality and all that like if a new
the new player on the block
you've got little quirks like
i
i you know i know people in the chess
world and
some people just don't know him very
well also he switched federation
to france recently and he has
little quirks here and there during
tournaments like like for example
um
he doesn't have a good relationship with
the wycombe state tournament right now
or also some organizers but
i guess the game is what
matters the most and he's number four in
the world and uh i think he's very
strong he
still has a lot of weaknesses currently
but nothing that can't be fixed and he's
only 19. so uh
i'm
very impressed with him and i think
magnus is as well but i think in this
tournament he has several suspicious
positions like he played very well the
rapping blitz but in the classical
uh he made quite a lot of errors like he
was losing against shaq
and i think he has
was losing yesterday
and
he wasn't really able to put much
pressure in the opening but
but um as i said he played knights he
takes e5 very quickly so uh
he's he calculates really well and he
makes very good practical decisions but
anyway after bishop hr knight d3 i
saw i saw the winning line like uh
i saw rook 88 and then only move knight
before
queen g6
yeah the the problem with the
grandchild store tournaments is that you
can never oh you guess you can't move
huh i'm not sure why
yeah because your brows oh you have to
click russian practice
oh you're oh sorry oh there you go yeah
sure okay
yeah so i was gonna play this
obviously if it's a blitz game i would
just play without without thought right
yeah queen g6
queen f3 bishop g4 we need three and i
guess i didn't realize that this
position is totally winning because uh
the main point is that uh yeah bishop
visits the bishop the main point is that
black has three attackers on the king
side the queen the bishop and the knight
and white has really no defenders maybe
only the queen and if you watch gary
kasparov's videos on teaching chess he
always calculates that if you have more
attackers than your opponent on one side
then you have an advantage there but i
just didn't think about it
after a game but the main point is i'm
turning c5 and i missed after bishop a3
like i thought if my calculations like i
mean through pigs d4 cd4 bd4
windy 4 bishop f3 g3 ato is through but
only miss knight g3
you missed knight g3 yeah i forgot that
you could sacrifice one more piece yeah
yeah that's what you actually got all
the way to this position yeah i got all
the way here oh what a pity and i
thought queen g4 e3 ah you got queen g4
trying to mate him on the light squares
and you saw rookie three yeah and i was
like
i was like hey
i was trying to play normal played safe
and i was like hey i could be worse here
like i'm down the road
but do you think if that thought process
that a draw was sufficient to clinch the
grandchester hadn't been on your mind
and you had that more killer instinct in
this position you would have been able
to find ig3 yeah definitely i think
yesterday i made several mistakes like
first of all i was too nervous thinking
about the result and all that i mean
obviously
winning the granchester would be a big
deal again because you play all year
round also i think i was preparing too
much between
um
[Music]
but also maybe oh nice maybe it's just
not my day
but um
yeah it's hard to say uh
it's just
it's uh it's not so easy for me
sometimes to play irrational positions
even if they're better for me like
positions i've never seen before and
yesterday was unfortunately was one and
alireza's just
better than me at that on those kinds of
positions so
but it's not so bad like i would still
be happy to get a door on this game like
on move 21 she takes h3
and
you know i i saw rook e5 i was about to
play it
but i didn't but i think after if i
played e5 but still wouldn't lose like
he was gonna play bishop c1
maybe queen h3 is possible but
roxy f5 is safe
and
he can play queen after if he wants to
win right but after rookie
i don't see how black can ever be worse
no it looks like it's very safe yeah he
said he was gonna play queen g4 instead
of queen of three yeah yeah but that's
not a winning attempt right yeah take
six knight up six and then i think he
was going to play c4 right
did he say yeah in the interview yeah
big but c4 is not the best movie after
exit 3 is a draw i guess
we can have their c4 actually white is
slightly worse after knight g4
but either way no no pressure on you
wesley when i think of you in the grand
chest store i think of consistency thank
you you're so kind well i'm not kind i
just look at the numbers tell me what is
the secret that
you always finish in the top
well i mean been playing grand chester
for like six years
in a row
um
[Music]
i don't know i guess i
respect my opponent so much that i enjoy
playing against the
best players in the world um i love
watching you know guys like ian or fears
or magnus play
and
you know i don't mind playing rapid and
blitz also i enjoy those formats a lot
like remember 2016. i first i played my
first uh rapid and blitz like that kind
of format in paris in belgium you were
there i remember you
you're watching some fabby's game so i
thought the format is
the format of rapid and blitz is very
fun and
also you learn you learn a lot
i mean all the classical is much more
serious but i think the fact that you
play the same opponents over and over
again and it's a learning process
and you get used to them and it's you
know it's fun and exciting
and um
i have years where i do very well
but i've won it before yeah i won it i
won before
well wesley congratulations on your
second place surely it's a good year for
you
yeah we'll see yeah well hopefully you
do better in the next the next one but i
must say also congratulations to
aliretha i guess he won the grandchester
he did yes yeah and probably ian wins
the same field yeah well we'll take a
look as we keep our eyes on this game it
is the last game of the tournament and
of the grand chester jan seems favorite
to win the engines do give him a
decisive advantage wesley thank you for
joining us here in the studio thank you
wesley just uh one quick question as you
may very well be aware
it's it's tragic story but i'm being put
to work
am being asked to choose the brilliancy
the tournament
and had you won yesterday in the style
that you were showing you would have
been a very clear favorite clear of
winning uh five thousand dollars in the
brilliancy prize
wait wait
yeah because you didn't
i've got to ask you uh help me guide me
i'm a i'm a judge along with peter but
what was the brilliant game
what are the choices
yeah but i mean there are 40 games i
mean
so what are you thinking the
game we were thinking uh ali raza versus
lavonne uh from i think it was round two
before yeah
what else
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
i mean that's that's interesting like
alert played perfect moves there
sacrifice food it was not perfect but it
was a very fun and exciting game yeah
there was one one particular move by
laressa that was very questionable and
the rest was very good yeah the thing is
like
when the one played g5 the game was
pretty much over and alireza just played
very confidently sacrificing a piece
um
let's see what what other games are
there
what other candidates i mean i could
name a couple
that's what we're asking you to do
there really isn't very much else apart
apart from that game i really don't know
where
it feels to me that jan is trying some
kind of a very very elaborate level
which kind of makes you makes you praise
alireza some more
uh that was
my feeling was about what yes i was
attempting to do but by the way yeah we
mine was on screen uh alejandro's wasn't
but there is a bunch of surprise pikachu
faces in the studio right now because he
undeclined to take on h6
for reasons which uh i can only describe
his reasons
yeah maybe he just wants to reach 40 and
also it's been a lot yes he has 50
minutes i don't think he needs to reach
40. before that's before that's before
yeah
i think he's okay yeah
you know he went through it's an hour
30.
[Laughter]
so yeah i'm not sure what's going on
here and the the prediction that jan
will will win this game has become a bit
trickier in the in the last five minutes
i guess if you think he's worried about
rook g8 trying to drop the rook now yeah
but yeah we looked at this but even
after e4 we thought the i mean he's just
doing great oh yeah e4 is very uh
yeah e4 is very strong once you see it
but it's also very uh
yeah yeah this is very concrete i guess
that's why we have yeah
e4 yeah it's very clean so this is the
current position but now the rook is in
the sixth rank so you can defend the
pawn yeah the problem black has so many
double pawns
so many double isolated ones yes sir
yeah yeah yeah
we'll save that for the ultimate moves
wesley we have a number of people right
behind yeah ready to come uh thank you
so much uh for joining us and uh
congratulations on your second place
the grand chess tour yeah thank you so
much to everyone who made the
granchester possible to you guys also
thank you wesley thank you wesley uh
okay we are confused come on what is
going on i didn't yeah i really i really
didn't understand
come on peter i really liked the patient
way he was playing until then and
actually once the rook landed on h6 if
we if we go through the game a little
bit right the rook landed on h6 on move
uh
36 yeah and then he spent two tempi
playing a2 a3 and rook c2 c3 which i
thought was very very clever because you
do want to stabilize as much as possible
on the queen side before you go in and
allow this rook h61 g8 setup right but
then you have to take on h6 exactly
eventually you have to you know
this whole threat is stronger than the
execution is
kind of bunk you know it's taken to
to the next level yeah this is
bank science so you you like this whole
uh right here a3 very nice restricting
the rope yeah five rooks e3 i still like
very very good but then just take take
the damn pawn now it's time to collect
the harvest and it had to be this move
rook g8 that put him off beater and then
we were looking at e3 e4 yeah 34 looks
logical you can play i'm guessing rook
h5 first and then e4 but there's no
particular reason to even wait there we
go and
and as we uh continue to battle between
ourselves uh let's jump back to
alejandro as a
linear dominguez is uh with alejandro
welcome lanier
welcome to the studio a long grand chess
tour
what do you feel about your results
uh well i
did
quite well in the um
classic part but
of course
i
i didn't do so well in the rabbit and
blitz so that's something to to work on
i guess
because i felt that in the classical
tournaments i was having my chances and
even in this tournament of course i i
feel that i should have done better
because i just
didn't convert three clearly winning
positions so in general
i was i was feeling quite okay in the
classical but yeah not so much in the in
the rabbit and blitz unfortunately i
have to say after your game against fabi
where you were losing but managed to
save it it felt that the theme of the
tournament was linear almost won yes
what was missing for you to get those
full points yeah i don't know i guess i
was lacking a bit of energy especially
because i was playing long games
most of the time
and uh
just yeah at the end i mean
it was a bit unfortunate because i mean
it in some of the games it like
yesterday for example it seemed that i
was
doing everything um
everything okay but then at the end i
was just missing the last
just the last uh
and uh but i think yeah the lack of
probably lack of energy was was
was crucial
in my games
i know that yesterday peter svidler saw
you in the street and he couldn't help
himself but to ask
what you chose in this particular
position a random move i i yeah i play
king h3 without realizing that king king
h4 loses i don't know what what i was
thinking but yeah it's i mean
uh
it would have been
really painful to to lose that way so
i guess i mean i was actually happy when
peter told me that at least something
that i can be happy about like a little
positivity from the game right yeah
it was a crazy queen end game but it
definitely felt that you had it in the
bag
um right how do you recover from these
positions where you're not winning
you're not winning they must take a toll
on you
yeah i mean it's it's uh it's really
uh unpleasant at least for me i mean
it's uh sometimes it
it's even more unpleasant than than to
lose a game uh just uh to spoil some
completely winning position because you
the the the feeling of the missed
chances is really annoying and it's it's
stays there for for some time but
on the other hand i of course
try to to look at the next game to look
at the future i mean
i came to realize at some point that uh
you don't have to be so dramatic in in
chess or you know it's it's just
you of course you will miss chances you
will miss huge chances and sometimes you
will
uh get lucky so it's better to try to be
a little bit pragmatic so that's what i
think of it's still kind of annoying but
i mean that's that's at least what i
what i try to do and
um just just try to to keep going spoken
from a lot of experience linear you are
the leading player to come from latin
america speaking of the future tell us
what's in store for you
yeah well i i still have some some um
exciting tournaments this year first of
all the the 960 which is always fun
uh then uh the u.s championship of
course it's it's a
big event uh
i'll try to
to
to be ready for that and then also some
online
tournaments as well so uh
um still some chess to to to be played
well near you've always dazzled us with
your theory we certainly look forward to
seeing more of your games here in the
960 and of course in the u.s
championships coming up starting on
october 5th thank you for joining us
here in the studio and on your results
here especially in the classical side of
the grand chess tour thank you
indeed uh thank you uh lanier just
missing the final touch in a couple of
those games might have been like that
yeah if he had doubled on the c file
against hans neiman and when he did
could hardly move if he had found that
winning move against nepo
a terrific result and as he said u.s
championships the
um
bobby fischer fischer random all coming
up we still have quite a number of
events coming up here in st louis and in
this
and we still have it this game
ongoing king c2 b2 uh peter did
the failure to capture the h6 pawn uh
spoil things or is it still white is
still better but i think now
there's a very very big question mark
over how we're making progress because
black has sort of is back to being
somewhat stable right
black really doesn't have any threats
anymore the the situation where we got
the moves a3 and rook c3 and
really really stabilized our situation
on the queen side the queen side is
really not in any danger anymore exactly
but
i mean a7 has been covered c5 is
difficult to attack because c4 is always
hanging and we didn't take on h6 when we
could so now maybe we will not be uh
allowed to do it again but we do have
another interview so let's uh let's go
today
to shaq
always a fun player to watch
shaq you definitely brought a fun to the
game but didn't score as many points as
you would like how do you rate your
performance not only in this tournament
but in the grand chess tour
of course it's of course it was not very
good
tournaments for me i mean all
tournaments i played not very well
i think it's a big problem for me i
played too much this year and
i just was very tired
i miss many
moves many games
and in this tournament and it was last
for me i mean last like uh
uh
last thing is how i lose is
there is a i mean absolutely a very good
position i lose in two moves or three
maybe
because
it's very strange for me yeah i think
i just was very tired and i miss i
blundered too much
uh you said that you're tired you've
been playing a lot of tournaments not
only the gran chester you of course also
played the olympiad
what are you going to do in the next few
months will you also have a full
schedule of tournaments or will you take
some rest
okay i have some contracts tournaments
of course i will play all my tournaments
which
i agreed
but
it's problem really i played too much i
say
i mean i calculate
i mean just
two weeks ago
i will pray in this year about
rapid
classical
and is uh like magnus store is all
together is about 300 games in just
classical and rapid without planting
bloods
rapidly i mean also
i mean grand tour village rapid and
i played only grand tour builds rapid
and also magnus tour
i think four tournaments or three or
four tournaments
and also i play in
classical chess about the 70 75 games
it's also yeah
i mean you play every time in the very
high level uh every time your opponent
is very strong
and after
some moments i just play i just
play animals in opening because
everything is finished and no home
preparation is like hotel preparation
absolutely very bad
openings and
i i will try not to eat till next year
and i will try to next year
to play not too much like this year i
just
relax preparing for chess and enjoy from
life do you feel that this is one of the
main differences between you and this
teenage players who never run out of
energy i mean normally i
never miss or
play like i played against al rizza i
mean i i got a very good adventure and i
just losing three moves and normally you
know i
i miss every move for
after take pawn i i don't know i mean
it's just it is only my fault i mean
this is
because when it was coveted uh we not
play chess after covet i think okay
i miss chess i need to play chess i will
play all tournaments why not but okay
when i start to play the whole
tournaments i agree
i mean
to play all tournaments and now i see it
was big mistake and
i'm really very tired i am very happy
tournament is not finished for me like
catastrophic i mean just as -2 is
absolutely
normal
results like
super tournaments like this because it's
not catastrophe i'm just a very bad
result yeah of course but it is not
catastrophe and
i will sing what to do and they will
think how to back well shaq we of course
love you to have to have you back we'd
love to have you at your peak because
you're such a fun player to watch thanks
for joining us here at the granchester
this year thank you very much good luck
thanks
thank you shaq one of those
you can play too much peter too much of
a good thing absolutely really ruin you
and as he said i like that hotel
preparation that was that was a very
very good sound
no longer home preparation
hotels
300 360
that's a bit much that's a lot of games
in one year what was maybe your maximum
number of games at your peak like
i've never really calculated but uh
maybe a hundred
no i'm sure i played 115 some years but
i mean there's a big difference between
150 and 300 yes i think you know
including rapid than blitz like 150 is
manageable maybe even 200 is manageable
but 300 is way way way too much brutal
and we have another interview with uh
alejandro
thank you guys we're here with lavonna
ronyan also finishing in the grand chess
tour a bit of a topsy-turvy tournament
for you but at the end how do you rate
your performance in the entire tour
not too proud i can say that but
you know
i think
after the olympiad i really
i'm not
feeling like myself so
it's okay you know uh
it's uh as
there is a saying you know it's a cloud
it has to pass so
i'm waiting for the cloud to pass and
things will be good again so
but
generally of course it's very enjoyable
to play here and the tournament is very
exciting with some very interesting
games so
and you regaled us with plenty of those
when you mention this cloud and you're
waiting for it to pass do you think that
this cloud partially is the fact that
you've been playing so much
no
i don't think i'm playing too much
because i
had a long
pause and
i i generally feel comfortable playing a
lot so
i
you know i can't imagine doing something
else throughout the day so
this is something that makes me happy
and plenty of chess upcoming for you
you'll be playing the 960 as well as the
us championship coming up that's right
yeah yeah it's okay
oh it's exciting to see you guys any
questions here for for the one as i'm
trying to keep an eye on this game
between
jan and hans and the more i say the more
confused i get yeah i think maybe we
could ask one about this because we put
him to work come on our perspective has
been kind of on the record so
if you had if you didn't know anything
about what happened before do you think
white has
a lot of winning chances not a lot of
winning chances none whatsoever what's
happening here
i guess somehow maybe he needs to bring
his king to the king side and try to
play with f3 you know
that's my feeling because somehow
i don't see any way he can get any you
know
progress but
maybe his rook might get trapped yeah
the rook is uh
is in awkward position do you mean this
rock on one eight or eight right um
yeah somehow i think uh
i think black should have enough how to
play here
it feels uh like
without seeing the previous it feels uh
like black has comfortably got his rooks
active and uh his rook on a6 is uh
controlling the pace so should be a draw
i guess
yeah draw team's favorite the engine is
also dropping the evaluation and that
would give us a playoff an exciting
playoff here for the singfield cup of
course uh the grand chess tour has been
taken tell us a little bit about this
newcomer to the gct you know already
comes into st louis blazing hot
destroys the st louis rapid and blitz
there's no other way to put it and then
performs very well here takes the gct
your thoughts on him
oh he's a brilliant player and a player
who doesn't get discouraged
uh and uh he's a is a great fighter so
and it's very exciting to see
somebody who plays uh fighting chess to
you know perform well you know it means
uh
for me personally i mean i'm more of the
romantic
players so it's good to see somebody
who's doing something similar succeed
and
it gives me hope
hope in what sense
well you know if you can play
romantically and
maybe
slightly incorrect you know
it means this
chess is not all pragmatic you know so
chess is still
very much
a game where you can take a risk and
achieve success do you think his
practicality is what is currently
setting him aside from some of the other
players in this tournament or some
people from his generation
i think he's very impractical that's
what i mean
and that is definitely setting him aside
from from other players so
it's it's it's his comparative advantage
pride of advantage well thank you for
joining us here in the studio i know it
was a topsy-turvy grandchild tour but
certainly hoping to see you in the next
year's edition and very soon in the us
championship thank you very much uh
quick question for you uh
uh
lavonne a quick question but maybe a
difficult uh one to answer as well
world champion magnus carlson has
abdicated his throne he is not going to
be playing anymore in the fide world
championship cycle
does this motivate you or the reverse
does this disappoint and depress you
it doesn't matter for me actually you
know it's uh
if
i regain my form
i don't care
who i'm playing you know i'm always
excited to play against anybody
so it's it's not that i think magnus is
unbeatable
there you go here you go thank you for
that
thank you uh lavon and good
luck to you in the official random as
well as the u.s championships we'll be
calling the action
and uh still peter we have this one game
remaining yan draws the game we want to
inform everybody there will be a playoff
later today between 6 30. yeah we even
know when which is uh 6 30 doesn't
probably uh give a
uh too much information to our viewers
that's in two and a half hours time
pretty much and do we know what the
tiebreaker is going to be uh by the way
is it the two 20-minute games and then
the blitz or is it something else we can
we can find out perhaps alejandro
already knows i think we have a graphic
eve that would be that would be good
yeah see how i like i like throwing the
production
under the bus there you go they all
you threw them into a tizzy there you go
playoff scenario if two players tie for
first we play a rapid double
round okay
that's right
that's basically
what are you doing there at the truck
man double round two players
it's a match it's a match of ten plus
five two games one with white one with
black still tied we go straight into the
armageddon there is no blitz
yeah and three players could not no
longer no longer relevant because wesley
did not win today uh so yeah the top the
the top part of this graphic is is the
relevant one and it is basically a two
game ten plus five match and if that
ends one one we just go straight into
the the death match yeah the armageddon
death match there it is well and that
will be coming up if this game that is
ongoing uh does go into a draw and uh
which is a big if i mean it's still far
from over oh absolutely yeah absolutely
and we just saw again uh kind of a lot
of twoing and throwing yes uh not too
much but we we had just seen a moment
ago
hans played the move bishop
and then back to e6 yeah yeah the
engines actually kind of severely
disagree with compared to the best move
in the position no
you went from zeros to plus one for in
my opinion no apparent reason well i
mean there is sort of a reason now if we
can go back to the position just just to
move prior yeah and the engines were
very adamant that after king bisou
you're supposed to go rogue g6
and you can actually i think you can
actually
logically understand why that is because
uh with the setup with a3 and rook c3
the rook on g4 really isn't doing very
much attacking the pawn on c4 no and
there's always those f3 issues as well
that as well yeah so you know bringing
it over to let's say g6 or b6 and
generating counter play uh via frontal
attacks towards uh
against the white setup it's just a lot
a lot more sensible and also just very
tactically
he's played bishop e6 jan blitzed out
took h8 which is the best move it is
yeah and now h6 is hanging again right
and if you play bishop g7 again you are
allowing knight b3 which is what we've
been aspiring
to do
and suddenly there are once again
questions for you to answer because
you're currently not attacking the pawn
on c4 you're definitely not taking the
pawn on a3
and things will start getting shed like
you can play with v6 i will get i will
go king c1 okay if i c64k8 i think is
very awkward this is this is very
awkward yeah and
you start getting slightly like torn
apart here and slightly torn somewhat
somewhat thrown apart yes
drawn and cornered with something that
we wanted uh back in the day this is
still not as big of an advantage as jan
would have had if he just snapped on h6
move 39 i'm still kind of flabbergasted
this didn't happen it's the whole knight
b3 activation
that i am very very excited about once
that knight gets in the game rook d6 on
the board we're expecting king c1 c2 i
don't know which one to choose both look
logical uh it becomes i think dark
squares peter it's a light square bishop
on the board you know how it goes
kingston already played yeah i mean jan
is definitely making a bit of a bit of
progress here but yeah you just keep on
coming back to the decision to not do
what your entire plans seem to be
culminating in uh we do have a move
after king c1
we should be seven years they're playing
very very quickly i'm pretty sure both
of them are still
not out of the first time control on the
clock despite this being more 47 i think
i mean young definitely has 43 minutes
from the first time control right i
think hans also hasn't uh uh run out of
his first 19 minutes yeah they've been
playing playing at a pretty pr
fast rate
i'll get there peter um
knight b3 93 definitely uh
there are also
also other moves available here the
engine for for instance on my screen and
uh yes in this game i've just given up
and i'm at least inquiring other things
apparently a3a4 is strong again for a3
a4 unplayable move i don't think i don't
think considering the positions in which
he hasn't played it already wouldn't
have crossed yeah i don't think you're
playing it here it just feels very very
strange but the the point being that any
captures you've got
you're you're activating your rook and
in more general terms it seems like we
are pretty much always interested in
getting that pawn to a5 because taking
away the b6 square from the rogue huge
is just a huge achievement but yeah i
think a4 is a very very difficult move
to even consider in this position uh
it's not the only one that gives a bit
of an advantage to white though but
knightly three uh number three
yeah
you'd go back i don't know i don't know
it doesn't look great at all i don't
know like 93 for some reason isn't isn't
the suggestion i've been trying to you
know understand why you actually use the
brain for for a change and the brain
says no no so i
maybe it is bishop b6 simply wow maybe
it is actually just be safe all right
peter we are going to take a break but
when we come back we will have the
exciting conclusion of our one remaining
game and will there be a tiebreaker and
a playoff or we'll find out soon we have
a clear winner
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institution's
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is
credibility a journalist's work revolves
around the truth
finding it
verifying it and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back and as
i assume you have seen on your screen
there uh this was probably not the most
perfectly timed break ever in history on
this show because we kind of expected it
to be ongoing and ongoing actually it's
not the case peter yeah it seemed like
it was a safe a safe moment to take a
bit of a breather but jan after king c1
bishop d7
uh chose
basically a move that is a bit of a draw
offer because i don't think you can miss
bishop a4 no it's it's what you've
played bishop g7 iv pretty much right
yeah and once again we're watching the
ios station yeah they're
obviously it's been a confusing endgame
for both of them i'm pretty sure that
the right
they they haven't really oriented
themselves perfectly well
you were mentioning knight b3 as a
potential draw for peter because after
bishop before i think
your choice suddenly becomes you either
make in the media draw the one uh the
one that jan actually made in the game
with knight c5 rook demand check and
that black has a very very comfortable
perpetual due to the fact that it
happened due to the fact that with the
king on b1 you cannot play rook c1
uh that loses the knight on c5 right you
want check you can avoid the perpetual
but that costs you the game immediately
so it's a very good idea uh and then
it's just a very very comfortable draw
for black or you can maybe after knight
knight be three bish by four you can
play knight g2 back but then white did
yeah it seems like 93 was a draw for
once again
uh the preferred solution here to make
progress with white from this position
onwards appears actually to be connected
with this idea of a 4a5 and as we keep
on uh mentioning throughout the
broadcast it just seems like this idea
was very much off the radar for
and we can't really blame him all that
much it's a very difficult move in
particular here
where
i personally would have found it very
difficult as well a4a5 but i did like
what lavonne aronian was suggesting
which was maybe you can bring the king
over to the king's side and maybe on a
very very good day prep f2 f3
i mean it would have taken a lots of
steps peter it wasn't uh it wasn't the
layup but the move a4 a5 you know it
just this is this is never easy yeah
this is never easy and
and this is really the story of this
entire end game is that uh
i think
really the way the way jan played it
he played it kind of
excellently well but also i think
without the belief that he was much
better right even when he was
and that maybe let him down a little bit
that the somewhat unusually for him he
he was making good decisions but i think
they were made with the underlying
impression that he is not going to have
much of an advantage anyway he was
pessimistic in the position
should have been more optimistic what
does it mean it means with this the
fourth draw
of this final round that we do have a
tie and at 6
30 our time
we're going to have playoffs between the
two players who typed it first for the
sinkhole cup title keeping in mind that
ali reza has already won the grand
chester
and uh over to you uh alejandra for your
thoughts about our break
nicely timed you shouldn't have told us
to do it
well sometimes we need a little bit of a
breather but i am surprised about how
this game went it felt that nepal got
everything that he wanted he just didn't
take on h6 and you kind of wonder why
you put your rook on h8 right you
weren't actually going to take that pawn
but we'll get a chance to interview napo
see what he has to say about that
particular move we'll certainly let him
go early because he has as you guys
mentioned so i'm prepped to do he's
playing ali resign a couple of hours
that's going to be for the sink field
cup title it doesn't really matter how
many gcd points are distributed we
already did the math for that already
does get first place no matter uh what
the result of the playoff is but we want
to know who takes the same field cup
home right exactly that and this is the
moment peter
a three of five a bit a bit later even
yeah well right here rook h8
i like a3 i don't mind a3 at all you
don't mind no i don't like i don't mind
it i also don't mind rook c3 i think
getting as prepared as possible before
sniping on h6 is good but now you think
now's the time now you take and then we
were interviewing i believe uh it was
live on or no but that was the early
interview and i saw rook h8 b8 on my
screen in this position and i just went
what
uh his choice in fact was rook h8
yeah and which is just very very
difficult to figure out we have to
imagine that rook g8 is what dissuaded
him probably but now we can actually ask
and uh
uh and and find out what
what the others perspective was because
e3 e4
uh was where we were heading but again
we're getting
uh ian miked up
for an interview and to talk about the
sinkhole cup yeah let's let's let's go
to alejandro
thank you guys here with your nephew
yeah we're not going to keep you very
long we know that you have prep to do
for your thai break we're just going to
ask you this why didn't you take the
pawn here oh because i'm immoral so
that's
that's only question i mean anyway i
felt like it's like winning by
any sequence of moves because i mean
okay this position
you know speaks to it first speaks for
itself yeah like but
i mean uh i thought i mean frankly i put
like any sequence of moves at least to
victory but i mean once i let him like
push king d7 bishop to seven i think
it's not so easy anymore yeah definitely
not and at the end of the day okay i
just blundered that rookie one rook c1
uh i mean i think the one rookie one
check i can't protect with roxy one
because it's you actually blundered it
yeah i it's okay i'm not i wasn't going
to make a draw anyway uh so far so fast
yeah but probably
some games before this tournament i got
lucky and at this point
nothing to be proud
yeah and you still can win the singfield
cup you still have a playoff to play
against alaresa your thoughts about the
match coming up i don't care
why don't you care
i mean okay if i play like this game
that's probably nothing could help me so
i mean if i play like uh i don't know if
i can take a pawn in one move so
yeah probably i go have some rest and
i'll see what happens will you do
exactly that the playoff is in a couple
of hours and we'll see that action
good luck in the playoff
napo uh disappointed and understandably
so he had maybe the sinkhole cup in his
hands he just didn't yeah finishing
touches what lanier was uh lacking yeah
and i it appears i was entirely wrong
about my assessment of what happened
there because like
the the the two theories are either you
actually don't believe you're better
which is difficult to explain but maybe
or you think anything wins whereas and
then you think anything yeah yeah and
the anion went the the uh
overboard on the other side and he was
wrong because then he he made
it very difficult for himself in this
move a3 a4
uh we didn't ask john about that i mean
uh but he still has much to play with
exactly exactly
but we have his opponent hans neiman in
studio with alejandro aleandra hans it's
the end of your first super tournament
what did you think of your play
in the game or overall overall
well i think um
i have mixed feelings about my play
obviously because the the beginning
was starting i think my first four games
uh were i was so happy with
and i think in the first four games i i
could have likely i could even scored
four to four based on the chances and i
was winning in every single one of those
games
and then after that um
i just uh
the pressure of playing my first super
tournament combined with everything it
was uh it was a lot to handle and uh
i wasn't able to manage my nerves and in
many critical moments i just completely
choked
so obviously these
the second half was very difficult
to place a strong opposition under such
pressure on and off the board
but i think considering the
circumstances the fact that i have
survived is a miracle
so i'm very happy with
at least maybe not this game but
it's over and uh okay 50 if you include
the magnus win
with considering the circumstances i
think is a very good result and uh i
think that if i could play with the
clear mind and no drama i'm sure i would
have done much better before the
tournament did you imagine yourself
scoring 50 in the first try against
these 2700 plus imagine scoring higher
than that so
what did you feel about some of the
other games pressure got to you do you
feel that was the reason that you
weren't able to get some good positions
of course it's uh
uh
immediately after round four uh i had my
routine was ruined i was barely sleeping
i was waking up much later than usual my
preparation suffered
my i was much less calm i was extremely
nervous and anxious at the board because
uh when you're playing chess you need to
only be thinking about chess and you
simply can't afford to think about
anything else especially playing at such
a high level
um so
i think i'm at least happy that i showed
my
my ability to play under normal
circumstances
um as we saw in these first four games
which were i think amazing to be honest
and
after that i guess i went into survival
mode and okay i lost these two games
against wesley and fabiano with white
and like that i should absolutely have
never lost these games um
i think at fabian maybe there were like
four junctions
where i could have
i had like four chances to just
you know shut things down
even more and i failed at every single
attempt just because
my mind wasn't in the right place
and uh against wesley this is just
completely uncalled for and okay when
your opponent plays the petrov you
should not be losing uh
you survived the tournament it's over
for you in the sink field cup you were
the center of a very tumultuous event
what are you going to do next
well um
i guess now that the tournament is over
it's time to
reflect on the chess first of all um and
to reflect how many things that have
happened and uh my next classical event
is the u.s championship so of course i'm
looking forward to that
and
i'm just uh i just hope to have a day
where i can uh
not look at social media and uh
just uh just enjoy life and be relaxed
and have a clear mind so i'm hoping that
i can i'm looking forward to some peace
and uh
i guess we're gonna some things we'll
see how things uh move forward you have
several weeks until the u.s championship
gets started you're gonna be playing
some of these top players there as well
what are you gonna be doing in those
weeks to prepare yourself mentally
well i think that
having time to recover first of all
will be really important
second of all
i think
just having a stable routine is really
important you know in this tournament
in the first few rounds i was
going to sleep at like 9 30 p.m
and i was waking up quite early i would
go swim laps for about half an hour then
i would
eat around the exact same time i would
prepare i would it was also structured
and also disciplined
and that kind of collapsed
at some point event and that had a very
detrimental effect and what you do off
the board
and how you prepare for the game
mentally physically is extremely
important especially at this level of
play so i wasn't able to maintain that
routine but i think that with more
physical exercise with more training and
again the experience from this event i
think will
be really really important because my
first super tournament classical and uh
i think that there are a lot of sort of
tweaks that come into
super tournament chess speaking
specifically about the chess considering
this is your first super tournament what
did you notice you need to change
well um i definitely need to be more
risk-averse um uh if you have a spectrum
and you compare me and wesley
i would say that that is certainly a
parabolic uh
he's extremely risk-averse and
i've noticed that
each player is always extremely strong
but i've noticed differences in how they
make certain decisions at certain
moments
so obviously against wesley when i play
this move h4 lying at h5 i think that
any strong player would have simply okay
take on f6 take on d5 i'm never going to
lose the game ever
and that is a very let's say
professional approach and these types of
conscious decisions will prevent
all unnecessary losses and uh if you
look at the losses in this tournament
it's not like i was
completely dominated and not played they
were completely self-inflicted
um the loss against white wesson was
self-inflicted
the loss against white was
against fabi was completely
self-inflicted with his insane move g4
so uh the law says that i'm not losing
um
i'm losing because i'm
losing objectivity losing my calm and
not
avoiding risk and and that's simply the
name of the game like you look at a guy
like dominguez this guy's so
so risk-averse and it's really difficult
to beat them they're not going to win a
lot of games but
uh the important thing from my from my
opinion is just to take your chances and
the chances will come if you just like
if you can play nine games and never be
lost that's statistically you're going
to win some games do you feel this is a
rest of you from playing so many opens
and so many people that are lower rated
than you no of course yeah the the the
playstyle needs to adapt and
that has been a really weird process
because when you gain so much reading so
quickly and you're
adapting from different
tournament structures the tournament
structure really requires different type
of chess for example these guys shape
their entire repertoire
around simply forcing a draw in the most
concrete manner some players do it
someplace don't but if you look at like
yan for example his repertoire was black
is uh
it's it's he's wins a lot of games black
but i it's not that hard to force a draw
against them with white and a lot of
players are like this so
perhaps i need to adjust
because if you play super super slow
openings right you make yourself much
less of a target
um but i guess i guess i'll find my
style and i'll find what i like to play
and
but i think that
if i was i think that i need a little
bit of wesley
i need to is that that complete risk
aversion
and uh
really really making sure no blunders
happen is something that i think would
benefit me
a lot to balance out my ambition and
fighting spirit
the next super tunnel you're going to
play is the u.s championship we can
definitely call it a super tournament
what place are you expecting to get in
it
i'm expecting to play my best chess and
to
to improve upon this and if this is any
representation of my potential
i think that the u.s championship is
going to be even more impressive
considering this experience and
considering that i think i'm going to be
in a much better mental place during
that event right
tell us a little bit about the winner of
the grand chess tour you've got to play
here in
this tournament there's a fruit that is
what do you think of his chess
he's pretty good yeah
so i we actually uh
um
i've known him not known him but we
played actually in the under 12 in world
youth
in greece so uh
i was always familiar with him and he
was sort of uh we're actually born one
day apart oh that's funny so uh he's
always been the the leading my age my
year and then obviously now the entire
junior generation so i think his
representation of first of all
how this fresh ambitious tracks can be
so dominating
and also just to show that uh
you know he's uh
amazing work ethic and uh extremely
talented
so but as you see from him as well
sometimes in the candidates he was
taking you know ridiculous amount of
risk for no reason and so i think
i guess the younger players need to be
more professional
in some respects because uh
i think that some of these top 10 guys
would would never in their
minds play some of the moves that at
least i played because they're just
they would never think of even taking
any risk because it's just the smartest
way to play
yeah i'm being told has a question to
jump in with
actually i have to first of all the
tumult that occurred off the board that
was terrible but at least it provided us
with two moments of gaiety i want to say
one you were coming into the playing
hall
with some chewing gum man and like you
got wanted on that chewing gum like it
was you know the
high secrets and then the other one was
yesterday we had a quad of ladies who
showed up to express their great support
your your reflections first of all with
the ladies
uh well uh i actually found it after the
game i did not notice that
yeah that was certainly an interesting
uh surprise
and i saw someone made a reddit post
about that you know someone really is
desperate for reddit karma yes it's a
very important number like alejandro
i've seen him he's farming redakarma
like crazy you know as a commenter and
he finally saw the chance to post
because you've just been lurking in the
reddit comments for a while now um
[Music]
that was i think that that is the first
time in chess that that's ever happened
and um as i said in my interview with
anastasia i think this tournament will
go down in history
and um
i think it'll be i think when people
look back on my career and i'm going to
have a very very long career it's
apparently on the screen i was
definitely farming they read it they
read it yeah it really looked like you
were enjoying yourself there i think uh
i had to run because we have a seven
minute break between
excuse me who won who won that match
because because you play
you play you play tennis like wesley
plays chess
you just you just like but the thing is
that you don't you can't run so you use
me you're very smart with the placement
i'll tell you you're the placement
you're hitting to my back end every
single time and you got lucky it was our
first set and hadn't played in like a
year
technique too strong the tennis speaks
for itself so so many things i can say
right now incredible yeah but okay the
main point is obviously this is the
highlight of your commentary
you know you're waiting just for this
moment right yes then finally in chess
you know it's an interesting concept
because if you look at a lot of major
sports this is certainly a common thing
right but chess
to have like groupies
is a bit or fan girls if that if that
term is uh
denominatory um
is certainly unique and um
personally uh
i'm uh i think it's it's interesting for
sure
i don't know what to say here um thank
you for being my fans and uh
i will definitely not cut my hair now
because um
i really love my hair
and
the previous times i've cut it were all
by influence of a girl so i'm not going
to to let that mistake repeat itself
how's your fabulous her everybody knows
curly hair is the best yes yes it does
i have to echo what you said this will
go down as a tournament in history
above anything else i have done
commentary for the sing field cup since
it started in 2013 and never have i seen
the amount of attention that this one
has gotten and is there anything that
you would
finally like to add
um well first of all um the fact that
i'm even playing this tournament was
pure
chance
um
there was a last minute dropout and then
i was selected which was not guaranteed
and then i made a trip from turkey very
far and very tiring so
the fact that
the last three weeks seem like it's it's
parallel universe it's just doesn't make
any sense to me
because this wild card to miami for no
reason
and even there you know chess speaks for
itself and that went crazy and the last
uh it just felt like uh
quite crazy
but i'm very thankful first of all to
rex and jeannie singfield
for everything you've done in the chess
like this uh invitation will definitely
have a significant impact on my career
and we'll see if that is positive
or negative and that that's to be
determined
but
i'm just
very happy to play this tournament and i
hope i wish that i could have done
better
but um i think that
i showed that i can play with the best
of the best and
regardless of the result i think that
that's something that no one can can
deny
has we will see you very soon here at
the us championships can't wait for
those games to start thanks for joining
us thank you thank you hans indeed our
congratulations for uh your success
in this tournament and we look forward
to your
play in this year's u.s championships
we've got a lot of great events still
coming up peter
the road ahead we've got the ultimate
moves
we've got uh
960 and of course here they are this is
what's still on schedule peter yeah the
ultimate move starts in a couple of days
time and then immediately after that
we'll have a three-day uh fish random
chestnine lx tournament
if you're going to be competing in yeah
i'll come we'll lose your
people can't see my air quotes
around the world competing but yeah i
will be playing in it you will be
participating participating in it yes
and then the us us open in the u.s
women's championship start on october
the 3rd in saint louis and yeah a lot of
eyes will be on hans of course because
chances correctly
you know the the story of the chess
world definitely so uh lots to watch
lots to watch for yeah and the fan girls
were very very much appreciated as well
whoo
what an event uh and more to come
alejandro because we do have a playoff
later today but your final thoughts if
you will just about the classical uh
tournament itself i think it was amazing
i mean
no matter if you consider
the hurricane
that surrounded the tournament just
speaking of the chess i thought it was
great i thought laressa's fighting
spirit was amazing i thought that we had
some really cool rounds in which we saw
tons of decisive games we saw a lot of
theory we saw favi bringing in tons of
theory to this tournament of course a
pity to not see some of the matches that
i really wanted to see i really wanted
to see how theresa play magnus i'm
excited every time i get a chance to see
those gladiators fight but alireza he
just showed up he did what he had to do
in many cases he saved a lot of
positions that a lot of people would
have collapsed on and actually ended up
winning them and i can't wait for this
playoff that he has against nepo
wonderful and we have also anastasia
to also give us her final thoughts uh
from the social media side of things
what event it was actually i mean i
think all of us we had lots of fun but
i'm sure that people really enjoyed this
moment and they could share all their
opinions during this event i mean
because the drama started right after
the number the round number three when
magnus carlsen withdrew from the
tournament so i would like to show you
again what was happening so those who
missed it perhaps or
let's say lost the track of what was
happening can we remember again so
probably we can share some tweets
so first it came with magnus carlson who
simply was drew from the event published
in this tweet um that he announcing this
and um and then of course he created
lots of drama because nobody could
really understand the reasons so people
started to speculate and trying to guess
why actually he did so of course
everybody i mean many people started to
think that maybe he lost the game before
hans and maybe hans was cheating i mean
this word started to appear even though
there were not direct accusations from
top players but still there were many
streams i mean the hikaru nakamura also
came out with
his video on youtube and even though
there were no direct
accusations still i mean it created lots
of drama and people were discussing the
media were
were publishing lots of news i mean all
this the story came out and we can see
that it we had headlines in many
newspapers you can see new york post
you can see independent so it was
covered really well
what happened after when hans demon
actually he was still playing his game
and then he came back to his room and he
found out what's going on he came out
with the interview next day
where he said lots of things explaining
first of all that
that he and clearly claiming that he was
not cheating uh you can see the next
tweet which was published by which was
uh published by maurice ashley who was
here in saint louis and who said that
this extraordinary interview you should
definitely watch the interview in one
day made half a million views on youtube
and i mean it was i think one of the
most popular interviews in chess history
so after that interview of course there
was a reaction of the players in the
tournament of many top players including
of course the world champion gary
kasparov who um actually asked magnus
carlson for his statement
he asked him to explain actually what
were the reasons behind his decision and
clear reasons so it's all created lots
of drama and which we were following all
these days and then okay it was one free
day we have to admit it was one day that
everybody was enjoying the tennis and
you can see also hans demon who was with
guys
and we could hear some
details uh so there was a some kind of a
break and um after that
just come published the statement and
then we had like a little break and
after that we had a statement also the
chief arbiter who said that
no one know that he can absolutely sure
that there was no any business to to
think that there was
unfair play in in this tournament so all
this was happening and i just wanted to
finish the story with again the same
photo which was shown before but it was
already used so we had this fantastic uh
you know
yesterday we had this situation that the
fans came to the saint louis club and
they didn't manage to take photo with
hans neiman but they were still happy to
have alejandro there so this this story
will continue definitely and uh it will
not finish with sinkhold cup which will
for sure will remain in the history of
chess and of course we all will follow
the events and probably will see
something from magnus later on we found
magnus one time i didn't we didn't show
this picture but we found him in the
company of aryanthari one photo was
published with him and uh so we are
expecting something to follow for sure
this event was a really great event for
social media and if you
still don't follow granchester or san
luis chess accounts it's definitely time
to do so create your account and follow
us
these days back to you guys peter yes
sir
anastasia a wonderful recap when you
start to see gary kasparov and everybody
get involved
i you were missing some godakomski's
tweets too anastasia you're showing me
that that gada had improved by 300
rating points in a single year it was
like oh my god just to show that it's
not that unusual if we want to go into
technical yeah exactly gotta did that in
a very very different uh different era
when there were like these days the
rating lists come out once every month
right meaning that your rating
constantly get updated gets updated and
your expected score is obviously updated
with it and when you know gato or myself
where we we
you got rated we're two years two years
apart so i know i know the error he's
talking about right there
per year so if you if you had a sudden
burst of speed like you you were playing
on your very very low rating for like i
don't know seven tournaments in a row
right and that of course gave you a much
better starting pad so these numbers
they obviously have to be taken with a
grain of salt i've seen a lot of
statistical analysis published on
twitter in the last few days and uh
you do have to take a lot of things into
consideration before you know jumping to
conclusions on those topics
one thing i was very proud to see that
alejandro was representing the
commentators and while the fan girls
didn't get a chance to meet uh their
hero directly uh the great solace
provided by alejandro was much
appreciated
oh my god
and peter uh in two hours time we again
want to inform folks that we will be
having a playoff i suppose uh we'll get
a a break maybe swimming pool or
something we'll figure it we'll figure
it out yeah so once again this is uh
this is what we're going to be watching
in in a you know about an hour and a
half's time or two hours time right uh
the there will be two rapid games of ten
plus five ali raza versus
and if they if they tie those to
whichever way it happens two draws on
one win in one loss there is an
immediate armageddon with five minutes
per wide four minutes for black
uh
very importantly two second increment uh
only after starting from move 61 yes
which is uh which is uh important to
avoid clock banging and and other other
things but still gives white a very
significant one-minute advantage for the
vast majority of the game and of course
black gets
and that's for that
game wonderful i'll definitely be here
uh alongside you calling the action
and our
show will begin at 6 15 central times
and about 6 15. and uh drawing of lots
it's 6 20 as the players are been asked
i assume we will try to uh to start the
show to show you uh the drawing of lots
to kind of lead you through the the
entire process of absolutely of the
players arriving and choosing colors and
so on we'll go on break until then uh
see you at the playoffs
see you then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back
it has all come down to this yes it's
the way of time the final showdown for
the title of the uh single cup champion
2022 and it is between ferrugia who has
been
the dominant force over the past three
weeks yes no question about it
who actually came very very close to
winning the tournament outright he did
have a very promising position in the
last round against uh hans niemann and
had he won that he would have won the
tournament on on the plus three score
there would be no need for for any of
this and since we are in a playoff uh
peter do tell our audience what the
format is for this
two match player two player time yeah uh
so what we will see is two rapid games
with a time control of fifteen plus ten
that uh also appears to be somewhat
changed from what we are announced
earlier
production springing surprises were on
us so you know front left and center and
and then immediately no blitz
immediately armageddon if one one uh is
the result of the rapids uh and in the
armageddon you get a five against four
white gets an extra minute there's a
second increment starting room 61 which
is very important to avoid shenanigans
at the very very back end of that game
and black of course as a compensation
for the extra minute uh gets drawed in
that one we will be declaring a champion
alejandro here and who do you see
as the favorite between these two
gladiators
i think it's impossible to just pick a
favorite from them just by chest
strength
but alireza comes from an amazing rapid
and blitz he's fired up
nepo must be disappointed with the way
that he played today i mean you could
see it in his face in the post-game
interview yes so somehow i feel that
alaresa with the quicker game today has
the advantage but that i think is a bit
of a subjective feel i see
and here we have
head to head yeah that's that's the
head-to-head uh as you can see yeah
they're smiling there but
unclear just how much smiling will be
done when it begins uh and uh yeah if
you believe in momentum
momentum has to be on nalirez's side
here he he won the rapid and blitz and i
think more importantly is the second
part of alejandro's statement there
right alireza played a bit of a non-game
today he played a very black yeah a very
very comfortable game against mvl was
entirely untroubled and had the rest of
the day to you know chill and watch and
he knew i think from very early on the
way uh
wesley's game was going that if if there
is to be a tie break it will be uh
versus jan so he could have started
preparing you know five hours in advance
just
depending on how much preparation he
absolutely needed whereas for jan
yeah he was uh
unhappy he was very very very high
unhappy with all that game with how that
game ended and not without reason he is
a person who is
his own harshest critic has always been
he really really uh you know values
playing well dislikes playing playing
less than he uh less well that he can
and his his absolute best is very very
good as we wait uh for the players uh
they'll be a drawing of lots let's just
take a quick gander at upcoming events
peter as you know there's many more
events absolutely to be played here in
saint louis there will not be a gct play
of tomorrow which means that the players
the players and the media do get one day
off
and then on the 13th we have the the
ultimate moves the uh the the trash
talking uh
contest which uh everybody here seems to
enjoy a great deal and then the opening
ceremony for the champions showdown
chess nine elects the fisherendum
tournament the ten round uh ten player
round robin which will run from
september 14th to september 16th uh
three games three games a day and uh
that should be a lot of fun and then
there is a bit of a break finally right
and early october st louis will host
uh both the the the open and the women's
uh us chess championship which is going
to be a very very interesting event with
i believe all of the top players playing
right
the national championships are just
getting stronger and stronger it's just
been a joy
uh to behold as we getting ready once
again
for this playoff we see the players as
they coming in
uh getting wanded and
peter uh what can you tell us about nepo
as far as playoffs was concerned what uh
alireza said in his interview he's never
been in a playoff in his life at least
one day
yeah not in a high profile one i didn't
really do much research in in the
limited time he had available between
the end of the previous
part of today's show and this show but i
mean jan has played uh has played a
number the one i remember maybe the most
was the one that he won
uh to become
did he win that
maybe i'm just spinning and spinning a
tail there he played a a play-off in one
of the russian super finals in like in
the early to the 2010s
against sergey karaki and i think he did
win that but i'm not like
my mind is playing tricks on me now and
he lost the playoff late last year a big
one yeah and and obviously uh yeah he
played a bunch since
now they just had the drawing of lots i
saw that but it looked to me like
nepal got white for the first round i
actually uh missed it i missed that
moment it was like chris had the two
pawns in his hand he picked one i had
one job to watch that no it's nappa with
white
i failed utterly yeah nepo did get white
so that's uh that's the start so
first game you know it's funny in these
playoff
scenarios always preferred to have black
yeah
i think it's slightly more comfortable
in particular when it's such a short mic
like when it's just just these two and
there won't even be two more of
different formulas or something it
always feels like
uh uh you know it's my one chance today
to use a qriket analogy
chasing is always slightly more
comfortable than uh than setting a
target right and when you're playing
with black it feels like you will know
what you need with white right and that
makes your life kind of
simpler to understand maybe not easier
necessarily but simpler to understand
uh
if you make a draw with black you know
that
your options are you know you can you
can go all out
and try to win that game or perhaps you
you fancy your chances in armageddon and
then you can play with like with with
with a draw in reserve
and uh and if you win with black of
course then you know it's wonderful like
then you're really in clover yeah
because you
absolutely switch to
extreme strategy in the second one i
jump in uh alejandro when you when
you're in the playoff uh
you like starting with black as well
i haven't been into many playoffs that
are two game playoffs i was
with
thing is that from the people that start
with black
that win their round with black a lot of
them actually feel tons of pressure
going into the game with white and not
losing
because i remember seeing a funny one
trying to remember exactly who negi was
playing he was an ukrainian player but
it escapes me who he was playing in
trump so where negi starts with the
white pieces loses
wins with black
same thing in the second part of that of
that match started with the white pieces
lost with white
had to come back loose returns and wins
with the black pieces so i've always
felt that if you start with uh with
black and you win actually there's a ton
of pressure on you not to lose not to
fail on the second one yeah i've had
i've had libraries like that i think
maybe the very very first time i played
a knockout event which
uh was an interesting experience because
it sort of set me on the path which you
know eventually kind of made the chess
player out of me in a weird way i was
invited uh as a kind of a promising but
really somewhat non-descript uh young
russian player i was invited to tilburg
94
which was at the time the tilburg
organizers experimented with with a
knockout format
and in round one i played uh against
elon greenfield who you know became over
the years a good friend of mine an
israeli chess player and we uh traded
blows in the classical and that wasn't
normally like he beat me like a drum
with white and because he's a very very
good theoretician shout out to all on if
if he's if he's watching
and then i somehow beat him in some
sicilian
uh
and then yeah and then we started
playing rapid and in the rapid i would i
switched from grunfeld to my strange
d4693 bishop g4 stuff that i was playing
at the time which is not really that
great but it was a kind of a way to
avoid alone's opening preparation and i
kept on winning
with the black pieces and then being
completely unable to to make a safe draw
in the sicilian and i kept on playing e4
and losing sicilians
and then beating him in d4600 bishop g4
and eventually we came to an armageddon
okay and i drew wide
and i thought none of that and just
played one d4 in one very easy
it took a while
to dawn on me that i have other options
and i can go back to my childhood and
like play the colleen right
say
and and then in round two i played
halfman and once again i i
won the first one in some some dragon
and then he beat my
my browser sicilian he sacrificed
something with knight g5 one and
brilliant game
and then
the time came for the rapid tie break
and
he it was i think a 20 plus
10 game okay which he overslept by
15 minutes
in those years or maybe 25 plus 10 if
you ever slept by 20. but no zero
tolerance was uh enforced in those years
and alexander halfmann for me as a kid
he was an absolute icon i i adored him
and for me this was an incredibly
uncomfortable feeling like at first i i
begged
her tyson not to start the clock but i
mean he must start the clock i mean the
regulations are the regulations and then
i was kind of pacing unhappily around
the board just you know will he show up
won't he show up and he did show up with
five minutes on the clock
and just destroyed me
with the black pieces in some car
and obviously there was no coming back
from that
and my loss in round two of that
tournament meant i was just in time
to come back home repack and fly to
alistar to play the russian championship
and that and that one that was the first
one i won
the life of a professional player yeah
yeah i get it you know and if i if i you
know keep my keep my stuff together and
actually win uh you know a 20-minute
handicap rapid game against uh
somehow not lose with black
you know maybe i progress further and
then i definitely don't play that
russian right and and who knows what
becomes of me exactly
here we see the players getting prepared
there's jan uh
both players are well as is
their abilities to be ambidextrous e4 d4
jan has been playing into catalan
positions of late
uh your prediction as far as the opening
uh i think it's likely he will stick
with it
because he had d4 knight f3 g3
especially drawing white on the first
game right right
i think what alireza did against him uh
i can't exactly remember yeah i mean
first of all in the classical hibitum in
the classical here uh he played alireza
played a sharp line did and uh
i mean you can't really claim he didn't
equalize because he like he didn't
really know very much theory i don't
expect the same line to be repeated if
it is he will have improvements but i
think in the rapid and blitz alireza
played this very very solid take c4 and
then c5 knight c6 catalan against jan
and equalized
very very easily but you also feel that
really the way young played that game
that he just wasn't interested in
showing what he has that's right and now
he will be now now he will be very very
interested uh so uh
if that happens
we probably see something more
principled than the somewhat random
moves that jan was making in that game
exactly so uh just recall for me i did
this yeah did they c5 here 96 1965 65 uh
queen g1 rook d1 bishop c5 oh we can't
really see it so that's uh
i'm throwing this out there as uh as
prep for myself to get it
so i know what i'll be talking about in
case they do repeat yeah and that was
the knight d2 sometimes lucy iii and so
on yeah yeah okay so yeah young
definitely will be uh
better better equipped and uh sort of
more aggressive if that line gets
repeated but obviously alireza
has more than one system against the
catalan for sure most people these days
do i see that i've put in my moves
already so should i refresh my board
here peter no no there's there's no
moves play i know but i've unfortunately
i think you'll be fine yeah yeah we'll
see in a moment
uh and yeah both of them obviously
taking this very seriously as you can
judge by by lack of long sleeves
no no impediment to the free flow of
arms right it might not be that
important in the 15 plus 10 game but if
they do play in armageddon i am not
kidding this actually is somewhat
important exactly to have the absolute
freedom there in particular when it gets
done even when it gets down to the very
very last second and i believe we've
only had one other playoff right for the
sink field cup in all the years that
there was the the one between magnus and
ding yes and uh the
the three as a three player who tied
yeah they just died
who refuse
who went on a strike they didn't want to
play and there we have it they're often
away with the catalan as predicted
yeah but not now the z55 takes c4 line
yeah and okay bishop b7 kind of does
indicate that this will be the line and
alireza goes with a6 not the the very
fashionable stuff that
for instance wesley played against him
he's going for the traditional solid
stuff bishop this ambition c6
yep
[Music]
one sec
yeah i just have two
yeah we were
getting this a little bit late
but i think i got it
uh you got it well done
then i kind of got stuck right
yeah queen all the way to c1 yeah this
is uh this is obviously still very much
uh very much theory uh for the time
being we probably should be okay now
it's now it's back online uh this is a
very very topical line yeah a very very
topical line uh a6a4 bishop d7 is one of
the absolute top responses to sort of
the classical catalan and 96 is maybe
sort of slightly less popular i think on
the other hand i think this is what
talia has played against magnus in that
game in zagreb uh in zagreb yeah so it's
difficult to imagine young
people never having seen this
before whether he repeated it just sort
of in that hour and a half perhaps that
he had between
uh the end of his game and uh
and the start of this is unclear but he
plays e3 quite quickly
and bishop before
is a very kind of a telegraphed response
here by black alireza says uh my bishop
24 is extremely important to me i'm very
emotionally attached to it
uh please don't attack it with your
knight on b1 please specifically knight
c3 knight bg2 bishop d5 maybe is not
such a tragedy but knight c3 would
definitely drive the bishop on e4 away
from the long diagonal so and he's
telegraphing he is just just ready to
snap
on c3 follow it up with queen d5 i think
25 or h6 or yeah 25 c4 i mean maybe 25
anyway qd5 and the uh c4 queen of five
five right yeah and then f6 bishop three
right um so yeah this is a very very
concrete uh concrete idea seems to have
given uh
jan a bit of pause
now uh i don't know about your database
uh
alejandro but bishop b4
novelty no no no there's a couple of
games there's a couple of games okay
yeah including uh great alexander
baliafsky has played this exactly
the name you will that will be very very
familiar to you
absolutely
alexander
yanukovich
working on theory even even now yeah he
is he's at the forefront of theoretical
thought yeah there's not an old game
it's a 2019 yeah exactly this is not
yeah this is very very recent h7 h6
queen d5 looked very challenging look
challenging but i guess well
something wasn't quite right with it
even though yeah for me i thought that
was very much the idea
all right yeah it takes takes knight a5
and again
i have to say uh for game 15
these guys
are up to 17 right i mean they are
flying
yeah
uncharacteristically for him hasn't
gained very much time on the clock
is up two and a half minutes
from from his starting and perhaps we
could pause and talk about the structure
for a bit right right uh
generally you would say white is a bit
better i think uh
but
black does have counterplay the knight
on a5 is very safe i think
the yeah exactly that's what i was going
to say that the the pawn break you want
is much more e65 rather than c7 c5
because
um i think the knight only five does a
very good job restricting the knight on
g2 taking away some squares very much
yeah we're very interested in placing
the queen on c6 as jan is indicating
there over there oh yeah sorry uh uh
yeah it's an easy mistake to make
absolutely yeah very strong players
must be young e5 yeah e5 uh queen e4
played stopping queen c6 and black uh
just generally uh you you're trying to
resolve the situation in the center to a
degree but you i think you can also just
play like rook cafe a true kg8 b7 b6 and
keep the tension because for white to be
better
white will at some point want to uh you
know
start with some kind of a push in the
center majority yeah and the pawn e5 i
think does a very very good job of
making that difficult
yeah
uh placing the queen on e4 that's
because now he's now he's forced to do
something about it right he takes before
he's such a strategical threat he's not
taking twice on d4 but after queen takes
d4 playing pretty much any other move
yeah uh 25 is possible but after b6
we're really not doing very much right
now
is coming well even if i do
even if you do provoke before it's not
always going to be horrible exactly
exactly um
[Music]
although actually i kind of liked the
idea provoking e5 before okay let's have
a look at at least i like it more than
all the other ideas okay yeah g4 takes
e5 possible i think after okay i'm okay
with that structure change frankly yeah
he's played between d5 he has played 25
yes and against the natural b6 defending
the knight yeah v6 will be blissed out
you you you feel like everything else
would be a very strange choice like what
other options do you even have c6 maybe
yeah or 96 but that just doesn't seem
logical right okay b6 let's do it yeah i
think it must be connected with knight
f3 because then you're r8d8 you reckon
i i'm my plan was to take this bomb
peter quincy like i think i might be
very very okay tactically here with
queen g6 g6 on the board so my queen
ends has to go to a2 and i play queenie
four here i think i think i'm fine here
you know you're very happy you're more
than happy actually i think i'm okay i
think i'm okay uh but but i think the
point has to be just to go back to a2
and try to provoke either eg4 cd4 which
is our outcome okay
this i don't particularly like i think
after queen e6 now or
or queen d6 maybe i don't know which one
i think e6 probably is smaller
yeah just uh eyeballing these squares a
little bit yeah i feel like you know we
are definitely tempting white to go d4d5
which i don't hate for black at all it
gives the knight on a5 very nice squares
on both c5 and d6 once this happens
but 26 gives white a tempo to play
knight e4 at some moment maybe somehow
this looks like a cool groomfield for
black yeah yeah this looks like a very
very comfortable position for black i
really don't see how this can be better
for white
i don't know if it can if it can already
be better for black in any kind of a
significant fashion but
yeah i i feel entirely entirely safe
here with black i think at least to
begin with and then i will start
misplaying it hard
did the engine agree with peter uh
aleandra yeah it's zero zero we don't
really have to switch to me during this
one because we want to keep the action
on right but the end just think that
it's just completely fine for the black
side zero zero is a current evaluation
with any queen move queen g6 queen e6
queen d6 will include it
queen e6 queen d6
queen g6 yeah all zeroes
yeah as long as we don't i mean honestly
even if you play rook again q and f6 gf
i'm not sure it's so horrible but
there's absolutely like zero reason to
ever do that right exactly but
yeah i it just feels like
the only reason that i could possibly
prefer white is if this capture had been
made ages ago then i would have the
half c fox
excuse me very concrete to play for but
after
i like queen g6 i don't even know what
i'm supposed to be playing for am i
supposed to be playing for
e4 yeah i think e4 followed by g5 c4 and
just k you know saying that you know
it's not it's not seeing a queen trade
by the way well that is honestly a bit
surprising i i don't quite understand
this choice then the concrete reason is
that if you take with the king it can't
be dangerous and if you take with the
knight you do get the c4 square knight
takes knight c4 yeah i mean i'm taking
with the king here i think pretty
pretty clearly i i don't like uh giving
the c4 square up then yeah we're taking
with the king black i guess goes for kg8
and perhaps the king is the most active
piece yes
yes it's the furthest up the board uh
yeah king takes that uh and rook the and
okay yeah i mean i wouldn't have done
jesus black because i like i like
playing with the queens on on the board
but it doesn't really look at all
horrible for black
the current idea is definitely c7 c5
because the right hand is hanging i
think if you play like rook b1 it
probably takes much of the sting however
the idea of playing c5 but we can start
with rookie six perhaps re-establish it
also the rook might go to c6 later or
maybe even not much later maybe kind of
immediately exactly um
it feels fine okay i just would have
kept the queens on the board for
personal preference rook a2 defending
the knight trying as you say to take the
sting
out of c5 c5 d4 do that yeah and then
maybe i could uh
i could have a smidge suddenly knight to
e4 g4
removing support from the knight on a5
doesn't feel right unless you gain a lot
by doing it and i don't think you do
right now i think right now it's a it
would be a mistake so kind of a waiting
move is an order i still like my idea of
rookie 6 maybe with some rook g6 to come
um
and like the point in particular is that
if you play rookie 6 here let's say
white goes i don't know g3 g4 which is
not a stupid positional move right rook
e6 gt3 g4 after rook c6 you might have
to actually now now that i play g4 you
can play knight e4
because we've stopped the f5 but my
point was you can't put any rooks on the
c file because we will plunder the
central pawn there with rook c1 we take
on default twice right exactly so you
have to make slightly awkward moves
instead but ninety four dollars
but then you've got your knight yeah
well i got my super square well as bobby
fisher famously said to get squares you
got to give him
white will have earned himself the e4
square for his knight
uh and just in that line pardon me i
should have i should have played it to
its natural conclu
conclusion yeah the knight on e4 is
pretty good looking but as this
so is that he hasn't played rookie six
yet simply be like not because it's uh
such a great move but because
it really feels sort of far in the way
the most natural one in the position no
question about it i mean i i did
briefly
consider f7 f5 because you start to look
at
g3 g4
there you go boom
what f5
yeah he does he does i guess feel that
he needs to
grab some space on right on the king's
side do we ever play g3 g4 here okay jan
says no no shenanigans please yeah what
did he do rugby one rugby one very very
quickly uh your take alejandro at this
early stage of this first
uh playoff game if you had
if you were forced to pick a white side
which is why because i just like the
structure better
i don't know
i understand that black has a lot of
counterplay
but i like that structure it's solid i
feel that if i can maneuver my knight
around somehow
i could get a
i have more potential to get the better
out of the structure i think it's a bit
more fluid it's a bit more like we're
more flexible but like it's honestly a
very personal opinion i don't think that
you can say look at this position like
many that we've seen through the
tournament right and think yeah you
obviously take one side or the other i
think you're looking at white's king and
saying something about that king that's
leading its army that must be good about
it uh i like your move rookie sex peter
i liked it the the moment you suggested
it
and in this position i like king of
seven too i mean uh bringing you brought
your king into the action maybe i should
bring my king into the action king f7
but rookie six uh
the question here is whether he feels he
needs to have a specific answer it might
be three that really is maybe the only
idea what has but
rook d6 yeah so far yeah very quickly i
might add yeah
uh and uh
yeah some sort of maneuvering uh
maneuvering game going on here
46.
um
i guess 93 like i didn't think 93 was
doing very much in particular once black
lands rook on the sixth because my point
was if we play knight b3
yeah and black goes knight c4 i wanted
to play a6 a5 and pretend i'm attacking
the pawn on a6 but i don't think i am
really you can even ignore it or you can
play b6b5 and it's already protected by
the rook on d6 and it will be very very
difficult to get to that black yes it's
a kind of a nice looking knight on c5
but as long as there's a rook on the
sixth it's not really doing all that
much uh so yeah jan prefers just to make
a quiet move for now he's gone he's gone
roxy too i don't think he has a threat
he's for now just trying to establish
pieces on the best squares and see where
it leads him
also perhaps uh
he is expecting the rook to land on c6
at some point so he is preparing for it
right i just um
by the way if you're talking about
nitrates knight to b3 i'd much prefer
to execute such a high trade
by playing a move like rook b4 knight c4
trying to change trade the nights on my
terms uh maybe i could finagle an
advantage in that case
yeah i agree with that i think it
probably isn't enough even if black
complies and allows you to do everything
you want but you can also try not to
like group before i can maybe play rook
c6 and tell you right you'll have to at
least work for it a little bit next yeah
next to 10. at some moment uh if i'm
white whoa this is fair oh whoa whoa
very concrete
yeah i was wondering if this is what he
meant by playing rook d6
um
i think that's just based on a
miscalculation my first impression is
aren't you helping white a great deal
with this move i mean yeah in some ways
but what do you do against d5
ah d5 i think probably for check for
followed by c4 is the idea
artificially
any trade we're not taking it yet but we
would like to isolate it and perhaps
collect it later right perhaps it's a
it's a tall order here
i can play rook before but before xb2
though
i think that's too much pressure
and it's similar to the the end game
that nepo beat alireza in the classical
where you got this better rook end game
and he starts pricing starts pressing
and starts pressing
and in that uh
in that rook ending in particular what
was stunning for all of us was the
passive play
by uh ali reza and perhaps it's also
slightly playing undereze's mind here he
decides not to play not to play quietly
here he decides to go yeah and d45 found
and played by
baiyan very very nicely i somehow failed
to even consider that moving young kind
of zeros on it
more or less more or less immediately
um yeah good early signs for jan because
really you know i've known him for uh
for years and he has become a lot more a
lot less volatile let's put it like this
let's just go down this primrose path
this is primrose for who though
yeah at the end of the day
this rook is far more accurate i mean
maybe after b8 you have some drawing
chances but you should not be entering
the same game if you have any choice
whatsoever i'm not even sure you don't
have any drawing chances you don't even
have to take on a6 you can consider rook
d5 yeah absolutely it's a boring game
i wasn't really trying to make an
argument for him no no no no but what i
wanted to say is that
uh so far i think jan's play in this
game is a play of somebody who uh
you know dealt with the disappointment
of how the
classical game in round nine went
and why is he so severe on himself i
mean he
i mean i mean he doesn't tolerate even
when he plays a good game he's not yeah
i think i think that that has always
been the case with jan and
as someone who has
i think we share this particular
characteristic very much with him i
you know
my answer to that why would be like how
else can you be really
like a true optimist
uh but d5 is really putting uh ali in
the tank here yeah this is the most time
he's used on any one of his moves is
that right no uh i think i can improve
on that line a little bit let's go let's
go through it again e4 check e4 check
the king has to go back to e2 we go c5
c4 you play rook b4 and here i want to
suggest taking note with the rook on d6
but with rook on the 8th rook e5 rook e
and not rook c no no rookie five and i
want to take this rock because after now
yeah if you take on c4 i will take i
will take uh rookie takes d5 i am still
maybe a bit worse after rook g4 because
my rooks are kind of weirdly placed
right but i was calculating this i can
go king e6 king f7 here roxy g2
uh
rook c d d2 i think yeah i think this is
the point king 64. you forced me to
give me a little space get get this
structure and actually this is kind of
frightening right you it's a little
scary it is a bit scary because yeah if
you play this passively you will you
will lose so you have to maybe
immediately switch to like rook d8 rook
c8 and some kind of counter play in the
center i don't know
um but my point was largely that after
rookie five if you go once here
if you go rook cb2 this was my
backup plan my uh very very nice trick i
want to go rook eg5 and now you're too
late to go rook takes b6 because rough
tasty wins the piss
very nice yeah that was that was sort of
the whole the whole point of my previous
construction that's pretty
that's very pretty
um yeah uh alvarez is still thinking
here because yeah i think he realizes
that
this is not
easy very easy in fact
this is
really an extraordinarily critical
moment right here
right now now uh peter i i think it's
very important that we explain to our
audience why the move c3 c4 has to be
stopped just it's crucial
i've been wondering about this uh but
like once again nobody ever does this
but perhaps you could survive in some
positions if you allow c3 c4 but
generally speaking the answer is very
simple
uh
allowing white to land this protected
passer on d5
frees up so much
you your hands basically are completely
free here with white right to uh to
dedicate every all your energy to
pressuring as the b6 pawn if e5 before
is not played e3 e4 will become a huge
big issue because
yeah
and
in the more general terms
i think if the pawn in this position is
on a7 not on a6 that's a big deal yeah
maybe it maybe becomes borderline
playable it's not going to be fun anyway
but it maybe becomes borderline playable
bb6 pawn yeah but with the beast
so soft yeah it feels like it probably
just which is which is why we've been
pressing uh
for e4 and c4 to artificially isolate
the pawn to not allow it to become a
protected past pawn absolutely either e3
e4 or c3 c4 and again peter uh a lot of
time this is a a
one and a half minute thing guys yeah
it's been it's been a while and
understandably so but really i it's
difficult for me to understand the uh
even simply the desire to play c7 and c5
all together but
that was the secret i i didn't see uh
d45 at all but even let's say the
position after c5 if i take on c5 that
was the thing that i immediately
attracted to myself take steaks blinking
into here right and having you just done
me the biggest favor
by opening i guess
point was he will play rookie g8 here
and actually getting to play rook b6 is
good
like e4 g6 or something
and we are controlling
the squares quite well you can play rook
cb2 but after that you are still not
creating a single thread right i can't i
can't actually enter that is true and
maybe he just felt that okay he'll kill
goku if seven king of six maybe even and
and just stand and be reasonably safe i
wouldn't have gone for it
but i that part i could understand but i
think he just as i did for instance just
completely missed d45
right
and again rook takes d5 rook takes b6
that one is horrible the invitation to
uh attack the spawn on asex ae6 is just
that one that one is truly horrible i
think you do have to play e4 c4 and
white has an improvement over the
position we were discussing in that line
show me after e4 and c4 i think it's
probably cleaner to start with rook cb2
immediately
rook c2 to bt
okay because that actually stops my
rookie five from d5 idea this is now one
tempo too short so we all pretty much
always get the rook to b6 you can play
rook b8 but you will not enjoy the
experience of having having to play with
b8
so you take on d5 we take on b6 at some
point we need to remind laressa it's no
longer a classical tournament right
right right right four minutes he has
spent more time on this move than he has
remaining
well he is facing very serious problems
so in a way in a way he's doing the
right thing because you know he i think
he's realized by this point that if he
um if he doesn't find a good reply here
he might be in a tremendous amount of
trouble exactly peter i'm just gonna
i'm gonna
have to say that i don't like
letting the rook um crash through on the
b6 pawn i'd rather
you capture the scene we take on c4 and
we'll do and then in the end i go
i thought i'd go rook c6 but maybe it's
not that much i guess i start by giving
you a check
you have to go back to g8
that wasn't the intent i understand and
then we all think uh
you know c4 c5 comes to mind rook c6
forces rook a5 i think but that one is
not what i had in mind maybe maybe i
have to do something else here
pause break yeah i think that's probably
stronger waiting for knight takes so
that i can recapture
on i can include some moves here but
maybe like now that there can be seven
you will play king h7 next move right so
i'm not really gaining all that king f7
sorry uh yeah so let's take one
on c4 on c4 you will take and by the way
we do e4 check has been played king 2
has been played and now the big question
comes yeah right uh so in this position
i will take on c4 you will take twice i
mean i will you know a couple of
captures d5 rook c6 right right and c4
played already
yeah yeah
that's what it feels like that you have
to go for this position there's no
choice we and rooksy 2 to b2
just exactly as you prescribed
peter
on the board by
jan i've got to say uh jan's playing
this at that
finding that moment and playing rather
d4 d5 rather quickly yeah i mean hats
off that was impressive he spotted it
really really quite really quickly and
he also clearly uh trusts his his
instincts and
well you know years and years of playing
uh all kinds of formats i think taught
him that when you know when he's playing
well he can actually trust
trust the hand so
uh this position after rook c6 never
play five rook a5 i don't think i'm
winning this actually because i i
thought rook a5 i can play rook before
and kind of keep things together but you
are trading a lot of stuff with b6b5
here gotcha
i'm not in love with this all right i'm
not in love with this uh maybe it's
something you're throwing g4 though uh
but after rook c2 what do we have no
keep going down the line
before
rugby seven rugby seven is the key rugby
seven take take on c4 take everything
and then we go g3 g4 and then you go g4
i just want to illustrate this okay that
might be dangerous yeah it's it's not
fun i think i am kind of obliged to go
fg and h6 h5 by the way ali reza did
agree to trade the b6 yeah but he chose
a slightly different setup right he
because he he allowed rook d5 and and
then rookie g8
yeah this was the top engine's choice by
the way
yeah i saw that the engines preferred
this it was kind of surprising b2 was
played already
rook
b1 b2 yeah
this is definitely not the position
no
definitely not that was a a mouse slip
um
we just go back wait wait a second
no that's uh
you have a couple of moves rook eddie
forgot
no yeah okay rook b6 here
there we go that's the position yeah
that's that is the position sorry i
no i lost it momentarily so yeah and as
i can see well sort of understandably
you're really not supposed to give up
the pawn on a6 i briefly considered
making some kind of a waiting move here
let's taking h7 just to illustrate okay
and then go in rook a6 knight b3 okay
but i think the issue with that is i
will take one b3 and then i will go rook
a6 b6 without giving up any control over
the g2 square and that doesn't seem
enough so already does go rook g6 i
think he went rook eight d6
there right yes
okay d6
now you have an option you could take
you could go to rook six b4 hinting that
c4 is weak right but i personally am
more attracted to doing the same thing
but trading off a pair of rooks first
just so there's less counter play
yeah i think i think we want a pair of
rooks off because then the the king will
just be perfectly adequately effectively
protecting the knight on two we don't
need to do anything more about the
knight on d2 so take stakes and then
perhaps uh find a way to activate our
pieces rugby hc-8 comes to mind
depending on where the king goes or rook
v8 and perhaps start preparing that very
annoying g4 break and that he agrees
with us takes one pair of rocks now
let's see if he plays rook b8 which is
natural rook b4 also natural
by the way the move rook d6 did come
a blunder alert with rook takes d2
tragic
possibility
rook before first or am i hearing rook
check and rook c8
yeah i mean all of these options are all
of these options are interesting um
the immediate g4 comes to mind but i'm
not always such so much in love with
trading uh the pawn on e4 for the pawn
on g4 i think black pretty much always
takes on g4 and he accepts
the slightly spoiled structure but i
think for black every single pawn traded
the way of uh traded off the board here
is a bit of an achievement so
before roxy six uh played yeah so uh
now the rook is passive and we can
actually you know consider playing like
h3 or by the way it's not just that the
fact that the rook is passive it's not
that i'm going to go and attack the
knight on a5 but in truth that knight on
a5 is
horrified it is a very
i start to think about h3 and g4 and
maybe bringing my knight to g3 i may be
playing a piece ahead
well i mean the moment the knight leaves
the g2 square it will open up the b3
square for for the knight on a5 h3 in
the meantime have has been played and i
really like that idea because it
it asks black you know how happy are you
with with me playing g3 g4 how do you
want to miss it exactly do you want to
prepare and meet with g7 g6 do you want
to play h5 and then perhaps try to take
on g4 and play g6 there's a number of
options but they all result in black
having a somewhat softened pawn
structure which will become a target
uh alejandro is are the engines excited
by white's strategy do they feel he has
a
an advantage and if so by how much well
it was one
but after g4 g6 it's only 0.3 they were
not in love with the idea of playing g4
actually they prefer the move f3 right
away
aha just back
here after rook c6 yeah here or even on
the next move yeah the idea of just and
i think it's a very difficult idea yeah
very difficult because once you put it
on the board i think you can understand
it a little better yeah three if not
just clean
or no or maybe king takes and then e4
and then maybe no it's knight takes no i
think i think it is knight takes because
the knight on d4 lands with such a thump
attacking so many things and still
controlling the knight on e5
and for the time being after pawn takes
knight takes you still can't bring the
king to the center yeah i think i think
it's very very concrete because the the
f f by five pawn is also kind of soft if
if i play knight g4 if you play roxy 5
you will just lose to b6 so you might
have to spend a tempo here on something
like g76 which loses material as well if
you want like g695 you've already lost a
pawn and now for example now the
position that we have on the board let's
uh update that one because it doesn't
have that much time
the edges do say it's time it's time to
play knight b3 it just just the night is
so terrible get that nice the night is
so terrible you can give up a pawn for
it and because of the structure on the
king side specifically
yeah i think i think it makes a lot of
sense knight b3 if you take twice you
already have to defend upon c3 somehow
it's not easy to push it to c forever
and i can start thinking of king f6 king
g5 king h4
and black is active white simply is not
right
yeah f6 played first i don't think that
spoils anything at all i also asked jan
what his intentions are with this
exactly yeah
yeah i mean
that's a very good point there is
counter play on offer
on the king side and i think this is
where you begin to realize why it was
perhaps so you know beloved of the
computer to try and exploit the
immediate concrete details of the
position while the king was still on g8
uh because now i mean it looks
unbelievably passive like the knight on
a5
will only have a move even when white
allows it right the rook.6 is also
completely preoccupied by defending uh
uh the entire structure but it's only
two pieces left on the board pawns are
being uh traded away
and uh defensive resources are
quite
check quite high check i mean
check no
g6 i guess
g6 probably right because king g5 f4
maybe or four or f3 yeah four then i can
maybe go back to g6 but i think f3 might
be kind of unfortunate that's clever
actually yeah king g5 maybe you just go
f3 yeah
a huge time discrepancy here as well
remember that it's only a 10 second
increment no longer 30 like they did in
the classical
time for
f three probably time for f3 anyway you
know yeah but it it feels like maybe now
black can start just solving issues
concretely king g6 yeah you play king
six you have three i think i'm probably
playing knight b3 i'm trying to get
those knights off the board i don't lose
material tactically i think because they
have check i have genji so nice uh
so i i will be in time to trade a pair
of knights and i think the moment that
that pair of knights comes off the board
black just instantly generates a lot and
a lot of counterplay so once again we're
expecting f2f
after the move king g6 our light board
for some reason hasn't been updated our
analysis board is actually live he has
after king g6 he's just returned his
rook to ba he's going to be eight
stopping knight b3 he's basically saying
uh i currently have no easy way to go in
so i will prevent you from making an
immediate drop perhaps by getting the
knights off and maybe a sign that
already is interested in the position
not playing king f6 immediately
all right goes forward yeah g5 why not
no why not there's
like i said i thought that i i was
thinking king h5 actually
and i was thinking that would force rook
f8 and i would go back to it and also
yeah specifically
against the move that he unplayed you
you probably feel slightly safer with
the king on h5 because ef knight f3 you
don't like that it's a check besides it
might not be you know all that lethal
but you don't like that it's a check you
would like to have a tempo to do
something in that position
for knight b3 maybe it's the time for an
ip3 the engines are adamant that you are
okay if you don't play knight b3 but
this is the best time to do so and
knight played zero zero according to the
engine yeah
because we always have this counter
plane now
uh in any straight rook ending and
suddenly if you if you visualize that
rook ending like the rook on b3 suddenly
i mean the
turns have tabled there for sure the
rook on six is just so much more active
than the turns are tabled correct i mean
you pulled that cheapo on me before yeah
and i missed it but that's pretty good
rook takes b3 we can go king h4 straight
away we can also perhaps invest the
tempo in rook c4 but why but yeah but we
don't need to yeah you can imagine this
is going to get vacuumed yeah
yeah there's counter play now yeah
things will things will start coming off
the board for sure and yeah they can't
play with the outside passer is always
going to uh uh
should always carry us home
uh as black here you can play like fe4
if before before the immediate rook
before
but i think black doesn't even need to
care about the e4 pawn at all just trade
i think we take on h3 we give up on e4
and then we go h5 exactly and we start
pushing exactly and uh
you're not even down upon
fe fe we're not taking on c3 at least
not not not the majority why not because
rookie six and then maybe you have to
think
i think i see absolutely no reason to
allow roxy rookie six uh attacking both
h6 and a6
by the way uh yeah all of this on the
board if you play rookie six here i
think the reason he is thinking is that
a5 rugby six exists
otherwise i think rookie six would just
be a very very clean solution but the
five rook b6 is a bit annoying true uh
so
uh yeah he's trying to to figure out a
clean way not to allow that i'm pretty
sure most sensible decisions here hold
but i very much like the idea of taking
on h3 waiting for take c4 and spending
one more tempo on h6 h5
and now we are ready to take on c3 if we
want next move because rookie six will
not attack two of our and uh we say that
rookie six player but i think he's very
concrete because rookie six a5 he does
have rook e3 yeah he does have rookie
five or perhaps h6 h5 yeah it's just
important not to blunder the h6 pawn
like king takes h3 uh rook b6 would be
lost yeah young goes uh c4
king h3 c5 but yeah that should not be
much of anything at all
well
yeah it's time to
rookie six is a very very strange choice
here i guess it's still enough sex is uh
the issue yeah like why are we why are
we allowing this this is uh i wouldn't
have i wouldn't have been allowing this
yeah rugby six it's still gonna be a
draw young will drive the king away from
i guess you go g4 f5 right you go
uh because if you go g3 and the rouge
six pushes it away no g4 most people
play it it has to be g4 five and then
you go ruxin to check and rook eight so
and with the white king uh cut off on
the back rank that there's
like experience tells us that these
positions are pretty much never ever won
yeah and like you say roxy took one rook
a2 and then we start planning king ji
for king of three no this is this is
hopeless this isn't yes this is just a
drawing it's just a draw so you have to
count this as a bit of a miss by jan but
probably not not as much as we expected
like he was better after f3 instead of
h3 but i gotta tell you guys uh for a
15-minute game this is one of the best
15-minute games in a very
i want to say nervy uh yeah uh play-off
i mean
playoffs are always
butterflies in the tummy type of thing
but the singfill cup in particular
it's just such a big money event it's
such a big
tournament uh and i think
the rest are showing that improvement
right from the same game that he played
against nepo where he lost because he
was passive right and in this one he
just understood what he needed is the
activity he needed to activate his king
activate his rook no matter if he loses
a pawn
and this is just much better defense
absolutely i think e3 perfectly time
peter yeah exactly i think uh
i mean i'm sure he knew the concept of
active defense existed even before that
game he lost
uh in the single there are a few books
yeah but he's recommended but still you
know it's an attractive narrative to say
that we are watching somebody learn in
real time right
it's i'm sure it's not entirely
incorrect actually um even if uh
you you have to assume he probably heard
about that yeah that idea previously he
did play with g6 check this is just the
drone exactly
that little extra nuance to drive the
black king back but uh
unfortunately for yan it's not going to
uh
be enough no i don't think it'd be no i
cannot possibly look behind
the a pawn
yeah on the topic of big money events i
i would like to be more sure about these
things but i'm pretty sure that the
money is actually shared
so what they're playing for is pride and
potentially
and we're being told that there's an
extra 10k for the winners so it's not
entirely
yeah i think they added that to this
year's gct regulations yeah
a lot of people complain why are we
playing playoff for no extra money but
yeah extra 10k actually add it to the
price below if you want to look at it
that way yeah that is actually quite
quite impressive
from the organizers of the gct because
they did they didn't need to do that but
they clearly they clearly understand
correctly how
how these things well these things work
and
i think it's now time to play rook f6
yes make sure i don't see king of three
king takes e3 land on the board yes and
he's done that
as napo
and then king king of three and like
okay allerson doesn't want to win the
pawn back but uh because i think you
thinking of three was actually winning
the pawn back very comfortably so he
didn't even have to uh uh think about
this very much but obviously like rooker
five king of six you're like we're not
losing this vision with black no
no we are not losing this position with
black yeah or rook d5 check and then
something and it doesn't really matter
that much
and it was king d king c2 or king d2
king digital but now he gave a check in
the kingdom
d4 here be fancy
rook d4 is actually pretty cute yeah
yeah but uh le reza instead just says uh
yeah and okay rook d4 is basically a
draw for
oh yeah i think i think ken plays d45
next move operation no no oh oh oh
[Music]
oh asserting dominance right
very important to assert dominance i i
remember talking such as it is yeah with
viktor korchnoy and uh he was explaining
that in the world championship match in
1978 he was furious with karpov for
forcing this kind of a
stalemate uh he really took it somehow
as a personal insult asserting dominance
as you said no i think i think you know
these two are get along fine enough yes
this will be seen as a
uh as a
no not a slight on a resistance person
right
pretty much
good game uh alejandro for our first
playoff i
i mean hats off to both players i didn't
see too many inaccuracies and all of
that i think alireza survived a little
bit of a scare after the move d5 i feel
that d5 came on the board and he felt
pressured he just sat there he thought
for like seven minutes right on a 15
minute game and he said all right this
is my best this is my solution i don't
see any real problems with it or at
least this is the least problems that i
can get into and he he did pretty well i
mean let's go all the way back
to
this position with d5
and we're thinking about a lot of
different things how to allow white to
take on b6 because there's no longer a
good way to avoid it and after check
here here he actually found the best way
to do it cb2 take directly and just play
rook d8 hold on to the pawn
and it's a scary position at the
beginning but i think he understood that
there were chances and the moment that
he was giving a chance to activate his
king he took it pretty good game here
for both sides nepal putting a little
bit of pressure but far from enough
and how how good or bad would it have
been if f2 f3 close to one
close to one uh instead of playing h3 in
this position you could start with h3
it's okay but it does think that after
king f7 you it is the time to play the
move f3 in this position it's point
eight actually and if you take take then
it gives white an advantage here you can
start thinking about it apparently the
knight on a5 is just too bad but as
usual the engine just wants to go into
this position down a pawn knight xb3
pawn takes is not as clean as the one
that we saw in the game why because in
the one that we saw in the game this
king has this little diagonal f6 g5 h4
in which to penetrate white's position
and create counter play you don't have
it here i haven't weakened my structure
this way but still this is very
difficult to make progress with because
this powerful pawn on e4 it kind of
binds the king the spawn on c3 needs
defense so still a lot of work to do for
white to try to even think of converting
an advantage
nice thank you for that uh yeah and it's
interesting how i think uh all three of
us and also jan very clearly in the game
we were all
instantly drawn to the idea of softening
the structure up with h3 and g4 right
and it's just a mistake because it gives
black additional counter play which you
have to kind of foresee way in advance
and in the rapid game i think you sort
of fall back on the on the patterns that
you've learned and the idea of
undermining the base of the chain there
it just comes so naturally right that
i think jan played h3 like within 20
seconds right you don't hit the head of
the chain yeah in this case the e4 pawn
would move f3 whereas exactly whereas
the idea of trading
what we assume will be a target
eventually right just is very very
difficult to assess if you're playing
quickly i i'm sure if jan paused there
he would have realized that at least the
idea exists and perhaps is very strong
but he knew what he's doing cannot be
much wrong because it's always a very
decent idea to try and uh to try and
undermine the structure by uh by sort of
challenging it challenging it from the
side but as it turns out it does give
black in this particular case it does
give black a very very crucial couple of
temperatures to start counter play and
from that moment on alireza just
defended very very cleanly
nice well now ali reza
the white pieces yeah i mean
it's a story in some way it's not an
armageddon game but i mean in some ways
and it will start very very soon it
starts in two minutes yes yeah and uh
this is very good by the organizers
again because i've seen uh
these types of games like
for some reason like the organizers
insist that i don't know 15 minutes need
to pass between the games regulations
yeah and uh my good there are very very
few things you really hate more than
having to uh wait and wait
to stew between games yes because like
most of the preparation probably all of
the preparation has already been done
sometimes like if it's a long match
people do maybe like to get out of the
supervised area make a quick i don't
know
send a quick message or a fault or a
second
if you need to fix something in your
repertoire but that would apply to let's
say a four game match where you played
one white one exactly you have some new
info right and then perhaps something
needs fixing
but for a two game match what you want
is to sit back down and play exactly and
this is what we're seeing and they are
off c4 another six g3 as a white player
in this position the move i hated the
most was always c7 c6
but jan says yeah let's play the english
if you want to play the english let's
play the english and he's playing the
slides with c6 i mean we can't forget
his big vector against dingler n yeah
absolutely uh and alireza actually said
that he was not supposed to play knight
c2 there he said and this indicates that
his preparation was cd5 e3 which is
definitely a move
i'm pretty sure he will just play e3
here now yeah it's actually he pretty
much flat out stated that knight c2 was
a mistake yes which is not a mistake
it's not a mistake it's not a mistake he
just didn't remember which move he was
supposed to yeah right i mean
e2e3 was the way i always approach these
positions because the strangest thing is
that everyone ever liked
my opponent playing for the queen h5
bishop h3 ideas yeah there it is yeah
and uh
he's corrected himself and this was a
very very easy guess on our part because
we did listen to the interview
he was extremely open about these things
perhaps he didn't expect that he will
need to play this position again right
yeah but somebody that might not have
seen the interview is
it's possible yeah it's possible but i
mean as a black player jan obviously he
you know the english is so much a
central part of so many people's
repertoires these days
that i'm sure that he's looked at this
very seriously possibly from both sides
even because he also plays the english
quite a bit and e3 will not be a
surprise there's like 100 games from
this position
break it down for us uh black's idea is
to maintain his pawn on e3 yeah white's
idea is just equally as obvious he tends
to break it down yeah i i think well i
mean the first order of business is not
blundering the e4 pawn right right so
it's very important if you do nothing
here something like quincy three
ninety three queen c2 will just win the
pawn on precisely so so yeah your first
idea here is just to make sure that
white can't attack it and pick it up you
can play you can make it
happen by playing bishop c5 or by yeah
removing the queen from the uh d5 square
or making the move that jan has just
made which is quite true this book do
you know this move well i mean it's
clearly been played by strong players as
i can see on my screen but it's a rare
move
it's a rare move it's been played
boris played it yeah instead of uh
knight actually no again it was played
against boris yeah
by a very good player yeah is bishop c5
is the main move i think bishop c5 and
queen e5 are basically it's an equal
split and you get this position anyway
this is this is the main position
whichever move order you get it by and
then you can play the immediate g3 i
think i pretty much always played two to
d3 there after bishop c5 and queen e5
because you
you don't really have to worry about
bishop takes d4 very much but there's
other moves as well yeah yeah there are
some games of mine there oh very good as
you can see
okay but uh knight a6
um
yeah it's a good it's a good surprise
yeah the sideline variation has stopped
i'll erase it for just a moment because
he yeah g3 seems very very logical
because in this position uh it actually
feels it might be useful for for us to
keep the
knight the pin for the time being
because it stops black from going e4
takes g3 if you start with with knight
c3 queen e5
uh i'm pretty sure that uh yeah d3 here
will be met by it xd3 or maybe yeah i
mean apparently not apparently bishop g4
is also a move but
and there's no more pin yeah so
keeping the pin alive makes i think a
very
large amount of sense now that you
mentioned it bishop g4 maybe not here
though because d takes c4 is playable
right queen a5 jack yeah
bishop d2 exists right
[Laughter]
yes because i was trying to get some uh
quick earned castles on the queen side
for black going and
it would be a donny brook move d2 d3 uh
how you like them uh
apple's alejandro man i'm way too tired
to think i'm gonna ask the engine
that's the engine what is this s plus
seven knight a6 is kind of a bad move
really kind of a bad move
i think i think it's likely to be some
kind of a semi-bluff i'm pretty sure he
is not living here if he is out living
here you know some kind of due diligence
has been failed and so
somewhere along the way i would have to
say because these things will commence
immediately at 7 pm sharp uh i mean this
is a reasonably central position it's
been it's been played a
decent amount of time by strong players
so yeah i get the feeling that perhaps
he just did not repeat this particular
opening today
and he is now trying to remember
what the file says
and what do you reckon the file does say
because i couldn't easily see from
the uh
body posture that
jan is actually in the tank now
yeah it's it's unclear i mean
you're sort of drawn to the idea of
trying to develop as quickly as possible
something bishop before check and then
perhaps
after you play bishop d2 which is what i
assume you play right
maybe even castling and and going for
something quick while knight c3 is not
really hitting us as strongly a vision
before check played we expect bishop d2
and then you have to think okay
um you have to think there's also some
kind of fancy stuff like you can play
knight c5 here but by the way he takes
e4 my database just went
like this would be a novel position it's
hard to believe that
appears to be a novelty which is very
surprising really that's the most
natural move yeah well knight c3 has
been played the two times that the this
position has been reached one is golf
and against inarchive
which was won by black
and then i assume in an open tournament
sakura played jan timon
uh
in 2005.
yeah ic3 it's weird to me that bishop
detour has not been tried because i
think
i think you know the very very
obvious and kind of ambitious idea of
lending the full night on c3 the night
that cannot be traded exactly and then
collecting more more you know dividends
in the center seems to be very logical
so yeah also just looking at the
structure quickly for just a second i
mean it's easy for me to make a flippant
decision that my bishop on c1 is no
great shake yes
let me get rid of that
bishop let me put my knight on c3 and
really tickle that e4 pawn
bishop bishop pardon me uh since bishop
b4 check has been played
now
ali reza is taking his time yeah
i think as i said like i i would be
shocked if this wasn't uh at some point
looked looked at by team nepo and he has
some idea about this
and perhaps actually follow the
resolutions came as a bit of a surprise
because of just how rare it is and once
again
i
i was
i witnessed a conversation between chess
players during this tournament which
went sort of along the lines of they
were discussing a specific opening idea
and one of them says so we found this
idea and
it's a good try for one game and the
other person says so what's the initial
evaluation
and uh
the first person says uh
like 0.8 when in fact the ig is from the
black side and black does equalize long
term and the first person says that's a
very good find
and this is actually an interesting the
reason i'm i'm telling this seemingly
pointless story is that you value the
ideas which are initially rejected by
the computer
much more than the ideas which are shown
by every single engine right because
those might not get analyzed by your
opposition
by your opponent yeah because if you
find an idea which is playable but which
is like the machine instantly screams do
not do this right
it is sort of you know it's worth its
weight in weight and gold in some cases
because people will miss it uh that was
precisely uh
in an interview that fabi was having
with aleandra that was precisely a point
that uh that fabi was mentioned that he
oftentimes explores
uh
moves that are second and third and even
not really on the horizon because
they're likely to be overlooked exactly
as i was convinced by convincing myself
that bishop d2 was the best move knight
c3 appeared right
yeah right right on
target and uh knight c5 as well yeah
honestly if this is the best black has
i am really really not in love with it
at all why
because i think after gta xe4 you will
have to take okay he hasn't played he
hasn't played detective he's played c3
c4 which i think is
um
maybe not the most useful yeah i would
have taken only four i wouldn't have
bothered with this honestly uh even
though there is i think only a very
specific reason why it's not as good i
think and i glanced at the engine now i
know the answer you you specifically
have to play queen h5 here nothing else
equalizer but finished wifi which is a
good move yeah it's a very good move you
don't you want to both take on h5 and
take on e4 at the same time but you
can't you lots of chasse you only do one
at a time and he hasn't found it it's
not it's not very obvious yeah it's not
it takes d3 check
yeah yeah so he's played 25 and now we
we have a very good version of sort of
the kind of position i wanted to get
which is we'll we'll take only four
black will probably take the with the c
knight we will castle
i don't think we have to worry about c65
too much currently because even knight
b5 i think can play is playable okay
castles castles here and we want to play
queen c2 bishop b2 and then push for f3
and d4 and we if we get all that i mean
obviously you've got your two bishops
and you're a happy camper yeah but we
are you know we have a very very large
advantage if we get all of that in
and what do we have on the board
currently yeah so far so far take stakes
has been played castle castles hasn't
been played yet i still expect it to
happen but it hasn't been played yet
well queen e5 is such an annoying move i
think you have to count no you you do
castle here yeah yeah we're not worried
about c5
uh too much
i think we worry about c5 at all i'm
almost wondering if i can just make a
random movement
then black will castle like the issue
the issue with the quiet move there is
that black will castle and claim that
this is a gained tempo that
a lot of the players in our audience
would see that c5 move as uh threatening
peter yeah i mean knight b5 is is one
thing i mean even knight b3 probably
preserves some advantage but i'm kind of
kind of like knight b3 actually
yeah
and uh our plans should be our plans
they stay the same
like if an iv3 is the best uh is the
best we have there i'm sort of drawn to
that idea because then at least i can
i can visualize
perhaps some pressure against the pawn
on c4 like if i can play b6 really
quickly and once you drive my knight
away from e4
i can drop it back to d6 and attack the
pawn on c6 01 c4 i suspect it doesn't
work yeah after 93 specific yeah yeah e3
let's say i go castles yep uh queen c2
yeah
either b6 or bishop butch b5 also is not
that bad very sensitive
[Music]
okay and
believe it or not c5 is actually the
novelty of the game
somehow they transposed or they this is
the this is the czech ray uh checkered
semen game
perhaps through the transposition yeah
with c5 so c5 on the board yeah not b5
is playable but the engines do suggest
the knight belongs on b3 which is kind
of interesting to me because it really
did not seem like a you know anywhere
near the best square
but you do have to play very quickly
after knight b3 so might be through n
knight b5 is fine strategically it's
that you do take on a1
yeah
knight 27 check king e7 the ender just
says do your worst your knight is going
to get trapped
so
nightmare be five yeah if you don't take
on a1 you're probably worse but you can
take only one play knight is seven king
is seven and i guess if you take only
eight queen e5 becomes a topic like all
kinds of things become a topic that's
not yeah you start uh wondering how do i
rescue that fella not such a an oil
painting an oil painting but yeah maybe
three castles already played and i think
here white really needs to play very
very energetically because if you get if
you give black the kind of the setup
that we're discussing maybe it's not so
horrible but you can maybe even play
like very very energetically like a
three here
um let me just uh
promote this variation
to my
i think we start with f3 in this
position yeah this is what this is what
i meant yeah i don't see why not i just
don't see why not
use the time that you have because queen
c2 bishop f5 comes so naturally
thank you
yeah i think the point is that we can
actually play c3 f396 e4 just ignoring
uh
just ignoring the the c4 pawn for the
time being completely okay three three
ninety six
e4
knight takes c4 and i don't know uh
bishop f4 or f4 e5 i think i have 45 45
in particular
very attractive i always like those
storms with uh just just trying to kind
of sweep sweep black off the board
yeah
and
yeah i think if you give black like a
tempo or i mean definitely two but maybe
even a good tempo somewhere here and
black gets to play either bish p6 or
bishop five queen e6 and kind of
restructures the pieces a little bit it
becomes very playable for black because
knife b3 is very very restricted if
black let's say supports dependency 5 by
b7 b6 and nothing bad happens to them in
the center for a short while yeah then
what is your knight doing on b3 then
black is just fine so you have to be you
have to be fast here i i liked your idea
of queen c2 and bishop b2 just putting
the bishop but then then you will have
to spend some more time be solving those
issues right like if we if we continue
that like quincy two bishop five okay
bishop b2 i have to play queen e6
exactly f3 found yeah three found you
know and here i mean that takes g3 is a
threat if you have to spend a tempo on
something here i didn't know if i could
or could not get away with f3 i have 93
there in the end but the f3 has already
been played so we can probably uh
discard that or ignore this very safely
a 15 move knight d63 played 96 players
kind of expect the pawn sacrifice with
e4 don't think it's forced yeah
but it is difficult to hold on to that
c4 pawn now that queen c3 is on top
yeah well
for example if i go queen e2 i think
just yeah and there it is yeah f3 96e4
played pi over alireza very well found
you don't have a choice here because
bishop f4 is winning a piece yeah if you
don't play that takes d4 your position
is just straight up busted because yeah
before is a bit too much of a threat
here to do anything else so you must
just close your eyes and take
okay uh everything else is just lost and
then we go which before i think we maybe
completely
i apologize this is where you like that
for yeah just opened the bishop on g2
right yeah and this is such a typical um
idea and for example the king's gambit
sorry the king's camera the king's
indian fiance variation
where you just give up a pawn right but
as long as you can get f4e5 in and the
knight on f6 lacks a logical square
you might be doomed for a very passive
dispense for a long time it's it's just
not going to be fun and in fact you know
the one pawn that we gave up i think the
pawn on c5 and in a lot of cases you
just collected like for example you go
knight d7 let's just put something like
queen e2 uh queen e2 or even queen c2 i
don't know yeah and let's imagine that
you don't have knight d b6 so you remove
the knight
you just go bishop e3 you start
attacking the pawn and then rook ac1 and
how you how are you going to hold it
with your bishop c8 and rook on a8 and
all of your pieces away from from the
game you can also just go for straight
up mating attacks with like if you can
get a five of six in somewhere it will
just basically be made
queen
e7
that's a straight-up piece blunder guys
e5 e5
e5
ah he saw it he already saw it
he's going for it yeah i mean boom
oh and that was a little curse i'm
seeming in russian yeah oh oh yeah this
might be a short game that was it yeah
young i don't i don't see young playing
this out maybe even necessarily he is
just
he's going to swear himself for a while
and this this might be it honestly and i
mean the position is completely lost
it's not like he is losing too much ev
here by
not playing it out yeah the position is
completely and utterly lost in a kind of
a funny way i was thinking of
knight takes c4 f4 and sacrificing a
piece on e5 you know
to avoid
what we're about to see but in that case
i would have gotten an extra pawn for
what's trouble
[Laughter]
you
know
would still be quite bad but would be
maybe slightly better than this yeah
exactly so yeah i don't know i mean
really nobody will blame jan if he if he
just packs it in here you're not really
saving very many of this you know you
play knight takes c4 you have queen f6
and uh in that position like if you give
black a tempo to play b7 b6 and then
bishop b6 it becomes a game that you can
actually play and particularly this was
a blitz game in a rapid game you're not
very hopeful but yeah queen d5 just wins
the opponent five for
really i think i'm playing this out
right i think i am interested in trying
to see how good the snake is i make a
poor move
something like this yeah
yeah if you can consolidate and not i
think i think we're playing this two
pawns i think we're playing this but
unfortunately five like yes you win a
couple of tempe you can chase the queen
around you play bishop e6 you play rook
ac8 it goes back to f2
and then you realize that so you
have one pawn for a piece and
the pieces are a bit passive but who
cares there is a bit it's one more
they're they're not even that passive i
think you're being helpful you play
queen d4 you start chasing your opponent
around
yeah no i mean
we're only really discussing this
position seriously because there's
nothing else to discuss right yeah it's
it's a full extra piece and a game
between two stronger and much yeah he
might play something but we think
resigning is actually favorite yeah i
think it's i think it's fine to just
just stop here but on the other hand you
know no games have ever been saved by
resigning and blah blah so and you know
nobody knows that lesson better than i
do
you have a bit of a reputation here for
now uphold death to uphold and by
advocating for resigning here questions
uh
maybe or something i don't know
it's hard to create tactics when you're
down a piece yeah
yeah this is not this is not good
something i discovered more or less once
i
cross the 1400 barrier
slightly call you out on that statement
though because i'm pretty sure you never
crossed the 1400 barrier i did my first
rating really yes
and the northwest in the barbaric
northwest we had the
northwest uh
ratings and uh eventually we became all
uscf membership so i i i sort of assumed
that the
those ratings just didn't exist but yeah
yeah obviously
my understanding of the the uscf ratings
uh let's promote something incomplete
yeah so 25 from bhp six queen takes e5
he's played h6 h7 h6 there
um
to stop bishop g5 for now
h oops h7h
you know a move with you know you can
describe it by you know this is a move
as good as any other in this position
like it's it's no better or worse than
any other move you can make yeah for
opening up the bishop yeah it's just
it's just a piece yeah there's really
not very much to talk about in this
position exactly f4 yeah i love truth
being told i kind of like queen d4 well
he's creating a threat of f5 that's he
will go to g4 if the queen is chased
away like he's doing this yes he's
optimizing yes min moxing exactly f4
threatening f5 any
any uh attacks on the queen queen d4
yeah this is uh
this is over
it is done gee guys i don't know but
this might be a good time to reflect
deep reflections about
who predictions
ah
very good i don't want to miss an
opportunity
right
uh okay so just remind everybody i
played r8 i'm not trying to figure out
why he's not losing more material to f45
yes
he kind of is yeah he is the evaluation
actually doesn't change that much
because for a computer one piece two
piece what's the difference
yeah but f5 b6 yeah
yeah queen c7 yeah
queen yeah seven in particular yeah
queen c7 it's time to pack it in that
that that will be two pieces it's it's a
bit much yeah obviously like most moves
here which don't blunder a piece in one
move are still good but yeah why not
play a five or you can go back to your
roots and go queen takes a7 yes
yes queen takes a7 very nice yeah all
bishop takes b7 yeah i don't know which
one they prefer
all of those two very very sensible
decisions as well i have a sec yeah i
like
f5 no f5 is good yeah why why how can i
not like f5
yeah
no it's it's just like we
we're not really you know having fun at
jan's expense very much but
i mean if we are forced to discuss the
position seriously some kind of some
amount of girlish giggling is i think
allow very very justified right right
time effect well time factor i mean uh
no no not for already no no
yeah
we're just waiting uh waiting for this
too running for the handshake to
conclude yeah
a bit of a letdown for jan i mean uh
probably he came
into these playoffs feeling like i don't
mind losing but i want to really play
two hard good games
and he just didn't not in this one you
just yeah you just hate losing like this
it's not that right i mean you you as
the saint louis wrapping and blitz
showed you can definitely lose a game of
rapid chest toilet resume yes he's
proven that yeah it is something that
can definitely happen to people but yeah
losing a game like this for uh for a
very very strong player such as i mean
undoubtedly is
is just not a very pleasant sensation
you kind of pegged it yourself though
there uh earlier peter when you said you
know
call the guys that this seems to be a
kind of a hole in the uh prep knight a6
didn't pan out he didn't i really
thought there will be
you know some kind of a more fleshed out
idea like
what he did was he played knight h6 and
he he tried justifying it by normal
means what i expected was knight a6 and
then some kind of a gambit to follow it
up right uh instead of just accepting a
slightly worse position and trying to
play it uh and yeah if that was the
intention that i really am
not all that impressed with
his prep with this idea yeah
rook c8 and queen f4 yeah instead of
queen of four queen takes a seven was
actually winning a lot of material but
larissa says yeah okay i'm done
calculating let me just uh you know
trade some pieces and wait and if you
don't agree to trade queens then
you've got a big big big
attack going with f6 i think the point
there like
if if we ought to discuss this if you
took on a7 there after rook c8
uh bishop takes a five yeah you can
actually play g3 g4 and there's not a
single check black has so you're
actually winning this bishop
next move yeah because you're
controlling absolutely everything
despite appearances you control every
single square that you need to control
in this position and the bishop doesn't
have any other squares of the queen
takes a7 which is kind of important
because we're taking away the g7 square
but once again yeah not not really all
that crucial to uh to discuss this
right the extra piece speaks
speaks for itself i'm going to stop
saying yeah
[Laughter]
exactly exactly
yeah i'm kind of attracted to the idea
of f6 just to give myself the f5 square
for the knight because bishop a4 is very
likely to be the next move yeah and just
to have a good square for it f5 is a
wonderful square
for
f5 pardon me f5 f6 certainly has
my attention as you said he's just
played bishop before he doesn't really
want to be fancy and bishop before i
guess we just go knight b3 where
we don't have to organize f3 really like
i didn't really like the idea of
bishop a4 moving moving that night away
from its very nice central porch but
nothing is being spoiled by
by doing this of course
uh we have a move after bishop
not yet not yet not just thinking
yeah
one pawn it is just the one form yeah
for a dark squared bishop on f4 and you
were right
bishop c2 played at least jan is playing
quickly here so he is ex you know trying
to exploit
uh or at least you know attempt to drive
drivers to have
actual
low low time on the clock like currently
i mean five and a half minutes here is
again just hard to produce problem
problems for your opponent when you're a
piece down g3 g4 weakens the king side
but not because
yeah and now i think after 95 you can
start really packing it in because white
also gets activity to go with the extra
piece like knight g6 threads rook f2
okay one like the it just plays itself
we've been saying that for a little bit
though
i have and i'm not wrong
[Laughter]
in fact it's becoming more and more
salient with each passing move 95 is
incredibly powerful f6 is also not a
mistake but like it's difficult to make
a mistake
yeah right
really really is kind of difficult to
make a mistake
this is just over
yeah 95. there you go e1
you don't want to play knight d3 because
it simplifies the position yeah but if
you don't it's objectively the best move
yeah but if you don't what are those
pieces on c2 and b2 doing like exactly
so it's bad yeah
there's only so many ways we can say
this is bad
try yeah
riveting guys but
there is really nothing to say in this
position is there it's it's pretty bad
uh something went back to bishop before
it is protecting against knight c6 you
can sort of relate but right i mean we
can start offering more trades like rc1
looks logical just to
continue suggesting that
that one day i might land on the
doorstep there simply just removing
pieces from the board is advantageous
for us here
as the the proud owners of the extra
horse right
more or less the 1500 years the
the accepted formula went ahead in
material trade and trade and trade some
more rook ac one he has been played yeah
jan jan took on c one and there is not
trying to figure out he has to worry
about forks if he takes with the
rook and then f6 93 happens the answer
is no the answer is no but also you can
take with the bishop in four small
trades i assume
that was the reason why i was thinking
about bishop takes just it's all about
the trading game right now just
hacking things off he took with the rook
he did to take with the rokan and there
is just one
trick in the position one thing you
shouldn't do here is play rook c7 just
to play for sort of for the peanut
gallery because then fe five bhp five
rugs you want check and you might
actually regret your life
uh choices becoming a professional chess
player because you didn't just blunder
one piece uh yeah yeah well i mean
bishop of one still exists but yeah
right you should not be doing this but
apart from this like pretty much
anything else will be okay he's gone 96
93 is a response bishop d5 is almost
made but not quite but you can just go
rook c7 yeah the bishop's actually
defended yeah yeah that's
that was a good and he has uh gone rook
c7 and you're right bishop that was it
we have a winner guys we do he has one
at all st louis wrapping on blitz wins
the same field wins the grand chess tour
i don't think this man's ever leaving st
louis
yeah don't don't give i would petition
don't give people ideas right wow uh
what a month it has been for ali reza
our congratulations to him yet again the
winner of the grand chess tour as you've
just so eloquently put it wrap it in
blitz singfield cup grand chester
what's next i mean the guy's not playing
the u.s championship
wow
those are exactly the kinds of ideas i
didn't want you to give people
hi um yeah an extremely impressive
performance by by the young man
decimating the field and the wrapping
them blitz wow and
playing a very very exciting uh
tournament in in the sinkhole cup
starting by losing two toyan round two
and then bouncing back in a very very
impressive fashion winning some very
sharp games he had to run quite well to
win them
i mean
no point sugar coating the truth there
he he did have
suspect positions in a number of those
games but
look look at the crosstable exactly
as the old story goes it doesn't matter
the result is what matters and so that
just kind of like
exhale poof
thank goodness that is over uh
what a member a memorable i was going to
say memoriable
memorable
event it has been the sinkfield cup i
don't know how it's happened but over
the decade or so that it's it's been
played uh we've seen it all from the
streak at the 7-0 bobby magnus carlson
and
all the great players that have played
here but somehow this
this one will kind of
stick in our memories
never disappoints yeah you you you get
you get tremendous tremendous chess you
get a very very uh good interesting
lineups and people play very uh very
exciting chess here and this year is no
exception it will have been you know
somewhat overshadowed by leof boards
yeah
let's honor our participants uh peter
let's start with who unfortunately came
in the bottom and tied for eighth yeah
there we have acharya
very honestly saying you know this is
not great he didn't call it a
catastrophe he was very clear he wanted
to make a statement that this is not a
catastrophe but it's not great of course
exactly a very surprising uh low finish
for mvl
leader comes into this event and uh
clawed his way to third place on the gct
right i think so yeah he did he did uh
levon died for sixth uh uh and earns
uh a bit below twenty thousand dollars
uh dies was for sixth with uh
grand chester
for lavon
yeah uh hans is the story of the
tournament in a way and uh yeah the
second half did not go according to plan
but
[Music]
but the first half was so good
this was pretty good yeah veneers solid
but somehow missing the final touch yeah
could have been on plus three wow
winning the tournament outright fabiano
coming back after not such a good
showing in the earlier events takes
third place takes home forty
our congratulations to fabi
absolutely and he ties it with uh wesley
who was
you have to say one precise calculation
away from winning everything from
winning everything uh yesterday uh will
be disappointed with this result but
still a fantastic consistency in grangia
stores over the years
jan ends up
in second after that rapid game which
was so abruptly lost in one move pretty
much but still a creditable performance
by him he will still be a bit unhappy
about the amount of practice he got in
he wasn't joking and i think he wasn't
wrong either he he played fourth
theoretical draws in a row at some point
goes home 77
500 richer and there we have it the man
who actually did win it all yes
the the 19 year old from france uh
alireza ferrugia is the 20th 22 single
cup champion
right congratulations to the young man
wow
very impressive and uh
once more is with alejandro
there's a what a performance here in the
thai bricks you've won it all in st
louis
anything you want to say to your fans
yeah it feels great um i didn't expect
to be in the thai breaks because jan was
completely winning today against hans so
um it's a miraculous thing that in
canada in the toy breaks so i'm really
happy
that i i was already happy that i had
the chance to play against him and uh
and uh he's obviously very strong player
so
um it's not easy to beat him but yeah i
think i played very well in the toy
breaks tell us a little bit about those
tie breaks we'll just go through a
couple of the moments won't take that
long but here after the move d5 you
spent half the time allotted to you
what were you thinking yeah it's i
completely missed the move after c5 um i
missed d5 so and it's a very important
position because white is getting e4 and
i have to be very concrete otherwise i
get very passive so
i think i i don't know if i found the
correct
way but i think it's it's okay and i
couldn't see how he wants to break
so i was happy with my decision after
all so what were you sure that you had
this draw in the bag
uh no it was very tricky because my
knight is out of the game and yeah
but yeah but i couldn't i never saw
advantage for him but so it's not easy
of course of course in the second game
you play an idea that you wanted to show
in the classical against shaq you came
in you said that you had actually
missed on the move order it didn't seem
like he was prepared yeah he completely
forgot the idea i think
the line is not knight a6 so
but i don't know if i punished it well
but i think it was interesting i
couldn't find a better way so
yeah in general the e3 mo is a good idea
i think and it's the business problem
all right and finally
in this position
yeah
your feelings
when he goes queen e7 yeah
it was shocking yeah because
you you have to think about e5 but okay
he's very tired and he was completely
winning today so he's a bit frustrated
so
it's kind of understandable but yeah you
have to normally see e5 but i think i
have a very promising position
instead of queen e7 but yeah it's a
it's a good gift
yeah it was a very good feeling here you
didn't hesitate you kept your tactical
awareness all throughout extremely sharp
how do you do it how does everybody get
tired but not you
yes today i was lucky i made a quick
draw and he was playing for five hours i
am sure if he had a quick game also he
would have been more sharp and he would
have been sharper and
better simply but
i was lucky that he played a very long
game
so but in general i think everybody
played a decent tournament here okay
some player of course they didn't but
in general everybody was in a great
shape i think and we saw a very high
quality tournament
so
yeah i'm happy with the my play at least
and
we'll see what happens in 960.
960 certainly a different beast you
ready for it yeah it's my first time
playing over the world 960 so
it's a it's a very interesting event of
course i'm looking forward to play gary
and
i have to take revenge because last year
i lost in online against him so
we will see what happens hey guys join
us here with the winner of well
everything here in st louis
yeah congratulations very well really
really congratulations uh uh we'll look
forward to the fisher 960 as well uh ali
raisin
um as we
uh get ready to say our goodbyes first
of all we do want to give a very very
big shout out we make fun of all of the
guys in the truck the whole production
whether it be varugen kevin kevin duggan
everybody we just want to say spectrum
studios
every insult that we've ever delivered
none of that was ever
doubled down
thank you all thank you for that thank
you to the st louis chess club and
scholastic center you guys make coming
in
to the club each and every day a
pleasure thank you thank you thank you
to tyler and finn who keep us on our
toes and tell us two minutes two minutes
two minutes coming to the broadcast to
alejandro yeah no my pleasure you
absolutely mine you guys were great i
always do love doing commentary with
both of you it's been many years that i
do commentary both but it's been a while
since i had the both at the studio in at
the same time
i had a blast i'm exhausted it was a
great tournament
great tournament to be casting so much
drama let's face it that makes it more
fun so much interest let's face it it
makes it so much more fun but it's not
over we have so many tournaments coming
up that it just feels like we're
bleeding right next to the second into
the next one absolutely in fact one more
time let's take a look at the upcoming
events
starting with the ultimate moves that's
the trash talking
uh go get em kind of one day event that
we enjoy here
that will be that will be at uh 1 pm
central starts at 12 50 uh
central uh on uh
what is it uh tuesday
saturday the days of the week are very
difficult it sounds right they all they
all absolutely blend together and then
three days in a row of uh chess chess
nine elects with as alireza uh mentioned
with gary coming in and
joining this field should be an
extremely exciting event
and then uh in october the the us
nationals for for both the the open and
the women's section are going to be
played and let's just save the best for
last peter seriously it's been
absolutely wonderful i love working next
to you for me your calculations your
insights have been terrific so thank you
thank you very much i'm sorry we're
going to be losing you and you'll be a
participant
i liked you uh next to me i suspect so
am i
when we're done with the 960 i will have
wished
that i stayed here
we'll keep the sea warm
we'll see how that goes but yeah it's
been it's been an absolute pleasure uh
and yeah uh thanks for everybody who
makes this possible thanks for everybody
to uh including me in uh in this
and uh really promising to come back
promise to come back in your
in your chair that would be very nice
i'd love to and to each and every one of
you thank you so much for joining our
show we'll see you on the next one
good night everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you